THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE WE ARE
GOING TO START BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE- FOR IN ROOM FOUR FOUR
FOUR WILL THE MEMBERS PLEASE
COME TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM SO
THAT WE CAN REACH QUORUM A GOOD
AFTERNOON AND WELCOME TO OUR
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
FOR TODAY ON. LABOR AND BEFORE
WE GET STARTED I WANT TO WELCOME
OUR NEW COMMITTEE CONSULTANT
PATRICK LEAHY WHO WILL BE A
JOINING US IN THIS IS HIS FIRST
OFFICIAL. BUT IT HEARINGS THE
WELCOME. AT TODAY'S HEARING IS
TAKING PLACE IN ROOM FOR THE
PANELISTS LISTED ON THE AGENDA
ARE APPEARING. VIRTUALLY USING
ONLINE REMOTE PARTICIPATION
TECHNOLOGY. WILL BE ACCEPTING
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF
THIS HEARING BOTH IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND ON THE PHONE. THE PHONE
NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE
DISPLAYED. ON THE SCREEN IF YOU
ARE WATCHING THIS HEARING ONLINE
THE PHONE NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. THE PUBLIC ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FIVE
FOUR FOUR. IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT
NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWO
ZERO NINE NINE AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU. WE
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE
WRITTEN TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
HEARING PLEASE SEND YOUR WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO BUDGET SUB FLOOR.
AT ASM DOT CA DODGY OB. WE WILL
CALL THE ROLL CALL ONCE THE
MEMBERS AT COME TO THE COMMITTEE
ROOM. BEFORE WE START. WE HAVE A
SPECIAL GUEST JOINING US TODAY
TO PROVIDE SOME OPENING REMARKS
ABOUT THE MANY LABOR AND
WORKFORCE. PROPOSALS WE WILL
HEAR TODAY WE ARE JOINED BY
SECRETARY OF THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR AND- WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY SECRETARY SECRETARY
NATALIE. PILOT PALU GI. US
SECRETARY BLUEJAY. YOU JOIN US.
THIS YOUNG. OKAY LET'S MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE CONNECTED. THANK YOU. I MEAN REMARKS. WE CAN HEAR
YOU THANK YOU OKAY WONDERFUL
THANK YOU WELL GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR CARILLO AND MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY TO
DISCUSS THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET FOR THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY
IT IS REALLY AN HONOR OF A
LIFETIME TO BE ABLE TO SERVICE
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST LATINO LABOR
SECRETARY PARTICULARLY AT THIS
CRUCIAL MOMENT IN WHICH THE
STATE'S PANDEMIC RECOVERY IS
TAKING PLACE ALONGSIDE OTHER
SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC SHIFTS
RELATED TO CLIMATE AND HEALTH
CARE. THE BUDGET THAT WILL BE
DISCUSSED FOR TODAY'S REALLY
INTENTIONALLY FOCUSED ON
ENSURING THAT THE LABOR AGENCY
REMAINS WELL POSITIONED TO HELP
EMPLOYERS AND WORKERS MEET THE
NEW DEMANDS CREATED BY THE
INTERSECTION OF THESE ECONOMIC
SHIFTS. I WANT TO RECOGNIZE MY
COLLEAGUES HERE TODAY THEY ARE
THE AGENCY LEADERS WHO REPRESENT
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
SERVE AND SUPPORTS THE
ENFORCEMENT WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND BENEFITS
ADMINISTRATION ECOSYSTEM. THAT
SUPPORTS OUR WORKERS AND
EMPLOYERS. THEIR WORK AND
DEDICATION CANNOT BE OVERSTATED
I AM SO GRATEFUL FOR THEIR
CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO THEIR
CORRECT THEIR TIRELESS WORK BOTH
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC. AND AS
WE ENTER THIS NEW STAGE OF
ECONOMIC GROWTH. WE ALL KNOW
THAT THE WORLD WHEN YOU PART OF
MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY HAS
CHANGED I'D LIKE TO TALK BRIEFLY
ABOUT WHAT IT MEANS FOR OUR WORK
AND OUR MISSION. FIRST WE ARE
AIMING TO ADDRESSING YOU
WORKFORCE DEMANDS IN SECTORS
SUCH AS HEALTH CARE AND ENERGY.
WHILE ALSO FACING UNPRECEDENTED
CHALLENGES RELATED TO HIRING AND
RETENTION. SECOND WHILE WE WORK
CARBON NEUTRALITY AND CLIMATE
JUSTICE FOR COMMUNITIES WE FACE
A SIGNIFICANT RESPONSIBILITY TO
SUPPORT WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS IN
THIS TRANSITION IN INDUSTRIES
AND TO DO SO IN A MANNER THAT
PRESUMES LESS AND LISTENS FOR.
THIRD AS WE TRACK AND FEEL
GRATEFUL FOR ECONOMIC RECOVERY
AND PROMISING FUTURE WE MUST DO
SO WHILE ALSO FOCUSING ON THE
DIFFICULT TRUTHS BUT THE
PANDEMIC ON COVERED. IT IS FACT
THAT PERVASIVE ECONOMIC AND
SOCIAL INJUSTICES CONTINUE TO
EXIST AND HAVE GROWN OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL DECADES. IT IS FACT
THAT THESE INEQUITIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY ADVERSELY AND
DIRECTLY IMPACT OUR COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR WOMEN INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES RURAL COMMUNITIES
AND HEARTBREAKINGLY BUT OFTEN
FOR GARDEN OUR YOUTH. IT IS ALSO
FACT THAT THE DISCONNECTION AND
THE POVERTY THAT INEQUITY
PERPETUATES RESULT IN GROWING
SOCIAL COSTS AND LIMITS HOW
QUICKLY WE CAN RESPOND AND ADAPT
TO THE DEMANDS OF OUR SHIFTING
ECONOMY. THIS BUDGET RECOGNIZES
THE DISTRICTS AND A
RESPONSIBILITY TO RESHAPE AND
REIMAGINE OUR STATE PROGRAMS TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR INVOLVING
ECONOMY WHILE ALSO LIBERATING
OURSELVES FROM THE STUBBORN AND
PERVASIVE INEQUITIES. SPEAKING
OF INEQUITY WE HEAR THE TERM
EQUITY SO MUCH THESE DAYS IN THE
MEDIA IN POLITICS AND ACADEMIA
EVEN IN OUR OWN POLICY AND
OPERATIONAL DISCUSSIONS. BUT THE
GROSS INJUSTICES AND THE COSTS
THAT INEQUITY CREATE WON'T
DISAPPEAR SIMPLY BECAUSE WE WILL
THAT THE TO OR BECAUSE WE PRIDE
OURSELVES ON THE BACK FOR
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THEY EXIST.
AT THE LEVER REGENCYWE AIM TO
COMBAT IN EQUITY BY REMOVING
SYSTEMIC BARRIERS FOR
POPULATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY EXCLUDED FROM OUR
WORKFORCE AND TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES. BY DISRUPTING THE
STATUS QUO READY TO REIMAGINE
AND TEST STRATEGIES THAT CREEK
BROUGHT SYSTEMS CHANGE AND BY
PUSHING FOR SYSTEMS CHANGE WHICH
RECOGNIZES THAT MEETING THE
NEEDS OF THOSE ARTISTS TO START.
AND I WILL REPEAT THAT MEETING
THE NEEDS OF THOSE ARTISTS TO
SERVE IS THE KEY TO SUSTAINABLE
ADOPTABLE AND MEANINGFUL
ECONOMIC TRANSFORMATION. GROWTH
AND PROSPERITY FOR ALL.
INVESTMENTS IN THIS BUDGET AND A
COMMITMENT TO EXECUTING THEM
WITH A FOCUS ON COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIP EMPOWERMENT AND
INNOVATION INTO TO JUST THAT TO
MEET THE DEMANDS OF THE FUTURE
ECONOMY WHILE ALSO LIFTING OF
THOSE DISCONNECTED FROM THE
CURRENT ECONOMY. THE BUDGET ALSO
RECOGNIZES THAT WE CAN'T MAKE
THIS CHANGE ALONE OUR BUSINESSES
ENTREPRENEURS AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS ARE THE PIONEERS
OF ECONOMIC TRANSITIONS THE
MERIT AND REQUIRE SUPPORT TO
SUCCESSFULLY MEET THE DEMANDS OF
PIONEERING INTO OUR FUTURE. SO
HOW DO WE GET THERE. HOW DO
SUPPORT WORKERS BUSINESSES AND
COMMUNITIES DURING THIS
TRANSITION WHILE MEETING NEW
ECONOMIC DEMANDS BREAKING DOWN
BARRIERS AND MODERNIZING THE WAY
WE SERVE CALIFORNIANS. FOR THE
LABOR AGENCY IT'S ABOUT
INTENTIONAL INVESTMENT AND FOCUS
ON THE MOST PRESSING NEEDS THE
BUDGET THAT YOU WILL DISCUSS IN
MORE DETAIL WITH MY COLLEAGUES
HERE TODAY IS DRIVEN BY A FEW
DISTINCT PRIORITIES. NUMBER ONE.
THE UNDENIABLE AND PRESSING
DEMANDS FOR NEW BETTER AND MORE
INCLUSIVE HEALTH CARE JOBS AND
PATHWAYS THAT WILL LEAD TO
IMPROVED AND EQUITABLE HEALTH
OUTCOMES ACROSS THE STATE.
NUMBER TWO WORKFORCE STRATEGIES
AND INNOVATION THAT MEETS OUR
CLIMATE GOALS IN A MANNER THAT
RECOGNIZES THE CHALLENGES FACED
BY TRANSITIONING WORKFORCES AND
THEIR COMMUNITIES. NUMBER THREE
A RENEWED FOCUS ON THE IMMENSE
VALUE OF CALIFORNIA'S IMMIGRANT
WORK FORCE AND THE RECOGNITION
THAT CONNECTING THEM TO THE
EVOLVING ECONOMY REQUIRES
INCREASING ACCESS TO LANGUAGE
AND VOCATIONAL TRAINING THAT
MEETS BOTH THEIR PERSONAL CAREER
TRAJECTORIES AND THEIR EMPLOYERS
MEETS. NUMBER FOUR. CONTINUED
MODERNIZATION OF THE U. R.
SYSTEM TO IMPROVE CLEAN ACCESS
AND EXPERIENCE BOTH WHILE
ASSURING LONG TERM RESILIENCE
AND KEEPING OUR DOORS SHUT TO
FRAUD. AND IT GOES WITHOUT
SAYING AS A FORMER FEDERAL
WORKPLACE INVESTIGATOR THAT A
CONTINUED FOCUS ON PROTECTING
CALIFORNIANS IN THEIR WORKPLACE
IS THE BASIC REQUIREMENT TO
ASSURING THE INCREASE VOICE
SAFETY AND DIGNITY THAT ALL
WORKERS NEED IN ORDER TO SHAPE
THE PERSONAL GROWTH AND
MEANINGFULLY PARTICIPATE IN THE
BROADER ECONOMY. IN CLOSING I
WANT TO REITERATE HOW INNOVATIVE
AND UNPRECEDENTED THIS BUDGET IS
IT INCLUDES ELEMENTS THAT ALLOW
CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE THE HARD
WORK OF RESPONDING TO COATED
WHILE ALSO SENDING A MESSAGE OF
HOPE. ABOUT HOW WE CAN RECOVER
DIFFERENTLY AND BETTER THAN
WE'VE DONE IN THE PAST WITH
INVESTMENTS THAT FOCUS ON
EXPANDING OPPORTUNITY CREATING
BROADER ENTRY INTO THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES AND STRENGTHENING
THE FOUNDATION OF CALIFORNIA'S
WORKFORCE SYSTEM. AS IT LEAVES
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY TOWARD A
SUSTAINABLE FUTURE. I WANT TO
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STUFF
FOR YOUR TIME NOT JUST TODAY BUT
FOR ALL THE WORK YOU DO OUTSIDE
OF HEARINGS LIKE TODAY'S TO SHE
POLICY THAT SYSTEMS CHANGE AND
IMPROVEMENTS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. MY LEADERSHIP TEAM
IS PRESENT AND READY TO ADDRESS
YOUR QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THIS CRUCIAL AND MUCH NEEDED
INVESTMENTS IN OUR WORK FORCE.
OUR WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS WHO
CARRIED CALIFORNIA THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC DESERVE NOTHING LESS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. SECRETARY POLLUTION HI
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
OPENING REMARKS AND I KNOW I
SPEAK FOR THE COMMITTEE AS WELL
AS SEVERAL MEMBERS IN THE
LEGISLATURE WHEN WE- SAY THAT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
AND- A PATHWAY. TO ACCOMPLISH
THE GOALS THAT YOU JUST LAID OUT
WHICH WHICH IS THE VISION THAT
WE ALL SHARE. I THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND WILL BE ON HOLD AS WE
BEGIN OUR FIRST CANNOT BUT FIRST
WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE ROLL
CALL. REALLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KOREA PRESENT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOPER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKING
HERE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER NAZARIAN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS. AND TO
REQUIRE. THANK YOU FOR THAT WE
WILL BEGIN WITH OUR FIRST PANEL
. OUR FIRST ITEM- WILL PROVIDE
AN UPDATE ON ET T. AS WELL AS AN
OVERVIEW OF THE VARIOUS BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSALS TO IMPROVE
OPERATIONS AND ADDRESS FRAUD AT
THE DEPARTMENT. OUR PANELISTS
FOR THIS ITEM INCLUDE OUR NEW
DIRECTOR OF EDIE DEMI'S NANCY
FARIAS- CALEB CORRAL WITH
FINANCE I'M SORRY CHIEF OF
FISCAL PROGRAMS WITH THE DVD
READER GRASS DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY WITH EDT
GRACIOUS STATEMENT A DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE WITH EDT CHRIS COOK
ASSISTANT PROGRAM BUDGET MANAGER
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
ANDREW MARCH PRINCIPLE PROGRAM
BUDGET ANALYST WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE PATRICK
TOPPIN. A FINANCE FINANCE BUDGET
ANALYST WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND CHAST ALAMO THE
PRINCE PRINCIPLE FISCAL AND
POLICY ANALYST WITH THE L. L.
LET'S BEGIN MISS VARIOUS YOU ARE
ON. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE GOOD
AFTERNOON THANKS FOR INVITING US
HERE TODAY TO UPDATE YOU ON THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS. AS
WELL AS SOME OF THE PROGRESS
MADE OF THE LAST FEW MONTHS AT
EDT FOR THE RECORD MY NAME IS
NANCY FERRIS I AM THE DIRECTOR
OF THE- EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT AND WITH ME HERE
TODAY AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
MENTIONS IS- TEAM OF FOLKS AND
WHILE I'M EVER SO GRATEFUL TO
HAVE THIS TEAM WITH ME TODAY I
WOULD BE REMISS IN NOT
ACKNOWLEDGING AND THANKING THE
STAFF WHO ARE NOT WITH ME TODAY.
THOSE ARE DOING THE WORK THAT
DIRECTLY IMPACT CALIFORNIANS
THOSE IN THE CALL CENTER THOSE
PULLING AND ANALYZING DATA SO WE
CAN MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS. AND
THE THOUSANDS OF EMPLOYEES ARE
DEDICATED TO HELPING PEOPLE
NAVIGATE THE COMPLEXITY THAT CAN
BE YOU DD. ESPECIALLY AS WE
CONTINUE THROUGH THESE DIFFICULT
TIMES I THINK THAT IS AN IMMENSE
TEMAS FERRIS I'M SO SORRY BEFORE
YOU CONTINUE- AFTER YOUR
PRESENTATION CAN YOU PLEASE HAVE
YOUR TEAM PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF
THE OPERATION AND FRAUD
PREVENTION RELATED TO THE PC
PIECE OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE. MAY
GO STRAIGHT TO THE QUESTIONS
THAT THEY MAY HAVE MY APOLOGY
STATEMENT TO SAY THAT BEFORE YOU
BEGAN. YEP NO THAT'S FINE WE
HAVE CALEB THAT WILL DO THAT
THANK YOU- I JUST WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR THEIR COMMITMENT TO
CALIFORNIA ALL THE STAFF AT EDT
SO I'M JUST GONNA JUMP RIGHT IN
AND HIGHLIGHTS SOME OF THE
IMPROVEMENTS THAT I'VE MADE OVER
THE LAST FEW MONTHS SO. IN
RESPONSE TO RISING NUMBERS OF
CLAIMANTS WAITING FOR BENEFITS
EARLY LAST YEAR WE LAUNCHED A
NEW PAIN NOW PROGRAM THAT
EXPEDITED OUT THAT TIME
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND PAYMENTS. THESE CLAIMS
WERE PAID IMMEDIATELY AS EDT
CONTINUES ITS WORK TO VERIFY
ELIGIBILITY. WHILE THESE
CLAIMANTS ARE NO LONGER WAITING
FOR PAYMENT THE DEPARTMENTS WORK
TO DETERMINE ELIGIBILITY REMAINS
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND CLAIM IT'S STILL
REQUIRED INTERVIEW TO DETERMINE
ELIGIBILITY EVEN IF THEY ALREADY
RECEIVE THEIR BENEFITS. TO
BETTER MANAGE THE PROCESSING OF
THOSE CLAIMS WE BOOSTED BENDER
STOPPING THANKS TO THIS
COMMITTEE LAST YEAR IN CROSS
TRAINED MORE STAFF TO HANDLE
COMMON ISSUES REQUIRING
INTERVIEWS AND CONTINUE TO SHIP
STOCK. TORT CLAIM DETERMINATION.
WE ARE WORKING TOWARDS A WRITTEN
BY AUSTIN AIR IN FOR A PHONE
CALL INTERVIEW MARC. GAP ELEGY.
IN AND OR TO MAKE A- AND MUCH
LESS TIME. MEANWHILE AS I'M SURE
YOU'VE SEEN ON THE NEWS WE
CONTINUE TO FEND OFF AGGRESSIVE
FRAUD ATTEMPTS FROM THOSE WHO
ATTACKED STATE UNEMPLOYMENT
SYSTEMS. ACROSS THE COUNTRY. OUR
EXPANDED PROTECTION MEASURES
INCLUDING THE CONTRACTS THAT ARE
BEFORE YOU TODAY. BLOCKED OVER A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS IN FRAUD ATTEMPTS IN
TWENTY TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. THE FRAUD PREVENTION
CONTRACTS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ASSIST US IN PAYING
CLAIMS TIMELY. WHILE CONTINUING
TO PREVENT SCAMMERS FROM
INFILTRATING OUR SYSTEMS ON THE
FRONT. I ALSO UNDERSTAND THE
MANY CONCERNS OF THIS COMMITTEE
REGARDING THE OVER PAYMENT
PROCESS AND WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE
FOR THOSE WHO MAY HAVE RECEIVED
PAYMENTS THROUGH NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN. YOUR CONCERNS ARE MY
CONCERNS AND I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
A FEW POINTS ON THIS. CURRENTLY
WE ARE NOT ESTABLISHING OVER
PAYMENTS FOR FEDERAL BENEFITS
AND ONE OF THE REASONS IS
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA ALONG WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
STATE WORKFORCE AGENCIES. NASA
CONTINUES TO LEAD DISCUSSIONS ON
THIS TOPIC WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF LABOR AND CONGRESS. WE SHARE
THE CONCERNS IT'S A CONCERN THAT
CLAIMANTS WHO ARE NON FRAUD NON
FAULT. SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO GET
A BLANKET WAIVER THE DEPARTMENT
OF LABOR AGREED JUST A WEEK OR
SO AGO AND ISSUED NEW GUIDANCE
REGARDING BLANKET WAIVERS. AND
YOU CAN BE SURE THAT WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE FULL ADVANTAGE OF
EVERY OPPORTUNITY THAT WE CAN'T
TO BE FLEXIBLE FOR THIS NON.
FRAUDULENT POPULATION. ONE LAST
UPDATE ON OUR FRAUD PREVENTION
MEASURES IS THE PROGRESS OF
FORMER U. S. ATTORNEY MCGREGOR
SCOTT- EDT HIRED AS BROAD
SPECIAL COUNSEL LAST YEAR. I CAN
PERSONALLY SAY THAT GREG AND HIS
TEAMHAVE HAD A VAST IMPACT AND
IMPACT IN PARSING THROUGH THE
SUSPECTED FRAUD OF TWENTY
TWENTY. ONE OF GREG'S MOST
HELPFUL ACCOMPLISHMENTS HAS BEEN
FACILITATING ACCESS TO EVIDENCE
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT. THIS WAS ONE
OF EDIE'S BIGGEST CHALLENGES WE
JUST DIDN'T HAVE THE RESOURCES
THE RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
FEDERAL STATE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT. TO HELP GET THE
DATA TO THEM QUICKLY WHEN IT WAS
NEEDED. NOW INSTEAD OF A LENGTHY
SUBPOENA PROCESS GREG HAS HELPED
TO FACILITATE ANIMAL YOU PROCESS
WHICH EDT AUTOMATED. AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND HAS NOW HAS AN
IMMEDIATE ACCESS TO THE DATA FOR
THE CASES THAT THEY ARE
INVESTIGATING. WELL CLEARLY LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS STILL IN THE
INVESTIGATION STAGE FOR MANY OF
THESE FRAUD CASES GREG WORKS
WITH ID ME THOMSON REUTERS AND
ACCENTURE. TO LEVERAGE THE FRAUD
ANALYTICS NEEDED TO PROVIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT WITH THE DATA AND
EVIDENCE BUT THE MOST EGREGIOUS
CASES. SO THEY CAN MOVE INTO THE
NEXT COUPLE OF STAGES WHICH IS
OF COURSE PROSECUTION. AND
RESTITUTION TO EDT. THE
RECESSION BECAUSE BY COLD
NINETEEN FOLLOWED ISTORY
PATTERN. UNEMPLOYMENT FROM
RECORD LOWS OF THREE POINT 9% TO
SIXTEEN POINT 4% IN TWO MONTHS
THE FASTEST RISE EVER RECORDED.
EVERY STATE HAS HAD TO RETHINK
WHAT THEY THOUGHT THEY KNEW
ABOUT RECESSION PLANNING. UNDER
S. B. NINETY THREE NINETY BY
SENATOR LEHRER. EDT CRAFTED A
VERY THOROUGH PLAN TO BETTER
PREPARE FOR FUTURE EMERGENCIES
AND ECONOMIC RECESSIONS. I KNEW
PLAN INCLUDES CAREFUL MONITORING
OF MARKET CONDITIONS AND
RIGOROUS WORKLOAD FORECASTING
TIED TO STATE AND NATIONAL
ECONOMIC INDICATORS. WE ARE ALSO
ANALYZING JOB DUTY
CLASSIFICATIONS TO ENSURE STAFF
ARE DEPLOYED AS EFFECTIVELY AS
POSSIBLE. FINALLY EDT WILL
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN SYSTEM
IMPROVEMENTS THAT HELP CUSTOMERS
AVOID THE NEED TO SPEAK WITH EDT
STAFF IN THE FIRST PLACE. A
RECESSION PLAN IS DUE TO THE
LEGISLATURE BY MARCH FIRST AND
WE ARE HAPPY TO PROVIDE ANY
ADDITIONAL BRIEFINGS ON ITS
CONTENT ONCE IT'S TRANSMITTED.
MANY OF THE REFORMS AND BUDGET
REQUESTS THAT ARE BEFORE YOU
TODAY COME FROM THE WELL THOUGHT
OUT RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR AS WELL
AS THE EDT STRIKE TEAM. WE HAVE
MET EVERY DEADLINE STEP BY THE
AUDITOR AND SEVENTEEN OF THE
TWENTY ONE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
COMPLETE EIGHTY ONE PERCENT. THE
REMAINING RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
WELL UNDERWAYINCLUDE HIRING AND
TRAINING THE STAFF TO CARRY OUT
WORKLOAD PLANNING AND
IDENTIFYING AREAS FOR FUTURE
AUTOMATICALLY PROCESSING. THE
EDT STRIKE TEAM RECOMMENDATIONS
OF WHICH THERE WERE ONE HUNDRED
OR SLIGHTLY OVER ONE HUNDRED.
81% COMPLETE INCLUDING 1100% OF
THE SHORT TERM AND NEAR TERM
RECOMMENDATIONS. AS WE HAVE
MENTIONED IN PREVIOUS HEARINGS
AND FULL TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY WE CREATED A
PUBLIC AUDIT PROGRESS REPORT
WEBPAGE. THAT DETAILS THE
DEPARTMENT'S EFFORTS TO COMPLETE
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS AND I HOPE
IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING THAT THE
CONTINUED IMPLEMENTATION. AND
COMPLETION OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS IS A PRIORITY OF
MINE IN MY NEW ROLE AS DIRECTOR
. MANY OF EIGHTY DAYS
SIGNIFICANT TECHNOLOGY
MODERNIZATION PROJECTS WERE
PLANNED BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
BEGAN COPING NINETEEN TESTED-
SYSTEM THING CAPABILITIES TO
THEIR LIMITS AND CAUSE US TO
RETHINK SOME OF OUR APPROACHES.
IN RESPONSE WE REVISE THE
DIRECTION OF OUR TECHNOLOGY
MODERNIZATION WORK. TO BRING
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE SYSTEM
IMPROVEMENTS THAT CAN HANDLE
MORE EXTREME SEARCHES AND CLAIM
ACTIVITY. ADDITIONALLY WE
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN LANGUAGE
AND USABILITY IMPROVEMENTS
CARRYING ON A MISSION TO
PROCLAIM ITS FIRST. DURING THIS
PANDEMIC EDT IS INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY BLANK BRANCH
DELIVERED MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
TECHNOLOGY PROJECT PROJECTS TO
IMPROVE CUSTOMER SERVICE AND
SPEED PAYMENT. IS MUCH MORE WORK
TO COME I LOOK FORWARD TO
UPDATING THE LEGISLATURE AS WE
PROGRESS- PROGRESS OVER THE NEXT
YEAR. AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE WITH
THE TREMENDOUS HELP OF THIS
COMMITTEE ESPECIALLY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHIU CHAIR CARILLO AND OF
COURSE MR TANG AS BUDGET CHAIR.
EDT EXPANDED AND IMPROVED ITS
LANGUAGE ASSISTANCE SERVICES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY. THIS INCLUDES MORE
TRANSLATION INTERPRETER SERVICES
INCLUDING A MULTI LINGUAL ACCESS
PORTAL. AS WE ALL OF WHERE ONE
IN FIVE CALIFORNIANS COMMUNICATE
IN LANGUAGES OTHER THAN ENGLISH
SO IT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO ME
THAT YOU NEED TO CONTINUE THIS
WORK. RECENTLY EDT EXPANDED
TRANSLATION SERVICES AND TRAIN
FRONTLINE STAFF TO CONNECT
CALLERS WITH TRANSLATE
TRANSLATORS EXCUSE ME CAN NOW
ASSISTING HUNDREDS OF LANGUAGES.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO PARTNER WITH
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION AND SUPPORT
AND AS MANY LANGUAGES AS NEEDED
TO INSURE THIS POPULATION IS
WELL SERVED. CONCLUSION THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS FOR
EDT BUILT UPON THE PROGRESS MADE
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND LAYS
THE GROUNDWORK FOR ADDITIONAL
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE YEARS AHEAD
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
APPRECIATE THE PARTNERSHIP WE
HAVE DEVELOPED WITH THE
LEGISLATURE DURING THESE VERY
CHALLENGING. PAST COUPLE OF
YEARS I ESPECIALLY WANT TO THANK
THE STAFF FOR ALL THE INCREDIBLE
WORK THEY'VE DONE TO ASSIST.
CLAIMANTS IN YOUR DISTRICT
OFFICES AND WE STAND READY. TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DIRECTOR. AND A
CONGRATS. ON THE NEW PER AND TO
YOUR HEARING AS DIRECTOR OF EDT.
I WANT TO WELCOME. OUR CHAIR
BUDGET MR TANG FOR JOINING US IN
OUR HEARING TODAY- AND BEFORE WE
GO FOR Q. AND A WITH THE MEMBERS
ON THE DIETS LET'S HEAR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE AS WELL AS
THE ELIO. PERLMAN A FINANCE. A
BETTER TIME AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE HAVE NOTHING FURTHE
TO ADD AT THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT.
HELLO WITH OBSCURE CHANNEL
WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE ON ST STE SIMILARLY WE
HAVE NOTHING OUT OF ON ON THE
OVERVIEW ITEM BUT WILL BE HAPPY
MAKES REMARKS TO THAT SPECIFIC
EASY PIECE IN THE IMAGE ON.
THANK YOU MR ALAMO- NOW GOING
BACK TO EDT CAN YOU IT'S AN
APPROPRIATE TIME THE YOU WANT TO
GO OVER THE BCPS BUDGETING
PROPOSALS. YES AND THEN AFTER WE
WILL OPEN IT UP FOR Q. AND A
WITH THE MEMBERS OF THE DICE.
THANK YOU. YES HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON TRICKERY ON MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD GREAT I AM
GALA HORO CHEAPER THE FISCAL
PROGRAMS DIVISION FOR THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME HERE TODAY TO TALK
ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT'S BUDGET
REQUESTS. THE SIX CALLS
INCLUDING THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
AROUNDIMPROVING OPERATIONS AND
PREVENTING FRAUD INCLUDE A TOTAL
OF ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR
MILLION IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO
MILLION IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR AND SEVENTY SEVEN MILLION
IN TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. THE
FIRST PCP VENDOR SERVICES
REQUEST NINETY SIX POINT THREE
MILLION IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE OF WHICH EIGHTY SIX
MILLION AS GENERAL FUND AND TEN
POINT THREE MILLION IS THE
UNEMPLOYMENT COMPENSATION
DISABILITY FUND BETTER KNOWN AS
THE D. I. FUND AND FORTY FIVE
POINT ONE MILLION IN TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR AND TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE. IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE CONTINUED FUNDING FOR
VENDOR SERVICES CONTRACTS
ENTERED INTO DURING THE CALL THE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC THE USER ARE
ENTERED INTO TO REDUCE FRAUD
MANAGE THE WORKLOAD BACKLOG AND
IMPROVE THE OVERALL CLAIMS
EXPERIENCE FOR CALIFORNIANS
FILING FOR BENEFIT PAYMENTS.
MANY OF THESE PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES WERE PROCURED TO
ADDRESS RECOMMENDATIONS BY THE
EDT STRIKE TEAM AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR THESE
CONTRACTS PROVIDE MISSION
CRITICAL SERVICES SUCH AS PROPER
MENTION DETECTION IDENTITY
MANAGEMENT SECURITY SERVICES
LICENSE MAINTENANCE FOR
LEGISLATIVE TRACKING WORK SHARON
ASK EDT AND DOCUMENT UPLOAD
FUNCTIONALITY. ADDITIONALLY SOME
OF THE CONTRACTS ALSO PROVIDE
CRITICAL FRAUD MITIGATION TOOLS
FOR THE. DISABILITY INSURANCE
PROGRAM AS WELL. THE SECOND
PROPOSED CYBER SECURE RESILIENCE
. REQUEST TEN POINT TWO MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY NINE
POSITIONS IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. AND SIX POINT ONE MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY NINE
POSITIONS IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR AND TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE. IN ORDER TO ASSESS THE
DEPARTMENT WITH FRAUD MITIGATION
AND TO IMPROVE ITS CYBERSECURITY
IN CIVICS OF THIS SUSPICIOUS OF
THAT MONITORING RESPONSE AND
RESILIENCY. THIS PROPOSAL OF THE
FUND THE CYBER SECURITY DIVISION
AT THE DEPARTMENT AUGMENTING
STAFF FOCUSED ON CYBERSECURITY
SUPPORTING FRAUD RELATED
TECHNOLOGIES RISK MANAGEMENT.
AND IMPLEMENTING ADDITIONAL
SECURITY INTERNAL CONTROLS AND
TOOLS. THESE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES WILL ALLOW THE EDT TO
ADDRESS ISSUES AND FINING
STEMMING FROM THE INTERNAL
REVENUE SERVICE UNITED STATES
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR CALIFORNIA'S
STATE AUDITOR. THE CALIFORNIA
CYBER SECURITY INTEGRATION
CENTER THE CALIFORNIA MILITARY
MILITARY DEPARTMENT AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY
. THE THIRD PROPOSAL THE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY BRANCH
RESOURCE ALIGNMENT REQUEST
TWENTY THREE POINT FIVE MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN 232-223-2320
FOUR AND TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE. PER CONTINUED FUNDING OF
THE INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
BRANCHES A HUNDRED TWENTY TO
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE WORKLOAD
POSITIONS TO MAINTAIN SUPPORT
FOR CRITICAL- A CURRENT AND
FUTURE WORKLOAD. IT IS
EXPERIENCED AS YOU ALL KNOW A
SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE IN WORKLOAD
FOR BENEFIT PAYMENTS DURING THE
PANDEMIC AS A RESULT BUSINESS
PROCESS IS NEEDED TO CHANGE
IMMEDIATELY. AND EVD IMPLEMENTED
MANY TECHNOLOGIES AND SECURITY
MEASURES DURING THE PANDEMIC
STAFFING COSTS DURING THE
PANDEMIC WE WILL BE FUNDED BASED
ON THE ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
FUNDING THE EDT RECEIVED.
HOWEVER AS FEDERAL FUNDING
STARTS TO DECREASE EDT CAN NO
LONGER SUSTAIN THE CURRENT I. T.
BE STOPPING LEVELS THAT PROVIDE
CRITICAL SUPPORT FOR THE U. I.
PROGRAM WITHIN EASE EXISTING
BUDGET. REQUESTED FUNDS WILL
SUPPORT AMONG OTHER THINGS
APPLICATION DEVELOPMENT AND
SUPPORT FOR VARIOUS YOU
APPLICATION YOU AYE APPLICATIONS
INTERFACES AND ENVIRONMENTS
TESTING SERVICES FOR NEW SYSTEMS
AND SUBSYSTEMS SUPPORT FOR THE
U. I. VIRTUAL CONTACT CENTER. AN
INTERACTIVE VOICE RESPONSE
SYSTEM RIDE VR AND DATABASE
SERVER ADMINISTRTION. AND DATA
PROCESSING AND ANALYTICS. THE
FOURTH PIECE. WHICH IS THE U. I
COMMAND CENTER AND
IMPLEMENTATION. REQUEST ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND
IN 222-323-2420 FOUR TWENTY FIVE
TO SUPPORT TEN POSITIONS OPERATE
THE U. I. COMMAND CENTER
DIVISION. B. Y. COMMAND CENTERS
PRIMARY FUNCTIONS ARE
FORECASTING FUTURE YOU AYE
WORKLOAD VOLUMES QUALITY
ASSURANCE MANAGEMENT ENHANCING
THE CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE AND
ENSURING ADEQUATE STAFFING
LEVELS WITHIN THE U. I. BRANCH.
THIS PROPOSAL DIRECTLY RELATES
TO STRIKE TEAM AND CALIFORNIA
STATE AUDITOR RECOMMENDATIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH IMPROVING
WORKLOAD MANAGEMENT BY
FORECASTING WORKLOAD VOLUMES AND
IDENTIFYING TRENDS IMPROVING
PERFORMANCE OF THE CONTACT
CENTER AND IMPLEMENTED LONG TERM
SUSTAINABLE SOLUTIONS THE THREE
AREAS ADDRESSED BY THE B. C. P.
INCLUDE THE VIRTUAL CONTACT
CENTER OPERATIONS WORK FOR OP
WORKFORCE OPERATIONS AND
WORKLOAD ANALYSIS AND
FORECASTING. THE FIFTH PROPOSAL
IS FOR- EIGHT LEGISLATIVE BILL
THAT WAS- PASSED LAST YEAR
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE TEN FRAUDULENT
CLAIMS FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
COMPENSATION BENEFITS INMATES.
THAT REQUEST TWO POINT TWO
MILLION EDT CONTINGENT FUND IN.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE NINE
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND HE
CONTINUED FUNDED TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR AND SEVEN HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND EDT CONTINUED
FUND IN TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE.
IN ORDER TO ADMINISTER THE
PROVISIONS OF AB ONE TEN THAT
WAS CHAPTER IN OCTOBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AB ONE TEN REQUIRES
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION IS TO PROVIDE
THE NAMES KNOWN ALIASES
BIRTHDATES SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS AND THE BOOKING DATE AND
OR EXPECTED RELEASE DATE OF
CURRENT INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS. TO THE DEPARTMENT
FOR PURPOSES OF PREVENTING.
PAYMENT ON FRAUDULENT YOU AYE
CLAIMS. AB ONE TEN REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT TO COMPLETE ANY
NECESSARY SYSTEM PROGRAMMING
WILL AUTOMATION TO MONITOR THE
CDC OURS IN MAY DATA AND PREVENT
PAYMENT ARE FRAUDULENT YOU AYE
CLAIMS ON OR BEFORE SEPTEMBER
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE. FEET
EIGHTY ALREADY LEVERAGES THE CDC
OUR DATA TO IDENTIFY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
ATTEMPTING TO FILE OR CERTIFY
FOR YOU I BENEFITS HOWEVER THE
CURRENT PROCESS IS PRIMARILY A
MANUAL- WORKLOAD FOR EIGHTY
STAFF. WITH PASSAGE OF AB ONE
TEN THE DEPARTMENT WOULD
ESTABLISH AN AUTOMATED SYSTEM TO
IDENTIFYING INDIVIDUALS
INCARCERATED STATUS TO PREVENT
AND DETER FRAUD. AND LAST. IS
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE NINETY SEVEN
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BENEFITS
DISQUALIFICATION NOTICE REQUEST
TWO HUNDRED FORTY ONE THOUSAND
HE CONTINUED FUND. IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE IN ORDER TO
ADMINISTER THE PROVISIONS OF AB
THREE NINETY SEVEN THAT WAS ALSO
CHAPTER IN OCTOBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. EXISTING LAW
INDICATES THAT INDIVIDUAL MAY BE
DISQUALIFIED FROM RCEIVING U.
I. BENEFITS IF THEY ARE FOUND TO
HAVE KNOWINGLY PROVIDED FALSE
INFORMATION OR WITHHELD
INFORMATION THE PURSUIT OF THOSE
BENEFITS. PRIOR TO
DISQUALIFICATION AB THREE NINETY
SEVEN REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT TO
PROVIDE NOTICE AND ALLOW
CLAIMING TO DISPUTE THE
POTENTIAL DISQUALIFICATION. THE
CLAIM IS THREE TO TEN DAYS TO
RESPOND TO THE NOTICE AND THE
DEPARTMENT HAS UNTIL SEPTEMBER
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO MAKE
THE NECESSARY FORMS SYSTEM
CHANGES TO COMPLY WITH THE
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THESE REQUESTS
AND MYSELF MY COLLEAGUES ARE
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU FOR THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOLLOWED
BY THE ALEJO. FROM THE FINANCE.
THANK YOU BETTER TOP IN THE
BARBARA FINANCE COMPANY HAD NO
FURTHER COMMENTS AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU. LOL GOOD AFTERNOON
CHANNEL WITH THAT LEGISLATIVE
ANALYSTS OFFICE WE HAVE MARKS
RELATED TO B. C. P. ONE AND THE
SYSTEMATIC GROUPING I'M AT THE
B. C. P. FOR VENDOR SERVICE AS A
LAST WEEK OUR OFFICE PUBLISHED A
REPORT ON IT SIX I'LL BE OF PUT
CONTRACTS IN THE VENDOR SERVICES
BCPL- SIX CONTRACTS. THAT IN OUR
VIEW WORSE- SPECIFIC TO THE
STATE FRAUD SPECIFIC- IN A
REPORT WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ONLY APPROVED ONE OF
THOSE SIX CONTRACTS ON THE
CONTRACT THAT WE RECOMMEND
APPROVING AT THIS POINT IS TO
PREVENT BOT ATTACKS THAT COULD
DISRUPT OR SHUT DOWN EDIE'S
WEBSITE- DURING CRITICAL TIMES
WE ARE RECOGNIZED WITH A HOLDING
ACTION OR REJECTING THE OTHER
FIVE CONTRACTS. AND WOULD MAKE
THIS RECOMMENDATION. FOR THREE
KEY REASONS OUR FIRST. THAT HAS
DEPARTMENT POINTED OUT. ALMOST
ALL OF THE- THAT. DURING THE
PANDEMIC IN THE U. I. PROGRAM
TARGETED A TEMPORARY FEDERAL.
BENEFIT PROGRAMS FOR SELF
EMPLOYED WORKERS. AND DOES
LITTLE PROGRAMS HAVE ENDED THEY
ENDED IN SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SO GOING FORWARD.
THAT RISK EXPOSURE FOR THE STATE
NO LONGER EXISTS. AND CERTAINLY
ON THE OTHER HAND FOR THE
STATE'S SORT OF LONG STANDING
REGULAR YOU AYE PROGRAM UP FRONT
DURING A PANDEMIC APPEARS TO
HAVE BEEN RELATIVELY MINOR. I
MEAN THIS IS A QUICKLY BECAUSE
THE STATE'S PROGRAM HAS. BUILT
IN SAFEGUARDS THAT THE FUNDS
WILL PROGRAM IT DOES NOT HAVE OR
DO NOT HAVE. MADE IT MORE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO FRAUDULENT
ACTIVITY DURING THE PANDEMIC.
AND FINALLY. WE MAKE THIS
RECOMMENDATION BECAUSE MOVING
FORWARD AT THIS TIME WITH
ADDITIONAL LAYERS OF FRAUD
PREVENTION RUNS COUNTER IN OUR
VIEW. TO THE MINISTRATIONS OWN
INSPECTION REPORT
RECOMMENDATIONS. THEREFORE MOVED
APARTMENTS ARE IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION- BY EMPHASIZING FRAUD
ELIMINATION ARE POTENTIALLY AT
THE EXPENSE OF. THE DEPARTMENT
MAKING PROMPT AND
STRAIGHTFORWARD- BENEFIT
PAYMENTS TO A TOWN EMPLOYED
WORKERS AT THE STRIKE TEAM
REPORT RECOMMENDATIONS
SPECIFICALLY THAT I'M POINTING
OUT HERE HAS TO DO WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S REVIEW. ANTI FRAUD
EFFORTS NOT ONLY FOR THEIR
EFFECTIVENESS BUT ALSO TAKING
ACCOUNT THE POTENTIAL ADVERSE
EFFECTS ON LEGITIMATE CLAIMANTS-
AND WE ELEVATE THIS RECORDED AT
THIS TIME BECAUSE WE CAN ARGUE.
ABOUT SEVERAL DEPARTMENTS STEPS
DURING THE PANDEMIC- THAT WERE
WERE ANTI FRAUD IN NATURE HAD
SUBSTANTIAL ADVERSE AFFECT ON
THE JEMAINE CLEMENT'S- AND. AND
MORE WEIGHT- CONSIDERING THE
STRIKE TEAM RECOMMEND THAT
ACTION. ON I DO WANT TO POINT
OUT ONE- ADDITIONAL ELEMENT- OF
ARE NOW- WE RECOMMEND
WITHHOLDING ACTION. SPECIFICALLY
ARE THE CAR. FOR I DO
VERIFICATION WITH THE- THAT THE
CONTRACTOR ID ME. AND THAT'S A
BIT OF CONTEXT- ARE THE STATE
SET UP HIDING ME IN THE SUMMER
OF TWENTY TWENTY- ON THE
RECOMMENDATION OF THE STRIKE
TEAM AND I DO MEAN THAT ABSENCE
CONFIRMS AN APPLICANT IS WHO
THEY SAY THEY ARE BY USING
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE TO MATCH
OUR A VIDEO OR A PHOTO THAT
APPLICANT TAKES TO THE- TYPICAL
DRIVER'S LICENSE THAT THEY- THAT
THEY UPLOAD TO THE WEBSITE-
WE'RE COMMITTING WITHHOLDING
ACTION. GIVEN THAT THAT THE
CRITICAL PERIOD HAS PASSED- SO
THAT THE STATE CAN TEND TO PAUSE
AND CONSIDER- IT'S APPROACHING
WHETHER IT WANTS TO USE FACIAL
RECOGNITION SOFTWARE GOING
FORWARD THE STATE'S YOU I
SYSTEM. M. THESE COMMENTS COME-
WE WANT TO ELEVATE THIS ISSUE.
FOR THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND WE OF
SOME SCHOOL THAT THE COUNTRY HAS
UNDER. WE UNDERSTAND. THAT I DO
NEED OUR HEAD INTO TO AGREE WITH
STATE WITH OTHERS- DEAL WITH A
ONE TWO. FACIAL RECOGNITION
MATCH WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY
COMPARING BEATING. THE PHOTO OR
VIDEO THAT AN APPLICANT SUBMITS
WITH THE DRIVER'S LICENSE THAT
THE APPLICANTS MEZZO ONE TO ONE-
I'M I'M BIG NOW WANTS TO THE
STATE AND TO OTHER CLIENTS I DO
NEED WAS ALSO. PERFORMING WHAT'S
CALLED A ONE TO MANY- MATCH
WHICH IS WHERE- THEY WERE
REVIEWING USING ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE THE PHOTO OR VIDEO
APPLICANTS SUBMITTED AGAINST A
LARGE DATA BANK OF MILLIONS OF
PHOTOS. OF OTHER INDIVIDUALS WHO
APPLIED. FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE NOW. THIS COULD FIGURE
ZERO. I'M HELP REDUCE FRAUD OR
BROWN DURING DURING THE PANDEMIC
BUT BECAUSE THIS WAS PUMPING OUT
TO THIS- THERE ARE SOME SOME
MAJOR RED FLAGS THAT THAT-
PRIVACY EXPERTS HAVE HAVE RAISED
WITH REGARD TO THESE ONE SO MANY
MATCHES AND FOR THAT REASON WE
THINK THE LEGISLATURE MY WANT TO
TAKE SOME TIME NOW TO CONSIDER
THE ROLE OF ID ME OR SIMILAR
TECHNOLOGY FOR THE STATE IN THE
U. I. PROGRAM. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR ALAMO FOR THAT- I HAVE
THE- JUST COMMON IN A QUESTION
RELATED TO THAT AND THEN OPEN IT
UP TO THE MEMBERS. THE L. A.
ALSO SAYS MEN REGARDING THE USE
OF ID ME BRINGS UP. SERIOUS
QUESTIONS OF REGARDING THE
APPLICATION OF A. I. DRIVEN
FACIAL RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY
ITS IMPLICATIONS ON PRIVACY. ITS
POTENTIAL FOR HARMFUL RACIAL
BIAS. AS CALIFORNIA MOVES BEYOND
THE PANDEMIC THE LEGISLATURE
WILL ENGAGE WITH THE EDT.
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE PUBLIC TO
DETERMINE THE BEST APPROACH. TO
QUICKLY AND EFFICIENTLY DELIVER
CRITICAL BENEFITS TO
CALIFORNIANS. WELL SAFEGUARDING
THEIR FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO
PRIVACY TO THAT END. DOES EDT
PLANNING CONTINUING TO USE
FACIAL RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY.
IF THE STATE DECIDES TO MOVE
AWAY FROM FACIAL RECOGNITION
WILL EDT ABLE TO CONTINUE.
AUTOMATING ITS CURRENT PRODUCT
FRAUD PREVENTION MEASURES. MISS
VARIOUS I TURN IT OVER TO YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- IT SO
RECENTLY YOU MAY HAVE SEEN THAT
ID ME AND THE IRS- ENTERED INTO
A CONTRACT AND WE ARE LOOKING AT
THAT CONTRACT AS A GUIDE FOR
WHAT WE WOULD DO AND WHAT
THEY'RE BASICALLY DOING. IS
ALLOWING INDIVIDUALS TO EITHER
UPLOAD A SELFIE AND THEN DELETE
THE SELFIE OR TO GO THROUGH A
TRUSTED REFEREE WHICH IS ON A
LIVE PERSON- YOU KNOW INTO THE
L. A. ALWAYS POINT. YOU KNOW WE
DO WANT TO MAKE DATA DRIVEN
DECISIONS AND RIGHT NOW WE SEE
THE DATA IN OUR DISABILITY
INSURANCE PROGRAM WE SEE THE
ACTUAL FRAUD IN THE PROGRAM. YOU
KNOW WE ALSO GET UPDATES FROM-
FBI FOR EXAMPLE AND THE DARK WEB
YOU KNOW AND IN FACT JUST A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO THE FBI ISSUED
A MEDIA ADVISORY WARNING ABOUT
SCAMMERS EXPLOITING JOB BOARDS
AND SOCIAL MEDIA SITES TO
IMPERSONATE. LEGITIMATE
BUSINESSES IN ORDER TO GET YOU
WHY- SO WE CERTAINLY ARE LOOKING
AT DIFFERENT WAYS TO USE ID NY
WITHOUT FACIAL RECOGNITION AND
WE SEE NO REASON. WHY WE CAN'T
FOLLOW WHAT THE- FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS NOW DOING. THANK
YOU ALL JUST FOLLOW UP WITH THE
A QUICK COMMENT THAT WE SAW IN
THE VARIOUS DIFFERENT HEARING
SOME AT THE PANDEMIC WITH REGARD
TO ID ME AND THE LACK OF ACCESS
TO LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES. THAT
DID NOT GET TO RECEIVE THEIR
BENEFITS ON TIME SIMPLY BECAUSE
THEY DID NOT HAVE A SMARTPHONE
THEY DID NOT HAVE. ACCESS TO
TECHNOLOGY AND SO EVEN BEING
ABLE TO USE AN APPLICATION ON
THE PHONE IS STILL INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT FOR MANY COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE. SO WITH THAT I
WANT TO OPEN IT UP TO THE
MEMBERS OF MISTER LUCKY. YES
CERTAINLY THANK YOU IF I CAN ASK
A REAL QUICKLY WHAT'S THE STATUS
OF EDIE'S FRAUD UNIT THAT WAS TO
BE FULLY STAFFED AS OF NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. DO WE HAVE
pIT'S FULLY STAFFED ACTUALLY
YEAH- MAYBE ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES
CAN. THAT'S CORRECT- HI ANNE
FAULKNER EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT ACTING CHIEF DEPUTY
OF OUR OPERATIONS- THE FRAUD
UNIT THAT WAS RECOMMENDED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR AND OUR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE PROGRAM.
IS NOW CURRENTLY FULLY STAFFED
AND OPERATIONAL AND CAN I ASK
WHAT IS FULLY STAFFED I MEAN.
HOW MANY DO WE HAVE. I CAN
ACTUALLY ANSWER THAT ANYTHING
CUTE HI GUYS HITS STATEN- EDT
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BRANCH
AND WE ACTUALLY STAFF UPDATED
COMPLETE SECTION WITHIN THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE PROGRAM.
THAT INCLUDES- A SECTION MANAGER
TO- MANAGERS TO SPECIFIC UNITS
AND THEN FOUR TO SIX STAFF
WITHIN- THOSE SPECIFIC UNIT SO
THE FRONT SECTION IN OF ITSELF
ENCOMPASSES APPROXIMATELY TWELVE
INDIVIDUALS. THANK A TOUGH JOB.
TWELVE TWELVE PEOPLE. OKAY- I
JUST WONDERED- BECAUSE THAT
OPENS A PANDORA'S BOX FOR A
BUNCH OF QUESTIONS THAT THIS IS
NOT THE PLACE FOR ME TO ASK THEM
BUT- THANK YOU FOR AT LEAST
ANSWERING THAT I GREATLY
APPRECIATE THAT AND IF I CAN ASK
WHAT WHAT IS HE UPDATE TO THE
DEPARTMENT SEPARATE TO CONTACT
CALIFORNIA CLAIMANTS. OF THE P.
U. A. SLASH P. U. E. C. PROGRAM
WITH PROOF OF ELIGIBILITY. DO
YOU HAVE ANY UPDATE ON THE- GOOD
SEVENTY TO EIGHTY I'M IF YOU'RE
SUFFERING TO- SPECIFICALLY THE
SELF EMPLOYMENT IMPLEMENTS
INSTANTIATION THAT WERE REQUIRED
TO- HAVE CONSTITUENTS RESPOND TO
VERIFY THAT THE INFORMATION WHEN
THE INITIALLY FILED ITS TRUE-
AND IN DOING SO THEY NEED TO
PROVIDE AND FURNISH
DOCUMENTATION. IN ORDER TO PROVE
THAT THEIR STATEMENTS WERE TRUE
CORRECT WHAT WE HAVE DONE IS
WE'RE TAKING A PHASED APPROACH
SO THE FIRST PHASE I'M IS AN
ELECTRONIC NOTIFICATION OR LINKS
HAVE BEEN SENT TO CONSTITUENTS
SUCH ADVISE THEM TO UPLOAD THEIR
NECESSARY DOCUMENTS- THAT'S THE
FIRST PHASE SECOND PHASE WILL
INCLUDE ANY OF THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO DID NOT RESPOND TO PHASE
ONE. THEY'LL BE FOLDED INTO
PHASE TWO WITHIN THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS- AND NOTIFIED VIA ANOTHER
LINK AND IN ADDITION TO A MAILED
NOTICE SO THAT THEY CAN RESPOND
IN WHICHEVER AVENUE THAT THE
STATUES. OKAY AND FINALLY MY
LAST QUESTION IS HOW IS YOUR
DEPARTMENT DIFFERENTIATING
BETWEEN ASSISTING THOSE WITH
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP WITH
OVERPAYMENTS AND THOSE ARE
GUILTY OF. FRAUD BECAUSE THEY
ARE VERY DISTINCT. DIFFERENT
POPULAR. I CAN ALSO TAKE THAT
ONE- SO COULD A SECOND WITH EDT
- THERE IS A SPECIFIC SUBSET OF-
KIND OF THE WAY IN WHICH THE
OPERATIONS FUNCTION TO BE ABLE
TO DETERMINE- AND ENSURE THAT
WERE APPROPRIATELY APPLYING THE
BLANKET WAIVER SPECIFICALLY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT RELEASED I'M
DOING WELL RELEASED SEVEN
DIFFERENT WAIVER BLANKET WAIVER
CONSIDERATIONS IN AS WE PROCESS
THE WORKLOADS AND IDENTIFY THAT
THE CONSTITUENT MAY HAVE FALLEN
UNDER AND- A CRITERIA THAT
ALLOWS THEM TO HAVE THEIR
OVERCAME IT WAIVED BECAUSE THE
OVER PAYMENT WAS DUE TO NO FAULT
OF THEIR OWN PERSONAL PRODUCT
AND THERE'S NO FAULT- WE WILL
APPLY THAT. WAVERED THAT LINCOLN
WEAVER TOOK OVER PAYMENT AND
THERE'S NO ACTION THAT'S NEEDED
BY THE CONSTITUENT WE WILL
NOTIFY THEM THAT THEY OVERPAID
THE OVERPAYMENT AMOUNT WE'RE
REQUIRED BY LAW TO NOTICE THEM
HOW MUCH IS GOING TO BE WAIVED
AND THAT THEY'RE THEY HAVE NO
RESPONSIBILITY TO PAY THE
BENEFITS BECAUSE THEY WERE PAID
TO THEM. WITHOUT THEIR FAULTOR
TO NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN- AND IT
WOULD BE AGAINST EQUITY AND GOOD
CONSCIENCE NOW WITH RESPECT TO
FRIDAY SPECIFIC OR THOSE THAT
ARE AT FAULT WE ARE PROCESSING
THOSE- AS- AS- STANDARD BUSINESS
. WHERE WE WOULD ADMINISTRATOR
WE APPLY SPECIFIC THOSE THAT ARE
DETERMINED TO HAVE BEEN- A FALSE
INFORMATION FOR THE PURPOSES OF
OBTAINING UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
BENEFITS. APPLYING A 30% PENALTY
TO THE OVERPAYMENT AND ENSURING
THAT WE CONTINUE THROUGH
COLLECTION PROCESS. OKAY THANK
YOU. IT WILL GO TO MISS WHAT'S
MISTREATING AND MISTER COOPER
THANK YOU THIS QUESTIONS FOR-
MYSTERIOUS- OBVIOUSLY WE'VE BEEN
THROUGH A JOURNEY WITH ATV OVER
THE PAST COUPLE EARS- AND
THERE'S BEEN CHALLENGES- ON YOUR
ALL'S AND OBVIOUSLY NO ONE
ANTICIPATED THIS PANDEMIC BUT-
IT'S BEEN VERY DIFFICULT AS YOU
ALL KNOW IN TERMS OF- US BEING
ABLE TO RESPOND TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS- YOU KNOW MANY OF
WHOM HAVE WAITED. MONTHS AND
MONTHS AND MONTHS FOR PAYMENT-
IN ADDITION THAT OBVIOUSLY THE
FRAUD AND ABUSE HAS BEEN
CHALLENGING- CAN YOU ARTICULATE
HOW EASY WOULD BE PREPARED TO
WITHSTAND ANOTHER SURGE IN YOU I
CLAIM SHOULD THAT HAPPEN OR AN
INCREASE IN AN UNEMPLOYMENT
LEVELS RISE- IN ADDITION TO-
DEALING WITH THAT THE FRAUDULENT
ACTIVITY AS WELL JUST HOW WHAT
IS THE- YOU KNOW AGENCY LEARNED
IN THE LAST COUPLE YEARS THAT
WOULD- HOPEFULLY MITIGATE
AGAINST WHAT HAS TRANSPIRED IN
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS. AND IN
OUR ABILITY TO SERVE OUR
CONSTITUENTS BETTER. YEAH THAT'S
A GREAT QUESTION THANK YOU- I
WILL SAY THAT THAT IS ALL IN OUR
RECESSION PLAN THAT'S COMING OUT
ON MARCH FIRST- THERE IS A- VERY
DETAILED- PIECE OF IT THAT TALKS
ABOUT ANOTHER RECESSION. IT'S
PART OF WHAT THE BCP IS THAT-
GRASSY AT THAT THAT CALEB SPOKE
ABOUT IN YOU WHY. AS FAR AS THE-
ADDING ON TO THE COMMAND CENTER
IN THE FORECASTING. OF THAT SO
WE WILL- WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO
BRIEF THE LEGISLATURE ON- ARE
RECESSION PLANNED IN THE NEXT
WEEK OR SO. IT'S IT WILL IT WILL
BE A BRIEFING IT'S IT'LL BE A
IT'LL BE A WHILE. THEY'LL BE A
LONG BREAK THINGS BUT I'M TRYING
TO SAY BECAUSE IT'S A LONG
PROCESS PLAN. AND THAT WOULD
INCLUDE BOTH- ADDRESSING FOR.
FOLKS TRYING TO GET THEIR
EMPLOYMENT AS WELL AS THE
FRAUDULENT PIECES WHILE. I'M IT
DOES IT DOES INCLUDE IT DOES
INCLUDE BOTH YES I MEAN AS FAR
AS THAT THE FRAUDULENT JEEZ THAT
MEAN THAT'S THAT'S THE PIECE
THAT WE'RE WORKING ON NOW. YOU
KNOW- GOING THROUGH THE- YOU
KNOW SUSPECTED FRAUD THAT WE
HAVE FIGURING OUT- YOU KNOW WE
USED A METHODOLOGY WHEN THE
AUDITOR CAME IN WE USED TO
CERTAIN METHODOLOGY- TO
DETERMINE WHAT WAS SUSPECTED
FRAUD. AND SO NOW WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS GOING THROUGH THAT WITH
THE HELP OF ID NEED THOMSON
REUTERS ACCENTURE. TO DETERMINE
WHAT ACTUALLY WAS FRAUD. AND
WHAT WAS ON TO THE ALEJO'S POINT
POSSIBLY SOMEONE THAT JUST
DIDN'T RESPOND TO EDT AND I
THINK WE WILL HAVE A LOT OF
LESSONS LEARNED FROM THAT AND A
LOT OF- YOU KNOW THERE'S THAT
BILLS THAT WILL SERVE AS A
GUIDE. ON TO HOW WE RESPOND TO
THE. NEXT RECESSION GREAT THANK
YOU. MMHM THANK YOU MISS WATSON
I WOULD NOTE THAT IF WE RECALL
AMID THE PANDEMIC FOLKS WERE
ALSO BEING EVICTED WHICH IS WHY
WE ESTABLISH THE EVICTION
MORATORIUM AS LACK OF WAGES LACK
OF BEING ABLE TO PAY THEIR
TELEPHONE OR CELL PHONE BILLS
ALL OF THAT CONTRIBUTED TO
PERHAPS A NUMBER OF CALIFORNIANS
NOT BEING ABLE TO RETURN A PHONE
CALL OR RETURN A LETTER OR NOT
HAVING ACCESS TO THEIR TO THEIR
BENEFITS. MISTER COOPER. MR KING
FIRSTERS. HELLO OF COURSE OF
MYSTERIOUS- HOW MANY
INVESTIGATIONS OF THE D. OPENED
RELATED TO FRAUDULENT CLAIMS. AB
CURRENTLY HAS ALMOST EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FIFTY INVESTIGATIONS
THIS IS JUST EDT. AND YOU KNOW
HOW MANY BEEN PROSECUTED-
THERE'S BEEN OVER TWO HUNDRED
ARRESTS. I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
HAVE BEEN PROSECUTE- LOOKS LIKE
ABOUT TWENTY OR SO WHAT WERE
THOSE ARRESTS COMMITTED BY EASY
DEAR LOCAL AGENCIES. ARE MADE
EXCUSE ME HOW WE WORK IT USUALLY
IN CONJUNCTION WITH OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT. SELL ONE ARREST IS
MADE INVESTIGATIVE DISCOVERY
BANK ACCOUNT WILL POTENTIALLY
FRAUDULENT FUNDS WHAT HAPPENS TO
THOSE FUNDS. SO THAT WE ARE
WORKING ON THAT CURRENTLY- YOU
KNOW IMEAN THERE IS- WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT RESTITUTION TO EDT
WHICH USUALLY DOESN'T OCCUR
UNTIL AFTER THE PERSON SERVES
THEIR TIME IN PRISON- BUT WE ARE
LOOKING AT- DIFFERENT WAYS TO
COLLECT SOME OF BAD RESTITUTION-
ABOVE AND BEYOND THE
ADMINISTRATIVE WAY THAT WE DO IT
NOW BECAUSE- WE'VE NEVER HAD
THIS KIND OF FRAUD BEFORE SO
WE'VE NEVER HAD TO THINK ABOUT
DOING IT A DIFFERENT WAY- BUT WE
ARE WE DO HAVE A WORKING GROUP
BUT WE'RE WORKING WITH- THE
GREGORY SCOTT. ON FIGURING OUT
HOW TO COLLECT THAT THOSE FUNDS
AS MANY PHONE RECOVERED TODAY. I
YES I BELIEVE THERE HAS BEEN-
FONG COLLECTED. TWO DATES- I
ORDERED BY THE COURT I'M NOT
SURE IF COLLECTED YET ORDERED BY
THE COURT RESTITUTION WHICH
AGAIN USUALLY OCCURS AS YOU KNOW
AFTER- A PRISON SENTENCE OKAY SO
WE MAY NOT SEE THAT FOR A WHILE
AND THERE ACTUALLY IS A BILL
THIS YEAR AB SIXTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN THE TAXPAYER RECOVERY ACT.
WHICH WILL ALLOW FOR SOME REAL
FUN TO BE RECOVERED- THROUGHOUT
THE FORFEITURE BUT ANOTHER
QUESTION ACCORDING TO THE STATE
AUDITOR ET THE PAST PAID OUT
ABOUT A HUNDRED A HUNDRED TEN
MILLION INCARCERATE INDIVIDUALS.
HOW MUCH EASIER COVER FROM THE
FRAUDULENT PAYMENTS TO
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS. SO I
DON'T HAVE THE ANSWER TO THAT
BUT I WILL TELL YOU THAT THE-
THAT WAS STOLEN IDENTITY SO THEY
ARE ASSOCIATED WITH A PERSON IT
COULD BE A PRISONER OR COULD BE
SOMEONE OUTSIDE OF- PRISON
WORKING TOGETHER WITH THE PERSON
WHO IS IN PRISON- I DO KNOW THAT
THERE WERE SEVERAL I THINK
ARREST EVEN JUST LAST WEEK- WORK
IN FACT I THINK IT WAS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THEN THE
DA'S WORKING TOGETHER. THERE IS
ONE FOR TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS I BELIEVE SO THEY ARE
WORKING. WE'RE SORT OF IN THE
INVESTIGATION STAGE RIGHT NOW OF
A LOT OF THESE- FRAUD CASES- SO
I MEAN I ANTICIPATE IN THE NEXT
YOU KNOW AGAIN AFTER. THERE'S
PROSECUTION AND RESTITUTION
AFTER- A PRISON SENTENCE I
EXPECT US TO COLLECT SOME OF
THAT. UNDER MR SCOTT MISTY ON IT
SAID THE MONEY WILL COLLECT WE
PENNIES ON THE DOLLAR REARDING
THAT. AND GOING BACK TO YOUR TO
YOUR UNIT THAT YOU GUYS STOOD UP
WITH YOU YOU CALL THE POLICE.
ESTO IN PLACE FOR THE ENTIRE
STATE. AND NONE OF THOSE
EMPLOYEES AND THAT INVESTIGATIVE
UNIT- SWORN OFFICERS ARE THEY-
ARE THEY ARE POST CERTIFIED IN
THE INVESTIGATIONS UNIT. OKAY
BUT IT BUT IN A SWORN OFFICERS
AND POSTED A FLOOD. BECAUSE
AUTHOR GOTTEN THE FEEL THE NEWS
INVESTIGATIONS AND ACTUALLY MAKE
ARRESTS. I BELIEVE THE ANSWER IS
NO MY CORRECT. I BELIEVE THAT
THEY CAN. I'M NOT SURE IF THEY
CAN ARREST TO BE HONEST MAYBE
SOMEONE ELSE KNOWS THAT. ANSWER. I KNOW THAT THEY YEAH I'M NOT
SURE OKAY I GUESS MY CONCERN IS
IT YOU HAVE SOMEBODY DOING
INVESTIGATION CIVILIAN AND THEN
THEY HAVE TO THE INFORMATION
OVER AND REGURGITATE THAT TO US
ONE OFFICER VERSES IF YOU'RE A
SWORN OFFICER THAT WOULD DO THE
INITIAL INVESTIGATION IT'S A
IT'S A SMOOTH TRANSITION BECAUSE
THERE THERE'S NO MIDDLE MAN OR
GO BETWEEN ON THAT AND THAT
SEEMS TO BE IN A BIG ISSUE SO I
DO HAVE CONCERN WITH THAT AND AS
FAR AS A PRIVACY ISSUE A. I.
DOES HAVE A- A PLACE HERE WE USE
FACIAL RECOGNITION A LOT FOR
DIFFERENT THINGS. AND YOU KNOW
IT IT DOESN'T WORK IT'S ONE OF
THOSE THINGS I THINK WHEN YOU
TAKE THE LEVEL OF FRAUD THAT WAS
COMMITTED HERE IN CALIFORNIA- IT
WAS THE BOARD'S FROM HISTORY OF
THE COUNTRY SO EXTRAORDINARY
TIMES CALL FOR EXTRAORDINARY
MEANS AND FOR YES SOME PEOPLE
IT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS WHERE
THE ADVOCATES OF THE PROPONENTS WOULD SAY. YOU KNOW WE WANT
ANYBODY. BEING OUT OF. BEING
USED. RECOGNITION BUT- THE SAME
TIME YOU HAVE TO PREVENT FRAUD.
WE'RE THINKING NOW WITH TI IN
THIS RAMPANT. ON WILL NOT TOUCH
OUR MAJORITY LEADER AND SHE HAD
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT IT BECAUSE-
SHE'S HEARING FROM HER
CONSTITUENTS THE SAME THING.
THAT APPLY FOR D. EITHER BEING
STUCK IN THE PORTAL. HAVING A
HARD TIME GETTING THROUGH.
THROUGH EDT A LOT OF ISSUES SO.
YOU KNOW AT SOME POINT WE CAN'T
LET THIS REPEAT. TO WHAT
HAPPENED AND I MEAN ALL WE CAN
DO IS GO FORWARD BUT- LIKE I
SAID IT'S EASY MONEY OUT HERE
DOING THIS YOU'RE NOT ROBBING A
BANK IN NOT SELLING DRUGS. THE
PENALTIES ARE VERY LOS CONSIDER
WHITE COLLAR CRIME. THIS IS VERY
ATTRACTIVE FOR. PEOPLE THAT ARE
DOING BAD THINGS TO PARTICIPATE
IS TOUGHER CRIME SO- HOPEFULLY
GET BEHIND I DO THINK ASSET
FORFEITURES AN ISSUE RIGHT NOW.
WE'VE GOT TO CHANGE IT BECAUSE
THESE FOLKS HAVE BOUGHT CARS. IN
BUT A LOT OF ITEMS SO HOPEFULLY
YOU DO YOU DO YOU WILL. WILL BE
SUPPORTIVE OF IT AND THE
ADMINISTRATION BE SUPPORTIVE OF
IT BUT RIGHT NOW- IF WE DO RUN
TO SOME THESE FOLKS. IS A BE
TOUGH GETTING THAT MONEY BACK
WITHOUT A CHANGE IN OUR CURRENT
LOSS I WOULD HOPE THAT- YOU GUYS
WOULD- MENTION THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND- HOPEFULLY
OBTAIN THEIR SUPPORT. SO THANK
YOU. I THINK. ON ON ONE OF MY
RESPONSES- WE DO HAVE ARREST
POWERS. SORTS OR THOSE LIKE I
GUESS THE QUESTION IS. ARE THOSE
TWELVE PEOPLE ALL SWORN OFFICERS
. YEAH I BELIEVE WE HAVE THIRTY
FIVE IN OUR INVESTIGATIONS UNIT
BUT THAT'S THIRTY FIVE CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION INVESTIGATORS
PEACE OFFICER POSITIONS CORRECT
THAT'S STATEWIDE BLEM THIS NEW
TASK FORCE THAT WAS STOOD UP
THOSE ARE THOSE BILLS
PROPOSITIONS OF THOSE CIVILIANS
ARE SWORN OFFICERS. YES THOSE
ARE CIVILIANS THAT'S A
DIFFERENT- THAT'S A DIFFERENCE.
UNITS OKAY. THEY WILL WORK
TOGETHER WITH THE FRONT WITH THE
INVESTIGATIONS DIVISION UNIT BUT
THAT'S- I WANT TO SAY MORE ABOUT
BUT THAT'S ABOUT POLICY THAT
UNIT THAT'S UNDER YOU WHY THAT'S
MORE ABOUT POLICY THAN IT IS
ABOUT- INVESTIGATIONS LIKE
RIGHTS BUT BUT BUT IF THE CRIB
REFORM WRONG MAJORITY THE REST
OF THE BEEN MADE IN CALIFORNIA
FOR- YOU AYE FRAUD. HAVE BEEN
THROUGH LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES LOCAL POLICE AND
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT CORRECT.
IT'S CORRECT WE DO WORK WITH
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT. OKAY
THANK YOU. THANK THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- IT'S JUST A QUESTION TO-
DIRECTOR FOR AREA SIR I'M GONNA
SNEEZE. OKAY MAYBE NOT. IT IT
SEEMS LIKE YOU'VE MADE- GREAT
PROGRESS ON THE BACKLOG SO
THAT'S WONDERFUL CAN YOU JUST
WALK US THROUGH- AS SORT OF-
WHAT DO YOU ATTRIBUTE THAT TO.
I'M I'M GOING TO DEFER TO GRESTY
ON SOME OF THOSE BUT I WILL SAY
THAT YOU KNOW THE- THE BACKLOG
THAT WE SAW. YOU KNOW AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC WAS
OBVIOUSLY DUE TO THE HUGE SPIKE
IN- CLAIMS AND OF COURSE THE NEW
CORPORATE THE NEW- FEDERAL
PROGRAMS. AND WITHOUT THE
FEDERAL PROGRAMS YOU KNOW THAT
NUMBER OBVIOUSLY IT GOES DOWN
SO- THERE'S ALSO AS I MENTIONED
IN MY OPENING- THE I. T.
DIVISION AT U. D. D. STOOD UP
OVER TWO HUNDRED. I. T. PROJECTS
THAT HELPED CLAIMANTS GET PAID
FASTER YOU KNOW AS WE GO THROUGH
THE PANDEMIC AND WE- YOU KNOW
LOOK AT LESSONS LEARNED WHAT YOU
KNOW WHAT WENT RIGHT WHAT WENT
WRONG AND WE'RE STILL IN THE
MIDDLE OF THAT THERE'S NO
QUESTION ABOUT IT BUT- YOU KNOW
WE DO. I WOULD SAY IT'S A IT'S
A- IT'S A CANCELLATION OF. ALL
OF THE DEPARTMENTS WORKING
TOGETHER. YOU KNOW US BOUNCING
IDEAS OFF OF OFF OF WHAT YOU
KNOW THE DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS
IN OUR I. T. BRANCH YOU KNOW
REALLY. BUSTIN OUT TWO HUNDRED-
I. T. PROJECTS TO HELP THE
CLAIMANTS FASTER. GUNS THAT
BELONGED TO MY NEXT QUESTION YOU
SORT OF A LITTLE TOO SO WHAT
WERE YOUR LESSONS LEARNED TO
THIS POINT I KNOW YOU'RE STILL.
IN THE PROCESS OF- FINALIZING
YOUR REPORT. YEAH I MEAN I THINK
THAT THE RECESSION PLAN WILL BE
IS WAS I OPENING TO ME- YOU KNOW
I THINK THAT- YOU KNOW BEING
ABLE TO HIT IT AND YOU KNOW OF
COURSE WITH THE- BEING ABLE TO
PICK IT QUICKLY. IT'S OBVIOUSLY
A LESSON THAT WE LEARNED AND WE
COULDN'T HAVE IT QUICKLY BACK
WHEN THE PANDEMIC STARTED- I
THINK YOU KNOW WITH THE I. T.
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE AND THE I.
T. SYSTEM THAT WE WILL HAVE. I
THINK THAT THAT WILL BE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE IN BEING ABLE TO PAY
THAT- YOU KNOW WE WORK WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON GUIDANCE I
MEAN WE'RE NOT WORK WE ARE NOT
ALL WE CAN'T ALWAYS MAKE THE
CHANGES THAT WE WANT TO MAKE-
YOU KNOW BECAUSE THERE IS
FEDERAL GUIDANCE THAT WE HAVE TO
ABIDE BY. BUT I WOULD SAY THAT-
YOU KNOW THE RECESSION PLAN IS
SOMETHING THAT. WE'RE GONNA USE
AS OUR GUIDE AND BIBLE YOU KNOW
FOR THE NEXT RECESSION. IT IS A
SEPARATE FROM I. T. WHAT ELSE
WOULD YOU SAY- DISORGANIZATION
LEE HE HAS HAVE YOU CHANGED TO
HELP YOU. PEOPLE TO PEOPLE MORE
NIMBLE AND RESPONSIVE. I THINK
SOME OF OUR POLICIES SOME OF OUR
INTERNAL POLICIES I MEAN WE'RE
DEAL WELL DOES GIVE US A LITTLE
BIT OF THE WAY SO TO SPEAK YOU
KNOW AND LIKE THE OVERPAYMENT
AREA AND SOME WAIVERS YOU KNOW I
MEAN WHEN WE CAN DO THAT. AND WE
CAN DO THAT AND WE CAN AUTOMATE
THAT THEN THAT HELPS TO SPEED UP
EVERYTHING ELSE I MEAN IN A
NUTSHELL I WOULD SAY THAT'S
PROBABLY THE BIGGEST THING THAT
WE HAVE DONE I MEAN WE ARE VERY
YOU KNOW WE ARE CLAIMANT FOCUSED
AT EDT AND WE ARE- ALWAYS
WILLING TO- LOOK AT THINGS A
DIFFERENT WAY- AND SO I THINK
THAT THAT HAS HELPED US OR THE
TEAM. YOU KNOW IS RELATIVELY NEW
OVER THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS
AND I THINK THAT ON THAT HAS
BEEN SUPER HELPFUL AS WELL.
LOOKING AT THINGS A DIFFERENT
WAY. GREAT AND THEN GO BACK TO
FRAUD ON A NUMBER OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE. COVER THIS
AREA- IN TERMS OF. FRAUD MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THE LARGE BALK
OF THE FRAUD WAS INTHE- IN THE
FEDERAL PROGRAMS AT THE PEW A
PROGRAM AND I. AM LOOKING ON THE
OTHER ACKERMAN. THE MY
UNDERSTANDING IT WAS- I DON'T
KNOW THE PERCENTAGE BUT- WAS A
9080% OF THE POPULATION IN THOSE
AREAS. 97% YEAH. SO IS YOUR- AT
YOUR NEXT AND I SENSED- FOR
PROPER NONDESCRIPT ASSISTANT BY
MY COLLEAGUES- BUT IS YOUR- THE
WAY YOU'RE SETTING UP YOUR
ORGANIZATION IS THE IS THE
MINDSET. WELL THE ROAD THERE
WASN'T AS MUCH FRONT IN THE
TRADITIONAL YOU ARE PROGRAM. SO
THEREFORE YOU KNOW WE SET UP
THIS UNITEL COMMITTEE- WITH.
TRADITIONAL YOU ARE. FRAUD BUT-
I GUESS WHAT WE YOU DO. IF YOU
HAD- IMPLEMENT ANOTHER KIND OF
FEDERAL PROGRAM- YOU KNOW VERY
VERY QUICKLY I GUESS THAT'S THE
QUESTION BECAUSE THAT SEEMS TO
BE WORTH A WORTH A LARGE BLOCK
OF THE FRAUD OCCURRED. SO THAT
THAT'S ACTUALLY A GREAT QUESTION
AND YOU KNOW I MEAN AGAIN AND- I
KNOW THAT I DO NEED YOU KNOW WAS
THE TOPIC- YOU KNOW OF THE
BEGINNING OF THAT THE HEARING.
AND YOU KNOW THERE ARE DIFFERENT
LEVELS AND DIFFERENT THINGS THAT
WE CAN DO AS FAR AS- FRAUD
DETECTION GOES- I WOULD SAY YOU
KNOW TO THE L. A.'S ELLIE OWES
POINTS ABOUT THE FRAUD CULTURE
AND SORT OF THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE-
RUNNING COUNTER TO WHAT THE
STRIKE TEAM SAID. I MEAN I THINK
I RE READ THE THIRD STRIKE TEAM
RECOMMENDATION OVER THE WEEKEND
IT ACTUALLY DROPPED FOUR DAYS
BEFORE I STARTED AYE DVD- BUT
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT PART OF IT
IS THAT YOU KNOW YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT PEOPLE RIGHT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE WORKERS THAT
YOU THE AND THE MANUAL PROCESS
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS
CULTURE FRAUD. YOU KNOW WHICH I
WHICH I IMAGINE IS ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY THEY SUGGESTED THAT
WE USE A VENDOR YOU KNOW THAT
MET THE FEDERAL STANDARD- IT
TAKES THE MANUAL PROCESS OUT OF
IT AND IT'S SORT OF ELIMINATES
THE FRONT CULTURE. I MEAN INTO
YOUR QUESTION I THINK YOU KNOW
WE ARE I THINK WE'RE UNDER
ESTIMATING. YOU KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY
ON YOU KNOW REGARDING THE
IDENTITY THEFT THAT WENT ON AND. QUITE FRANKLY CONTINUES TO GO
ON. ALTHOUGH EVERY PERSON I KNOW
HAS HAD SORT OF SCAM STEPS. TO
THEM DURING THE PANDEMIC EDT ARE
NOT YOU KNOW OR KNEW SOMEONE
THAT DID. AND I THINK THAT
SAYING THAT THE FRONT IS OVER
NOW THAT WE NO LONGER HAVE. ANY
A FEDERAL PROGRAM LIKE POOL I
THINK THAT'S A LITTLE BIT
DANGEROUS YOU KNOW- I DON'T
THINK THAT WE HAVE- WE ARE
PRIORITIZING FRAUD AT THE
EXPENSE OF. PROMPT AND STRAIGHT
FORWARD PAYMENTS I THINK FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE YOU KNOW WE
WOULD SAY IT'S THE OPPOSITE WE
WOULD SAY THE LESS FRAUD AND
IDENTITY THEFT THAT OCCURS. ON
THE FRONT END THE QUICKER WE CAN
GET. YOU KNOW PEOPLE KATE- YOU
KNOW SO I THINK THAT IT'S YOU
KNOW WE WOULD HAVE TO PAY FOR IT
AGAIN I WOULD IMAGINE IF WE HAD
ANOTHER FEDERAL. PROGRAM ONE
THING THAT YOU KNOW WE HAVE
LESSONS LEARNED AND I'M CERTAIN
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOES
AS WELL BECAUSE THEY ALSO.
CHANGED SOME OF THEIR- GUIDANCE
AS YOU KNOW WE JUST TALKED ABOUT
SEIZE JUST YOU KNOW OF A FEW
MINUTES AGO. AND THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS NOT IN THE
FIRST PROGRAM BUT WAS IN THE
SECOND PROGRAM YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
HAVE TO SUBSTANTIATE- EUROPOL
EMPLOYMENT YOU KNOW FOR FEDERAL
BENEFITS STONE. I THINK THAT-
YOU KNOW I THINK WE COULD PICK
IT I THINK I THINK THAT THAT'S
NOW THERE'S THE TECHNOLOGY IS
OUT THERE AND ORDERED AND WE CAN
GET IT. IF WE NEED TO. WE JUST
PIGGY BACKING OFF THE QUESTIONS
FROM TO MY COLLEAGUES EARLIER.
THEN DO YOU HAVE. THE PROPER
STAFFING TO DO WITH- POTENTIAL
FRAUDULENT CLAIMS- AS YOU
DESCRIBE THIS IS- IDENTITY THEFT
IS BECOMING MORE MORE PREVALENT
NOT LAST. SO THE QUESTION IS
THAT IS YOUR- IS YOUR STAFFING
ADEQUATE FOR THE MOMENT
ADDITIONAL STAFFING ADEQUATE FOR
THE FUTURE. SO I WOULD SAY YES
TO THAT AND I WOULD I WOULD SAY
WHICH IS WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY-
YOU KNOW IS TO TALK ABOUT THAT
THE PC PIECE THAT WE HAVE
BECAUSE THEY ARE VERY
INSTRUMENTAL YOU KNOW I THINK ME
IS ON THE FRONT END. ALSO THE
BACK AND TOM SOME WRITERS ON THE
FRONT END ALSO ON THE BACK AND
WHEN I SAY THAT I NEED ON THE
FRONT END THEY PREVENT FRAUD
FROM OCCURRING YOU KNOW AND THEN
ON THE BACK AND THEY ACTUALLY
HELP WITH THE ANALYSIS THE FRAUD
ANALYTICS THAT I TALKED ABOUT
THAT- MCGREGOR IS WORKING ON-
WITH ACCENTURE AS WELL- YOU KNOW
TO HELP US PARTS THROUGH. THE
DATA SO THOSE ARE IT. YOU KNOW
THOSE THOSE OF THE TOOLS THAT
WE'RE USING NOW AND THERE ARE
TOOLS YOU KNOW WE THEY THEY ARE
OUR CONTRACTOR AND WE CAN USE
THEM AS NEEDED AND AS THE
SITUATION DICTATES. GOTTA BE
JUST BASED ON THE BCPS YOU
SUBMIT IT LOOKS LIKE. YOU YOUR
DEPARTMENTS LOOKING AT. I. TS
90% OF THE SOLUTIONS THAT. ARE
FOR CARE I MEAN JUST BASED ON.
WHAT YOU'RE SUBMITTED DOLLARS.
YES I'M SURE THAT'S PROBABLY
RIGHT. I MEAN I THINK IS A BIG
COMPONENT BECAUSE WE WANT TO
AUTOMATE. YOU KNOW GETTING
PEOPLE PAID AND THAT OBVIOUSLY
AUTOMATION MEANS FASTER. AND I
GUESS THE CONCERN I JUST IN MY
CONCERN I DON'T DISAGREE WITH
YOU I THINK I T. IS A IS A HUGE
ANSWER HARM IT'S JUST THE
ABILITY FOR THE STATE OR EVEN
THE DEPARTMENT TO BE ABLE TO-
PULL OFF THE- THE I. T.
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE NEED WE
KNOW IT NEEDS OF THE STATE JUST
HAS A POOR TRACK RECORD IN TERMS
OF ITS ABILITY TO. UPGRADE ITS
IT SYSTEM SO COULD YOU. COULD
YOU THINK WE WILL HAVE A LOT OF
HELP- WITH CDT. AND ARE THE
LEGISLATURE I THINK THAT IF WE
WERE YOU KNOW WORKING TOGETHER I
THINK THAT. WE CAN DEFINITELY
HAVE A SUCCESSFUL PROJECT
THERE'S NO QUESTION IN MY MIND.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE IT. IN. THANK YOU-
MISTER TANK MISTER NAZARIAN TO
HAVE COMMON. I HAVE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS SO MAYBE I'LL WAIT
UNTIL THE SPECIFIC ISSUES ARE
BEING BROUGHT UP- I CAN START
NOW AS WELL IF YOU'D LIKE WHICH
SPECIFIC ISSUES. I WON I HAD
SOME. WELL FIRST SO FOR ITEM
NUMBER ONE FUNDED PCPS- BUT ALSO
ON JUST SOME GENERAL QUESTIONS
ON THE APPEAL WAY DOCUMENTATION
AND- AND- CONSTITUENT BASED
ISSUES. OF PROCESS IF IT'S
RELATED TO ISSUE ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU. IF YOU NEED A
COUPLE MOMENTS- LET ME JUST SAY
ONE THING PLEASE RELATED TO THE
B. ISSUE OF FRAUD- TECHNOLOGY IS
SOMETHING AS SIMPLE AS A FLYER
MADE OUT OF PAPER LEFTON
SOMEONE'S CAR AND I'LL GIVE A
VERY BRIEF EXAMPLE AND MY
DISTRICT IN THE OMMUNITY OF
THESE LOS ANGELES WHICH IS A
COMMUNITY THAT IS. BELOW THE
NATIONAL POVERTY LINE AND HAS
BEEN SEVERELY IMPACTED BY
MICHAEL THAT THE PANDEMIC AND AS
WELL AS UNDER COUNT FOR THE
CENSUS ALL OF WHICH IS RELATED-
SEVERAL CONSTITUENTS CALLED MY
OFFICE BECAUSE THEY HAD RECEIVED
A FLYER ON THEIR CAR. SAYING
THAT THEY NEEDED TO CONTACT.
SOMEONE WHO THEY COULD PAY TO
RUN THEIR EDT QUESTIONS. AT
WHICH OF COURSE CREATE AND IT
WAS A FLYER IN SPANISH WHICH WE
HAVE A COPY OF. AND SO I BRING
THAT TO YOUR ATTENTION A
DIRECTOR FARIAS BECAUSE MANY
COMMUNITIES IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES LACK OF ACCESS AS I
MENTIONED LANGUAGE BARRIERS.
IT'S VERY EASY TO BE IN A
POSITION OF I NEED HELP AND SO
I'M GOING TO PAY THIS PERSON TO
HELP ME WITH EDT. NOT KNOWING
THAT THEY ARE- AND THEN
ENDANGERING THEIR OWN PRIVACY.
AND POSSIBLY. EVEN PUTTING
THEMSELVES IN A POSITION OF
FRAUD WHICH WE HAVE SEEN AND SO.
UP THE ABILITY FOR US IN OUR IN
OUR DISTRICT OFFIE TO BE ABLE
TO COMMUNICATE AMID A PANDEMIC.
THAT NO ONE SHOULD BE CHARGING
YOU TO FILE YOUR EDT CLAIMS- AND
THAT OUR OFFICES ARE THERE TO
HELP WAS PART OF A LARGE.
OUTRAGE THAT WE NEEDED TO DO TO
NON ENGLISH SPEAKING COMMUNITIES
SO THAT THEY ARE ALSO HELPED AND
SECURE AND I KNOW THAT. WHICH
ACCESS HAS BEEN A PART OF THE
CONVERSATION AND SO WHILE WE
WORK ON HIGHER END TECHNOLOGY
SMARTPHONES ID ME ALL OF THOSE
THINGS. ON THE GROUND EVERY DAY
PEOPLE JUST SIMPLY NEED HELP AND
IF SOMEONE WERE TO SAY HERE I'LL
PAY YOU TO OR PAY ME TO FILE
YOUR EDT CLAIM. WHILE YOU'RE
STRUGGLING TO. YOU KNOW PAY THE
BILLS AND FIND A JOB AND- ALSO
YOU KNOW HAVE KIDS AT HOME WHO
ARE STUDYING. AT HOME AND ALL OF
THE THINGS THAT WE SAW HIM AT
THE PANDEMIC. THESE ARE ALL JUST
EVERYDAY THINGS THAT PEOPLE
EXPERIENCE AND SO I HOPE THAT'S
ON YOUR RADAR AS WELL JUST
WANTED TO MAKE THAT COMMENT THAT
SOMETHING AS SIMPLE A A FLYER
ON A PAPER ON YOUR CAR.
WINDSHIELD CAN CREATE A LOT OF.
A PROBLEMS LOCALLY FOR A FAMILY.
MISTER THIRTY PRE. THANK YOU
MANAGER DIRECTOR VARIOUS NICE TO
SEE YOU NOT NOT SURE IF I SHOULD
CONGRATULATE YOU OR OR- JUST
WISH YOU BEST SUCCESS AS AS YOU
ARE MAKING YOUR EFFORTS GOING
THROUGH ALL OF THIS PROCESS BUT-
NONETHELESS GREAT TO SEE YOU
AGAIN AND I APPRECIATE THE
CONSISTENCY THAT YOU'VE
PROVIDED- OVER THE COURSE OF THE
LAST THE YEAR AT LEAST- FIRST I
WANT TO START BY. ASKING
SOMETHING ABOUT SOME OF THE BCPS
THAT ARE INCLUDED- AND YOU KNOW.
THE IDEA AROUND THE FACT THAT
CALIFORNIA IS BUYING POWER WAS
ONE OF THE REASONS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
ENTERED. INTO AN ENTERPRISE
CONTRACT- WITH MICROSOFT FOR
OFFICETHREE SIXTY FIVE IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. OUR BUYING
POWER WAS SUPPOSED TO- TRANSLATE
TO COST SAVINGS. SO AND THERE
ARE MULTIPLE BCPS NOW FOR
DEPARTMENTS TO PAY FOR THEIR
MICROSOFT THREE SIXTY FIVE AND
THESE BCPS NOTE THAT. THEY ARE
TO COVER THE INCREASED COST OF
MOVING TO A STATE BY CONTRACT
FOR MICROSOFT AND USER LICENSING
AGREEMENT. SO ONE- DID THE
ENTERPRISE CONTRACT NOT
TRANSLATE TO COST SAVINGS BUT
ACTUALLY TO INCREASE COSTS. I AM
GOING TO HAVE TO DEFERRED TO ONE
OF MY COLLEAGUES ON THAT
QUESTION. BUT AFTERNOON I READ I
GOT ET US DEFENSE FOR MAKING
OFFICER SO BEFORE. CURRENTLY ET
DE MICROSOFT LICESING IS BASED
ON A PER USAGE- FIVE INSTEAD OF
AN ENTERPRISE AGREEMENT AND SO-
PDD LAST- UPGRADED THEIR
SOFTWARE WAY BACK IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN I BELIEVE ARE TWENTY
THIRTEEN WHEN I WENT WHEN THERE
WAS FUNDING AVAILABLE SO THERE
WAS NOT A CONSISTENT FUNDING FOR
MICROSOFT LICENSING THE REASON
FOR THE REQUEST IS NOW. WE'RE
GONNA HAVE A CONTINUOUS-
SUBSCRIPTION LICENSES FOR OFFICE
THREE SIXTY FIVE. RIGHT BUT BUT
AGAIN THE QUESTION IS THAT IT
WAS MANT TO. BRING ABOUT COST
SAVINGS- BUT BUT BUT THIS IS
THIS IS INCREASING I UNDERSTAND
THE NUMBER OF USERS THE NUMBER
OF YEARS IT WILL BE DOING
BUSINESS WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS A PHENOMENAL
OPPORTUNITY. AND ITS ADVANTAGES
TO ANYONE WHO IS GOING TO BE
ABLE TO BE IN A POSITION. TO
RECEIVE THE ENTIRETY OF THE
BUSINESS BUT AT THE SAME TIME
WE'RE INSURING THAT WE'RE
PROTECTING THE STATE'S. ASSETS
BY NEGOTIATING THE BEST DEAL
POSSIBLE FOR US. SO YEAH THERE
THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN A COST
SAVINGS IF YOU COULD WORTH INTO
AN ENTERPRISE AGREEMENT BEFORE
COMING INTO YOU THINK THAT THE
TDP'S CONTRACT- THE REASON WHY
WE DON'T HAVE A COST SAVINGS
BECAUSE HE WAS NEVER IN AN
ENTERPRISE AGREEMENT YOU WITH
WHEN. THERE WAS MONEY AVAILABLE
AND WE BY THE LICENSE DENNIS AT
THAT TIME WHICH WAS AVAILABLE
FOR UP WHAT ENTERPRISE UP THIRTY
FEET LICENSING WITH AVAILABLE
WAY BACK WHICH IS CURRENTLY NOT
NOT AVAILABLE FOR OFFICE THREE
SIXTY FIVE. SO THAT'S THE REASON
WHY HE DOES NOT HAVE A COST
SAVINGS JUST BECAUSE OUR MODEL
WITH DIFFERENT COMPARED TO THE
MODEL TODAY SO THEN DOESN'T THIS
REQUIRE OR ALLOW THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO. REVISIT AND OPEN IT
UP. TO SEE WHAT OTHER PROPOSALS
THAT MEET THEIR MAYBE. WHY NOT
WHY NOW GO FORWARD WITH- WITH
INCURRING A GREATER AMOUNT OF
COST. BUT INSTEAD SEE WHAT
TECHNOLOGY IS SPECIALLY GIVEN
HOW MUCH TECHNOLOGY FLOOD
CHANGES. IN A VERY SHORT PERIOD
OF TIME. WHY NOT NOW OPEN IT UP
AGAIN. SO WE ARE YOU THINK
TICKET OF POP UP. THAT WOULD SET
UP. RECENTLY OF TO FILL DIDN'T
DO THE- AT ECONOMICS OF SCALE SO
THAT IS THE BEST AFTER ABOUT-
OF- COSTING RIGHT NOW FOR THE
STATE. I'M SORRY YOUR WINNER
SAYING KATAKANA MEANS OF SCALE.
WE'RE PAYING MORE. AND THAT'S
EXACTLY THE ARGUMENT IF WE'RE
GOING TO UTILIZE ECONOMIES OF
SCALE CAR ADVANTAGE. WE
SHOULDN'T. DOESN'T SEEM LIKE WE
SHOULD BE PAYING MORE RIGHT NOW-
GIVEN. GIVEN THE SERVICES. THAT
WE'RE EXPECTING. EIGHT EIGHT THE
CARD PROPER OFFICE TO FIFTY FIVE
WAS THAT LET DOWN BY- T. P. AT
THE POINT OF TECHNOLOGY SO I
DON'T HAVE ANY INSIGHT. ON HOW
THEY PREPARED THAT THAT'S THAT
THE LICENSES I WOULD YES
AVAILING ITS RECEIPT HE IN TERMS
OF HOW MUCH IT'S GONNA COST YOU
DEFEAT OKAY IS SOMEONE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF. TECHNOLOGY
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER THESE
QUESTIONS. I DON'T SEE ANYONE ON
THE PANEL. THERE'S SOMEONE ON
THE CALL. NOW NO ONE'S EVER
KNOWN FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT EXTENT TECHNOLOGIES
CURRENTLY REPRESENTED BUT WE'D
BE HAPPY TO TAKE BACK ANY
QUESTIONS. YEAH BUT I'M I'M
SOMEWHAT SURPRISED THAT THIS-ANSWERED THIS QUESTION ISN'T
BEING ANSWERED. AND THERE'S NO
ONE ON THE PANEL THAT CAN ANSWER
IT. SHOULDN'T WE BE ABLE TO
ANSWER THIS QUESTION. WE WILL GO
BACK TO CDT AND GET YOU AN
ANSWER. OKAY SO DO WE KNOW HOW
MUCH MORE A CDC R. E. D. D. F.
TV IS GOING TO PAY FOR MICROSOFT
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND
OUTGOING AND OUTGOING YEARS AS
WELL- COMPARED TO WHAT THEY'VE
PAID IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE. R. ET
DE I COULD I COULD ONLY FIT FOR
EASY- FOR YOU DID YOU WE DID NOT
PAY ANY LICENSING PARKED UP FOR
MICROSOFT- IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
YES BECAUSE OUR LICENSING IS IT
OLD WORST FEELING OFFICE TWENTY
THIRTEEN WE HAVEN'T UPGRADED TO
OFFICE THREE SIXTY FIVE. OF THE
LAST TIME WE PURCHASE I BELIEVE
IT'S IN TWENTY SIXTEEN OR TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND I WAS ABLE A ONE
TIME- UP FEET INSTEAD OF A
SUBSCRIPTION LICENSE LIKE WHAT
WERE USED IMPROPERLY FIFTY FIVE.
SO WHAT IS THE UPGRADE GONNA
COST US. THE DIFFERENT. THE
TRANSITION TO OFFICE THREE SIXTY
FIVE. OH I'M SORRY WE ACTUALLY
HAVE A PAID FOR OFFICE A LICENSE
IT'S UP OVER SIXTY YEARS SO WE
HAVE BEEN ON ON A DIFFERENT
LICENSING ABOUT- MODOC COMPARED
TO OFFICE THREE SIXTY FIVE YOU.
THAT'S THAT OUR PUBLIC I THINK
THAT THAT THAT ANSWER THE
QUESTION BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
ANY BUDGET FOR OFFICE TO SUPPORT
ANY UPGRADE ON ON OUR MICROSOFT
LICENSES. SINCE THE LAST SIX
YEARS. OKAY THIS IS IT THIS IS A
NEW PURCHASE FOR EACH DIFFERENT
POSITION FROM OFFICE. TWENTY
THIRTEEN TO OFFICE THREE SIXTY
FIVE. OKAY THIS IS JUST RISING
UP THIS IS JUST RAISING MORE
QUESTIONS AT THIS POINT AND I
APOLOGIZE MADAM CHAIR I DON'T
WANNA TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
COMMITTEES TIME RIGHT NOW BUT I
STILL HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS IF
YOU DON'T MIND- THE LET ME. ASK
HOW MUCH DO ALL CALIFORNIA STATE
DEPARTMENTS IN TOTAL PAY EACH
YEAR. FOR MICROSOFT OFFICE THREE
SIXTY FIVE. MISTER NAZARIAN
EFFORT RELATED SOLELY ON EDT
THEY WOULDN'T KNOW HOW OTHER
DEPARTMENTS ARE WITH- ANY
UPGRADES TO THE MICROSOFT OF THE
SUCCESSFUL THERE IF WE CAN TRY
TO KEEP IT FOCUSED PLAY THAT'S
FAIR THAT'S FAIR- WELL LET'S
LET'S LET'S ANSWER THAT QUESTION
JUST FOR EDT. WHAT IF BUT FOR
TRANSITIONING OFFICE THREE SIXTY
FIVE IS AROUND FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS- THAT'S THAT THAT'S THE
TRANSITION FROM UPGRADING FROM
OFFICE TWENTY THIRTEEN TO OFFICE
. THREE SIXTY FIVE. AND THAT
WILL GET THE PROJECT AN ONGOING
SUBSCRIPTION SUPPORT FOR TEN
THOUSAND USERS. FOR TEN THOUSAND
USERS. AND IT'S GOING TO BE FIVE
MILLION A YEAR ON GOING OR IS IT
GOING TO BE MORE THAN FIVE
MILLION. THAT WILL BE- ABOUT
FIVE MILLION A YEAR ON GOING AND
I ARE WRITING AND- BASED ON CD
CASE CONTRACT I BELIEVE THERE IS
SOME INCREASE AFTER UP A COUPLE
YEARS BUT I'M NOT. I DON'T HAVE
THAT INFORMATION WITH ME WHICH I
CAN PROVIDE- LATER AND THIS IS
JUST FOR THE SUBSCRIPTION SO IF
THERE ARE OTHER SERVICES BEING
ASKED FOR. THEN IT'S GONNA BE
CONSIDERABLY RISING AND COST AS
WELL. AND IS THERE A CAP. THAT
THAT DOESN'T APPEAR IT'S
ACTUALLY PRETTY COMPREHENSIVE
IT'S NOT JUST OPPORTUNITY THIS
WEEK OF OFFICE THREE SIXTY FIVE
INCLUDING YOU KNOW THE OFFICE
PRODUCTS WORD EXCEL MICROSOFT
INCLUDING KEY IN SHAREPOINT- IT
ALSO INCLUDES A SOME SECURITIES
OUT THERE IN YOU BEGIN MICROSOFT
SO THERE IS IT IS DEFINITELY A
PRODUCT AND GETS NOT. ONE SINGLE
PLATFORM. ANY ADDITIONAL COSTS
THAT IS OUTSIDE OF THE SWEET
SWEET COULD POP BUT THAT'LL BE A
CUT BUT FOR NOW. THE WHOLE
ENTIRE SUITE IS THAT INCLUDED IN
IN THAT THOSE LICENSING. OKAY
AND WHAT'S THE CAP OF A COST FOR
A PER YEAR. AND THE CONTRACT. I
DO NOT HAVE ALL THE DETAILS WE
CAN PROVIDE- AND SHARED A
CONTRACT THAT IS- THE EDT
KATHLEEN TVP- PARTS OF THE
DETAILS. OKAY THANK YOU- AND
INNOCENT AFARIA AND FOR PURPOSE
OF CLARITY AS TO THE WHAT EDT
HAVE BEEN PREPARED FOR THIS WAS
A NON DISCUSSION ITEM ON PAGE
THREE OF THE AGENDA WHICH
ACTUALLY HAS THE BREAKDOWN
BETWEEN. THE GENERAL FUND AS
WELL AS EDT FOR THE QUESTIONS
THAT YOU'RE ASKING. I SAW THAT
BUT I COULDN'T GET ALL OF MY
ANSWERS SO THAT'S WHY I WANTED
TO. DRILL IN A LITTLE BIT MORE
THANK YOU MANAGER IF YOU DON'T
MIND I JUST HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS ALSO. BASED ON MY
CONSTITUENT ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN COMING THROUGH THAT I'D
LIKE TO ASK ON THIS IF YOU WANT
ME TO KEEP IT FOR ANOTHER TIME
OF COURSE THE SENATE THERE AND
JUST KEEP IN MIND THAT WE DO
HAVE OTHER PANELISTS WAITING TO
. BE HEARD ON THIS HEARING.
PRECIADO I MEAN I. THIS IS
ONGOING SO I CAN KEEP THIS FOR
THE NEXT PANEL- BECAUSE IT'S A
CAKE I THINK IT'S A CUTS THROUGH
SEVERAL DIFFERENT ISSUES BUT- I
JUST WANTED TO ASK. I HAVE A
SERIES OF QUESTIONS. I'LL JUST
LIMITED TO FOR NOW- TOOK FOR ON
ON THE INTERVIEW WAIT TIMES. OF
AND AGAIN I CAN ASK THIS LATER
IF YOU LIKE. I OR I CAN PROCEED
RIGHT NOW. PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANKS KEEP IT BRIEF AND KEEP IT
MOVING THANK CHAU STILL IT'S
STILL TAKING EDT AT LEAST TWO TO
FIVE MONTHS TO CONDUCT
INTERVIEWS- WHY THIS DEGREE OF
WAIT TIME SOLELY INTO THIS
PROCESS. SO I'M NOT SURE IF YOU
WERE HERE FOR MIGHT MY INTRO-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND I WILL-
ALLOW COLLEAGUES TO- AT ANYTHING
IF NEEDED BUT WE ARE- LOOKING AT
IN THE PROCESS OF. DOING A
WRITTEN INTERVIEW SO THAT WILL
GO OUT QUESTOR BRITAIN
QUESTIONNAIRE AND THAT WILL GO
OUT TO- PLACEMENTS THAT ARE
WAITING FOR DETERMINATION AND
THAT WAY THEY DON'T HAVE TO WAIT
THAT THAT AMOUNT OF TIME. WE ALL
HAVE SAID IN PAST HEARINGS THAT
THE WAIT TIME IS UNACCEPTABLE
IT'S A BACKLOG THAT WE HAVE IT'S
A BACKLOG THAT WE ARE
ADDRESSING- YOU KNOW WE HAVE THE
VENDOR THAT CAME IN- LAST LAST
YEAR THAT'S HELPING US THROUGH
SOME OF THAT SO AND WE'RE
HOPEFUL HOPEFUL THAT THE
QUESTIONNAIRE- WILL BE THE- THE
THING THAT EXPEDITES THIS THE
MOST. OKAY. SO ON DOCUMENTATION
SPECIFICALLY ON Q. A-
DOCUMENTATION WHAT WE HEAR IS
THAT THERE'S SUBSTANTIAL
CONFUSION ABOUT WHO AND WHY
PEOPLE ARE GETTING DISQUALIFIED
ONCE THEY'VE ALREADY SUBMITTED
DOCUMENTATION. AND WHO WOULD
THEN- WITH THE APPEAL- DOES THIS
EDT PROVIDE THEIR DECISION
MAKERS WITH VERY CLEAR AND
CONCISE CRITERIA. FOR WHO IS
APPROVED AND WHO. IS
DISQUALIFIED. OR WHO TO
DISQUALIFY. I CAN CERTAINLY TAKE
THAT ONE DIRECTOR SERVICE IF
YOU'D LIKE- SO THAT'S YEAH WITH
EDT- YEAH SO SPECIFIC TO THE
NOTIFICATIONS AND WHAT THE
REQUIREMENTS ARE FOR
CONSTITUENTS- WITH RESPECT TO
THE FIRST PHASE THAT WE'RE
CURRENTLY IN RIGHT NOW WE SEND
THE CONSTITUENCY THE LINK THAT I
REFERENCED PREVIOUSLY- AND IT
DOES BREAK DOWN IT IS VALUABLE
TO THEIR CIRCUMSTANCE AND
THEREFORE DEPENDING UPON THE
YEAR IN WHICH THEY SAID THEIR
APPLICATIONS FOR BENEFITS THE
YEAR PRIOR TO AND UP UNTIL THE
DATE IN WHICH THEY BEGAN THEIR
BENEFIT YEAR FOR BENEFITS. THERE
IS A TIME HEARD IN WHICH
DOCUMENTATION MUST BE PROVIDED
IT DOES NOT HAVE TO COVER THE
ENTIRE DURATION IT JUST NEEDS TO
COVER EIGHT ANYTIME BETWEEN THAT
POINT IN TIME AND SO ON THE
CLICK. IN THE LINK AS THEY'RE
NAVIGATING THE CONSTITUENTS
THROUGH WHAT THE DOCUMENTS ARE
NECESSARY WHAT WHAT DOCUMENTS
ARE AVAILABLE THAT THEY CAN PULL
FROM TAX DOCUMENTS SCHEDULE
SEES- JOB OFFERS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE BY EMPLOYERS THERE'S A LIST
OF DOCUMENTS THAT THE
CONSTITUENTS ARE PROVIDED WITH
US TO RUN IT WALKING BURKE
FLOWING THROUGH THE PROCESS WE
HAVE ALSO ACTUALLY EXPANDED OUR
PUBLIC FACING WEBSITE TO ENSURE
THAT WE ENHANCE THE
NOTIFICATIONS OF DOCUMENTS BUT-
GIVEN AT CONSTITUENTS CAN PULL
FROM. IN ORDER TO UPLOAD THEM
AND PROVIDE THEM TO US IN THE
EVENT THAT THEY'RE DISQUALIFIED
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN OUR INSTANCES
OF- DOCUMENTS THAT ARE TOO FAR
OUT- WHERE THEY MAY FALL INTO A
COMPLETELY DID YEARS PAST THAT
AREN'T SUITABLE OR ACCEPTABLE
GIVEN THE TIME PERIOD THAT THEY
WERE REQUIRED TO SUBMIT THE
DOCUMENTS FOR AND SO WITHOUT
THOUGH WE HAVE EXPANDED OUR
PROCESSES IN OUR OPERATIONS TO
ENSURE THAT OUR PROGRAM A
PRESENTED IS TO REACH OUT IN THE
EVENT THAT IT SOMETHING AT THAT
COULD EITHER BE CLARIFIED OVER
THE PHONE- OR THAT WE CAN
PROVIDED AN ADDITIONAL LINK IF
THAT'S THE SITUATION IN WHICH
WE- CAN PROVIDE. A NEW DOCUMENT. BUT IT'S- THEY DO HAVE THEIR
THEIR APPEAL RIGHTS AND WE WEEK.
ONE WHEN THE CONCERT SOME THOSE
BACK AND THE APPEAL- WE ASK
PERFORM ANOTHER PER APPEAL
REVIEW. THAT'S ACTUALLY
TRANSMITTED TO THE CALIFORNIA
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE PPEALS
BOARD. OKAY SO I APPRECIATE THE
SENSOR BUT JUST TO BE VERY
SPECIFIC WHAT. WHAT INFORMATION
DO YOU PROVIDE WHEN AN APPEAL IS
NECESSARY YOU SAID YOU. OFFER A
LIST OF DOCUMENTS BUT CAN YOU BE
MORE SPECIFIC AYE AYES TO. HOW
DO YOU ARM THE PERSON WITH
INFORMATION SO THAT THEY KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT TO DO AS THEY'RE
GOING THROUGH THIS PROCESS TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE. WHAT THEY NEED
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD. YES AND SO- WITH
RESPECT TO THE- WHAT WE'VE DONE
IS EXPANDED THAT LIST OF
DOCUMENTS THAT WOULD. THAT A
CLAIM I CAN ACTUALLY. PULL FROM-
THE EASIEST THAT WE'VE SEEN IN
THE QUICKEST THAT WE'VE SEEN
SPECIALLY FOR- ELECTRONIC TAX
FILERS GUESTS ARE TAX DOCUMENTS.
AND SO WE'VE ACTUALLY- INSURE
THAT WE'VE EXPANDED THE DOCUMENT
SO THAT THEY'RE AWARE OF WHAT IS
SUITABLE. AND FALLS INTO THEIR
SPECIFIC CRITERIA AS FAR AS THE
TIME FRAME. SO THEY'RE PROVIDED
WITH A LIST OF ACCEPTABLE
DOCUMENTS THAT THEY CAN PROVIDE.
IF BY CHANCE LIKE I MENTIONED
THEY PROVIDE OF A YEAR THAT'S
NOT EVEN WITHIN THE PARAMETER IN
WHICH THEY'VE BEEN NOTIFIED THAT
THEY NEED TO PROVIDE- THAT IS
ONE WORTH NOTICING OF THEM OF
THE DISQUALIFICATION. ADWORDS
REQUIRED TO BUY TO ALLOW THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- AND THEN
ADVISE THEM OF THEIR PEOPLE'S
RIGHTS. WE THERE'S THAT INTRO
WHERE- SAYING AT THE GIVE A
PERFECT EXAMPLE AS FAR AS IF THE
KIND OF BY ANY CHANCE PROVIDES
DOCUMENTATION THAT SPEAKS TO. A
YEAR THAT FALLS. THAT OVERLAPS-
AND IT'S NOT VERY CLEAR THAT
THAT YOU'RE ACTUALLY COVERS THE
TIME FRAME WE HAVE INSTRUCTED
OUR PROGRAM UPS TO CONTACT THEM
AND CALL THEM TO CLARIFY THAT-
AND REQUEST ITSELF ANTICIPATION
TO VERIFY THAT WE JUST WERE
EARNED. DURING THE TIME PERIOD
AND THEN WE CAN CLOSE AND SO
WE'VE- INDICATED A FEW AVENUES.
THAT WE CAN COMMUNICATE WITH THE
CLAIMANT PRIOR TO AN UP UNTIL
THEIR DISQUALIFICATION TO WHICH
THE ONLY AVENUE AFTER THAT AS IN
A PEOPLE. OKAY. OKAY I THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME THE OPPORTUNITY
MISADVENTURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER NAZARIAN WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO. THE
YOU I TRUST FUND REPAYMENT WE
WILL START WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND I ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE- KEEP YOUR COMMENTS BRIEF
AND TO THE POINT SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE ON WITH THE COMBINED
PANEL WHICH FOLLOWS AND WE
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO LOSE ANY
OF OUR PRESENTERS. THANK YOU.
THE PART OF FINANCE. THE CHECKER
PATTERN TOP AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- THE PROPOSAL IS THAT
CONSISTENT WITH THE THEME OF
RAISING LIABILITIES THROUGHOUT
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
OPTIMIZATION PROPOSING THREE
BILLION DOLLARS- GENERAL FUND
ONE MILLION IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND TWO BILLION IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. TO PAY
DOWN THE U. I TRUST FUND LOAN
THAT WAS TAKEN OUT FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO PAY YOU
AYE BENEFITS UNINTERRUPTED WHEN
THE PHONE WENT INSOLVENT IN
TWENTY TWENTY SO REDUCE THE
STATE'S LIABILITIES ACCELERATE
THE REPAYMENT OF THIS DEBT WHICH
IS CURRENTLY NINETEEN POINT FIVE
BILLION. EVERY TECHNICAL. AND HE
- IS HAVE THE UPPERS AND
TECHNICAL SUPPORT THANK. THANK
YOU AND NOW THE L. L. CHAZELLE
LOW WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- WE ALSO- LAST
WEEK PUBLISHED REPORT ON ON THIS
PROPOSAL BY WHICH THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES TO MAKE TWO PAYMENTS
TOTALING THREE BILLION DOLLARS
TOWARDS THAT OUTSTANDING FEDERAL
LOANS. DOZENS ARE ALL RIGHT
MODELS A COUPLE OF ECONOMIC
SCENARIOS- ANTICIPATING HOW- ARE
THE STATE AND EMPLOYERS WILL
REPAY OF THE FEDERAL LOANS- WE
ESTIMATE THAT THE THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED PAYMENT
WOULD REDUCE STATE INTEREST
COSTS. ARE BY A TOTAL OF BETWEEN
FIVE AND FIFTY MILLION AND ONE
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS- THAT
RANGE- IS INDICATIVE OF THE TWO
SCENARIOS SOMETHING LOW COST AND
HIGH COSTS IN ORDER WITH THAT
THAT OUR OFFICE- PUT FORTH. ON
WE ALSO POINT OUT THAT THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED PAYMENTS COULD
REDUCE- LAWYER YOU I PAY WHAT
TAXES AT THE END OF THE REPAIR.
WHICH WE ESTIMATE TO BE EITHER
TWENTY THIRTY OR TWENTY THIRTY
TWO- THAT THE PARENTS OPERATE
MUCH LIKE A LUMP SUM PAYMENT ON
A MORTGAGE- THEY THEY WOULDN'T
REDUCE OUR COSTS FOR ANNUAL
PAYMENTS BUT IT WOULD REDUCE THE
DURATION OF A LOTS OF THOSE.
PRIMARY DIRECT BENEFITS FOR
EMPLOYERS IN TERMS OF TAX
RELIEF- WOULD NOT OCCUR UNTIL
THE END OF THE REPAYMENT PERIOD-
WE PROPOSE AS AN ALTERNATIVE FOR
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER IT
SHOULD IT TO THE LEGISLATURE TO
PROVIDE MORE IMMEDIATE TAX
RELIEF IT COULD LOOK TO
PROVIDING A- YOU AYE TAX CREDIT
TO EMPLOYERS- TO OFFSET THE-
INCREASED FEDERAL TAXES
SCHEDULED TO GO INTO EFFECT THIS
YEAR. HOW TO REPAY THE LOANS I'M
THIS ALTERNATIVE WOULD PROVIDE
MORE. IMMEDIATE RELIEF TO-
BUSINESSES THAT THE- THAT THE
FAX PANDEMIC ARE ARE. STE LINGER
. IN THE STATE HERE THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU BEFORE OPEN IT UP
TO THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AT TO CALL. A MINUTE- THEY BOTH
KINDA COINCIDE SO. DOES THE
ADMINISTRATION HAVE A PROJECTED
DATE TO REPAY THE FEDERAL YOU
AYE DADDY AND HOW WOULD THIS
PROPOSAL REPAYMENT ASSIST
BUSINESSES AND EMPLOYERS. JERA
PATTERN TOP AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE DO NOT CURRENTLY HAVE
A PROJECTED DATE TO COMPLETE THE
RENT PAYMENT OF THE U. EYES THAT
JUST DUE TO THE AMOUNT OF
UNCERTAINTY THAT ANY PRODUCTION
WOULD HAVE SINCE IT WILL DEPEND
ON. THE STATE RATE OF
UNEMPLOYMENT EMPLOYER
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE U. I FIND
AS WELL AS THE ECONOMIC HEALTH
OF THE STATE. AS WELL AS
ADDITIONAL UNCERTAINTY THAT'S
ADDED REGARDING AN ADDITIONAL
TRIGGER AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
KNOWN AS THE BENEFIT COST RATIO
THAT COULD COME INTO. PLAY AT
YOUR FIVE INSOLVENCY- WHICH IF
THE STATE DOES NOT OPT TO WAIVE
THIS TRIGGER AND MEET THE
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS SURROUNDING
IT. BUT XCELERATED THE FEDERAL
UNEMPLOYMENT TAX ACT CREDIT
REDUCTIONS. BECAUSE THE DEBTS BE
PAID OFF MORE QUICKLY- AND
ALTHOUGH. AGAIN AS A RESULT WE
DON'T HAVE A CURRENT ESTIMATE-
WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE ARMENIAN
RECESSION YOU I FIND THAT PEAKED
AT AROUND ELEVEN BILLION. IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN WHAT WAS THAT
NOT REPAID UNTIL TWENTY EIGHTEEN
- AND AS FOR THE- HOW IT WILL
BENEFIT. BUSINESSES WILL
BENEFITS MOTHERS IS THE FUTURE
BY ACCELERATING THE PAY OFF-
WHICH WILL RESTORE THE FEDERAL
UNEMPLOYMENT TAX ACT CREDIT BY
UP TO A YEAR EARLIER- WHICH-
WILL OF COURSE BE. WERE THE
LARGEST CUMULATIVE IMPACT WILL
BE THAT THE- FOOD THAT. TAX
CREDIT REDUCTIONS ARE CUMULATIVE
YEAR OVER YEAR. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS ON ISSUE TO. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AT NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS FROM THE L. L. NONE
THANK ABOUT AFTER. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
OUR- COMBINED PANEL ON THIS NEXT
SECTION WE ARE GOING TO HEAR
FROM THE LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD AND EDT. THE PRESENTATION
WILL COVER THE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE PROPOSALS THAT ARE
PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S PACKAGE
TO EXTEND EXPAND I'M SORRY THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
WORFORCE. LOTS OF FOLKS ON THIS
PANEL SO LET'S BEGIN WITH THE
LABOR AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY. IF I COULD START I'M AT
PEACE NAY ON THE DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR THE FUTURE OF WORK
AT THE LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY THANK YOU SO
MUCH CHAIR CARILLO AND THANK YOU
MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE TODAY. AS YOU HEARD
SECRETARY FOR THE GI SAY ACROSS
THE- WORK FORCE DEPARTMENTS
UNDER THE LABOR AGENCY WE HAVE
THREE MAJOR CROSS CUTTING
INITIATIVES PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THAT HAVE
SPECIFIC PROGRAM INVESTMENTS IN
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT'S WORKFORCE SERVICES
BRANCH THE STATE WORKFORCE BOARD
AND THE EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
PANEL AS A VERY BROADOVERVIEW
THESE THREE INITIATIVES.
INVESTED IN HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE IN COLLABORATION WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICE AGENCY CLIMATE AND GREEN
ENERGY IN COLLABORATION WITH CAL
STAR AND NATURAL RESOURCES. AND
IMMIGRANT ECONOMIC MOBILITY IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE GOVERNOR
SENIOR ADVISER ON IMMIGRATION
SOCIAL SERVICES EDUCATION AND
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE SAID THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. I WILL SAY
IF YOU WORDS OF OVERVIEW ON THE
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE INITIATIVE
AND THEN TURNED OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUES FOR GREATER DETAIL.
THE BUDGET INCLUDES A ONE TIME
ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT OVER THREE YEARS AND
HEALTHCARE ECONOMY WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. THAT WILL CREATE
MORE INNOVATIVE AND ACCESSIBLE
OPPORTUNITIES TO RECRUIT TRAIN.
PLAYER IN ADVANCE AND ETHNICALLY
AND CULTURALLY INCLUSIVE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES WORKFORCE
WITH IMPROVE DIVERSITY WAGES AND
HEALTH EQUITY OUTCOMES. THESE
CARE CON ANY INVESTMENTS WILL BE
COORDINATED BY THE LABOR AGENCY
AND HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES.
AND THIS INITIATIVE INCLUDES
TWELVE PROGRAMS THREE THAT WILL
BE DIRECTLY AND ADMINISTERED BY.
IN A DALY THE STATE BOARD AND
THE. T. P. AND AS VERY VERY FACT
I THAT WE- RATE CUTS AND COMES.
ABOUT THE- SHORTAGE THE CRY IN
CARE. HOSPITALS ARE SHORT
STAFFED IN DESPERATE. VERY HIGH
REGISTRY RATES FOR TEMPORARY
WORK FORCE THESE WERE TRENDS
THAT WERE IN PLACE FOR ALL YOUR
THAT WERE EXACERBATED IN THE
PANDEMIC HOMELESS SERVICE
PROVIDERS ARE DESPERATE FOR CASE
MANAGERS AND WHICH TEAM MEMBERS
CHILD WELFARE SERVICE PROVIDERS
DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH PEOPLE TO
PERFORM ASSESSMENTS AND
SERVICES- WE ALSO HAVE
CHALLENGES WITH DIVERSITY AND
THE HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE. AND
IMPACTED TRAINING PROGRAMS IN
OUR TRAINING SYSTEM- AND SO THIS
INVESTMENT WILL ADDRESS THESE
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES BUT ALSO
CREATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE
FROM LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR TO MOVE
INTO THESE JOBS THAT CAN OFFER
PATHWAYS TO LIVING WAGES AND
SELF SUFFICIENCY. EIGHTY DAYS
LABOR MARKET INFORMATION
DIVISION PROJECTS ALMOST ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION HEALTHCARE
AND HUMAN SERVICE JOBS IN THE
PERIOD FROM TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN TO TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
EIGHT WITH WAGES AVERAGING CLOSE
TO TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS AN HOUR.
AND SIGNIFICANT JOBS. FOUR
PEOPLE WHO DO NOT HAVE A FOUR
YEAR DEGREE THAT CAN OFFER
PATHWAYS INTO FAMILY SUSTAINING
ROLES IN HOSPITAL PRIMARY CARE
AND COMMUNITY SETTINGS- BEING
VERY SENSITIVE TO TIME LET ME
SPEAK WITH BRIEFLY ON THE FIRST-
B. C. P. WHICH WOULD BE. FOR
STAFFING APPLE CALIFORNIA LABOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY FOR
TWO POSITIONS AND- FOR A HALF A
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR FROM THE
GENERAL FUND. TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT THIS WORK FORCE FOR
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA AND ISSUED IT
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY- I WANT TO AGAIN
BE SENSITIVE OF TIME AND TURN TO
MY COLLEAGUE TIM RAINEY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD. TO SPEAK ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL THAT WE WOULD IS IN
THAT. BOARD'S BUDGET TIM. THANKS
ABBY OUT VERY QUICKLY I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS. THE
HEALTHCARE HIGH ROAD- INITIATIVE
THREE HUNDRED FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THREE YEARS IS
BUILT ON TOP OF THE HIGHER
TRAINING PARTNERSHIP WORK THE
STATE PARTY'S BEEN DOING FOR
SELLERS SEVERAL YEARS- AS YOU
KNOW THE HIGH ROAD PRIOR TAXES
EQUITY JOB QUALITY CLIMATE
RESILIENCE- IN THE PRACTICES WE
CAN'T ACHIEVE EQUITY WITHOUT
PAYING ATTENTION TO JOB QUALITY
SO OP. OUR APPROACH IS TO ENGAGE
INDUSTRY FIRST. AND THEN CONNECT
EXISTING WORKFORCE TRAINING
PROGRAMS THAT SERVE POPULATIONS
WITH- SUPPLEMENT CONNECT THOSE
PROGRAMS AND THOSE PEOPLE TO
GOOD QUALITY JOBS. INSIDE THE
SECTORS WERE FOCUSED ON. SO THIS
. HEALTHCARE HIGH ROAD.
INITIATIVE WILL TARGET
OCCUPATIONS THAT DON'T REQUIRE
FOR YOUR DEGREE. LARGELY PUBLIC
HEALTH OCCUPATIONS- EVERYTHING
EXCEPT DOCTORS NURSES- INCLUDING
MEDICAL ASSISTANTS RESPIRATORY
TECHNICIANS SURGICAL TECHNICIANS
OTHERS- WHAT TRAIN APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND WORKERS OVER
THE COURSE OF THIS INITIATIVE-
AND I THINK. I THINK I WANT TO
LEAVE IT THERE BECAUSE I KNOW
WE'RE REALLY PRESSED FOR TIME IF
I CAN'T I LIKE THE HEAD OVER TO
MY TO THE NEXT ITEM- TO MY
COLLEAGUE GET THE EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PANEL HI MICHAEL
THEATERS. AFTERNOON THANK YOU
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR RAINY- MADAM
CHAIR ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU
FOR THE BRIEF OPPORTUNITY HERE
TO SPEAK IN REGARDS TO OUR I.
HEALTH CARE- WORKFORCE-
ESSENTIALLY THE REQUEST IS FOR
NINETY MILLION DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT JOB ENTRY AND CAREER
ADVANCEMENT- FOR ENTRY LEVEL
ANOTHER WORKERS IN CARE.
HEALTHCARE HUMAN SERVICE
SETTINGS AS WELL AS INCLUDING
SOCIAL WORK- IS FUNDING WILL GO
DIRECTLY TO EMPLOYERS TO PROVIDE
THEIR OWN TRAINING AND THEREBY
CREATING CAREER PATHWAYS- AS
WELL AS TO ORGANIZED LABOR. A
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
NONPROFITS TRADE ASSOCIATIONS.
THAT PROVIDE TRAINING TO WORKERS
IN MULTIPLE EMPLOYER SETTINGS-
THE TRAINING- THAT WERE THAT ARE
UPSKILLING. THE TRAINING WILL
UPSKILL EXISTING EMPLOYEES- IT
WILL REQUIRE AND DEMONSTRATE
THAT WAGE INCREASES THE
OCCURRENCE PART OF THAT
TRAINING. I'M LIKE ON OTHER CORE
INDUSTRIES WITHIN ETP'S
SERVICES. SUCH AS MANUFACTURING
AND CONSTRUCTION OF THE
HEALTHCARE AND HUMAN SERVICE
INDUSTRY PROVIDERS ARE NOT
NORMALLY ELIGIBLE FOR ETP
FINDING. ARE THERE FOR THIS
INITIATIVE WILL GO A GREAT WAY
TO HELPING THE STATE A PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL SERVICES TO THESE
PARTICULAR AREAS- BASED ON THIS
INITIATIVE THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
APPLY FOR THE FUNDS WITHIN
EIGHTY P. AND PEOPLE TO UPSKILL
THEIR WORK FORCE IN SUPPORT
CAREER ADVANCEMENT. IN TURN MORE
HIGHLY SKILLED AND COMPENSATED
ROLES- WE ARE PROJECTING TO
SERVE MORE THAN SIXTEEN THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS AS PART OF THIS
PARTICULAR EFFORT. I WOULD THAT
AND KEEPING MY REMARKS BRIEF I
THANK YOU AS WELL AND I'D LIKE
TO PASS IT OVER TO EDIE'S-
EXECUTIVE- DIRECTOR AND CHIEF.
DEPUTY DIRECTOR I BELIEVE OF
WORKFORCE- HAVE YOUR CRIMINAL.
TO SPEAK ON HIS INITIATIVE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS- WE SPEAKING ABOUT
SPEAKING. ON REGARD THAT TARGET
MEDICAL. CORNISH'S THIS WILL BE
A SIXTEEN DOLLAR PROGRAM OVER
YEARS ONE BEFORE YOU CAN. TO WE
HAVE THE RIGHT CAMERA ON THE
GENTLEMAN THAT SPEAKING AND CAN
WE HIRE HIS VOLUME PLACE. THAT.
CAN YOU PLEASE TURN ON YOUR
CAMERA. MY CAMERA ON AS FAR AS I
CAN TELL HERE. THANK YOU OKAY HE
- IF YOU CAN CONTINUE SPEAKING
AND THEN HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET YOU
ON CAMERA. OKAY. AS STATED THIS
AT THE END OF THE CAN SPEAK A
LITTLE LOUDER PLEASE OR CLOSER
TO YOUR MICROPHONE YOU SOUND
VERY FAR AWAY. RIGHT I'LL BE
CLOSER- CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW MUCH
BETTER THANK YOU. THANK YOU MY
PROGRESS THE TARGET EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICE CORPS
INITIATIVE- WILL BE AS I STATED
ALREADY SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS
OVER THREE YEARS THAT WE CAN
COMMENCE OF TWENTY MILLION. ARM
THIS IS FUN THIS ADDITION TO.
OUR WILL EXPAND THE EMERGENCY
THE EMERGENCY MEDICAL TECHNICIAN
WORKFORCE IN PARTNERSHIP. WITH
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEMS. I'M
ABLE TO USE BACK- YOUTH AND
YOUTH BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT- WE
WILL HAVE DISSIPATE CERTAIN
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED. EXISTENCE ARM
THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN DEVELOPED
AND TESTED IN ALAMEDA COUNTY.
IT'S A VERY COMPREHENSIVE
PROGRAM- THAT IT'S USED- ARE
WITH THE FUNDING WILL ARE SET UP
ON THE SITES THAT ARE BEST
POSITIONED FOR SUCCESS AND WHAT
WE MEAN BY THAT IS WHERE WE SEE
A COMMITTED PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM
PROGRAM IN PARTNERSHIP WITH A
MIX OF WORK FOR CEOS. THE SO
BASICALLY WE DO I WOULDN'T- THIS
PROGRAM HAS BEEN TESTED. ITS
COMPREHENSIVE IN ITS APPROACH.
AND BUT SIT IN A NUTSHELL KEEP
IN MIND COMMON SHORT. BY THE
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
FOR THAT MISTER MERRILL IS THERE
SOMEONE THAT YOU'RE PIVOTING TO
THAT'S GONNA ADDRESS ADDITIONAL
. I THINK COMMON. HEALTH HEALTH
CARE- RELATED- ITEMS. OKAY THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND AGAIN THERE ARE
NINE PEOPLE ON THIS COMBINED A
PANEL SO THE ISSUE WAS JUST SOME
TELL ME MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE A
HIGH LEVEL CONVERSATION AS TO BE
PROPOSALS AND THEN ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FROM OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE DYESS. LET'S ADD
NOW THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL OF
YOU LET'S HEAR FROM DEPARTMENT
FINANCE PLEASE. BETTER TOPIC
APARTMENT OF FINANCE- WE HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS BEYOND THOSE
ARE MADE BY THE MINISTRATION
THANK YOU. LOL. HELLO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
THE HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE
PROPOSALS BROAD TOUCHES MANY
STATE DEPARTMENTS OUR OFFICE IS
STILL WORKING ON ANALYSIS UP IN
ITS ENTIRETY- BUT WE PUT IT IS
THIS POINT THAT THE PACKAGES IS
VERY CONCEPTUAL IN NATURE RIGHT
NOW- GIVES THE LEGISLATURE
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP SHAPE HOW IT
LOOKS OVER THE NEXT COUPLE OF
MONTHS AND SPECIFIC SO THE
WORKFORCE PIECES- THAT THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD AND
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL WE DO
POINT OUT THAT. BOTH ENTITIES
HAVE. RECEIVE SUCH. FUNDING
INCREASES OF CENTS A PANDEMIC
BEGAN AND THIS WOULD BE ON TOP
OF THOSE LEGISLATORS GONNA WANNA
MAKE SURE AS A CONSIDERS THE
PACKAGE IN ITS ENTIRETY. THAT
BOTH THE BOARD AND THE PANEL
HAVE THE RESOURCES- TO SCALE UP
GRANT MAKING BUT ALSO THAT THE
DEMAND- EXISTS IN THE FIELD- SO
THAT. THE THESE PROGRAMS CAN
EFFECTIVELY TARGET- THE WORK
FORCE NEEDS- THAT THAT AIM TO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THAT I
THINK THAT YOU WILL SEE A LOT OF
ENTHUSIASM FOR OUR FROM A LOT OF
THE MEMBERS WHEN IT COMES TO
CREATING JOB OPPORTUNITIES
CREATING A- A PIPELINE FOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. AND SO
WHAT THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
PROVIDED A LIST OF JOBS IN
SECTORS THAT WILL BE SUPPORTED
THROUGH THESE PROPOSALS SUCH AS-
ACUTE CARE TO SCHOOL- SKILLED
NURSING HOMES OR SOCIAL WORK.
WHAT FACTORS WERE CONSIDERED IN
BUILDING THIS LIST AND WHAT JOBS
OR SECTORS. WILL BE PRIORITIZE
AND NIGHT I ALSO WANT TO ADD
THAT GIVEN THE LAST TWO YEARS OF
THE PANDEMIC. WE HAVE SEEN HOW
ESSENTIAL IN FRONT MY WORKERS IN
THE HEALTHCARE PROFESSION. HAVE
BEEN A COMPLETELY OVERWHELMED AS
ESPECIALLY IN SKILLED NURSING
HOME FACILITIES AND SO WOULD
LOVE TO HEAR. HOW THIS LIST CAME
ABOUT THANK YOU. I CAN. GIVE ME
I CAN RESPOND- ONE WAY TO START
WITH IS THAT THIS INVESTMENT
WILL BUILD UPON THE
LEGISLATURE'S INVESTMENT LAST
YEAR IN LONG TERM CARE AND
SIGNIFICANT- BUDGET ITEMS THAT
WHEN PRIMARILY ON THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES SIDE TO INCREASE
TRAINING FOR IN HOME SUPPORT
SERVICES WORKERS AND CERTIFIED
NURSING ASSISTANTS- IT HAS BEEN
A THRILL AND AN HONOR TO WORK IN
CLOSE PARTNERSHIP WITH HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES WORK THAT
WILL CONTINUE. AND TO- FACE ARE
. RESEARCH AND PLANNING ON IN
PROJECTIONS BY ON THE LABOR
MARKET INFORMATION DIVISION- AND
OTHER PROJECTIONS THAT- H. CAI
FORMALLY- OUR STRIDE IS MAKING
AS YOU SAW IN THE OVERALL
CONDITION AND IF THERE ARE
SPECIFIC- LINE ITEMS FOR
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS FOR.
NURSES FOR IN B. FOR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH- AND SO I THINK BIG PART
OF THE PLANNING. FOR THE-
INITIALLY THAT WE HAVE TALKED
ABOUT TODAY OUR TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHERE THEY WERE
MARKET DEMAND IS GREATEST AND
WHERE THE JOBS WILL OFFER THE
BEST CAREER PATHWAYS FOR
INDIVIDUALS FROM UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AND THOSE ARE LIKELY
TO BE PATHWAYS- THAT THAT CAN
DESCRIBE THAT DO NOT REQUIRE A
FOUR YEAR DEGREE THAT COULD BE
RESPIRATORY TACKY CAGEY TACKLED
HER SOUND- AS WELL. AS- ESHEL
ROLES IN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH- THE
MAGNITUDE OF THIS PROPOSED
INVESTMENT WILL REALLY ENABLE
CALIFORNIA TO STAFF UP TO FILL
MUCH NEEDED ROLES AND AGAIN TO
REALLY PROVIDE. PATHWAYS INTO
GOOD JOBS FOR- MANY PEOPLE WHO
LEFT OTHER ROLES IN THE- IN THE
PANDEMIC AND CAN- FIND NEW ROLES
AND HEALTH CARE. THANK YOU I
KNOW THAT MANY YEARS AGO THERE
WAS A SAYING OR- CALLED THE
SILVER TSUNAMI IN WHICH WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE. PARENTS AND
GRANDPARENTS AND EVEN
GRANDPARENTS OF THE SAME
GENERATION ALL AGING OUT I'M
SORRY THAT'S AN APPROPRIATE
PHRASING ALL BECOMING A SENIORS
OR ELDERLY ALL IN THE IN THE
SAME CATEGORY SO THIS IS AN
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT. PIECE OF
SOLVING THAT HEALTHCARE A
NECESSITY FOR MANY COMMUNITIES
I'LL JUST- ONE OPEN IT UP TO THE
MEMBERS AS WELL BUT HOW MANY
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
WORKERS ARE PROJECTED TO BE
TRAINED I HEARD I THINK TWENTY
TWO THOUSAND WHEN IT WAS BEING
PRESENTED. THROUGH THESE
PROPOSALS WHAT METRICS WILL BE
USED TO DETERMINE SUCCESS. I
THINK PART OF DEVELOPING EACH OF
THESE. GROSGRAIN COMPONENTS
UNDER THE INITIATIVE WILL BE TO
IDENTIFY THOSE SPECIFIC METRICS
THOSE ARE LIKELY TO FALL INTO
THREE CATEGORIES METRICS
MEASURING THE PROGRESS OF
TRAINING PARTICIPANTS OF THE
IMPACT ON PROVIDERS AND THEN THE
IMPACT ON THAT PATIENTS AND
CLIENTS- WHO ARE RECIPINTS OF
SERVICES FOR TRAINING
PARTICIPANTS THOSE METRICS ARE
LIKELY TO FOCUS ON COMPLETION OF
TRAINING. ATTAINMENT OF A DEGREE
CERTIFICATE OR LICENSE JOB
PLACEMENT WAGES AT THE POINT OF
PLACEMENT AND AS THOSE- PEOPLE
EVENTS IN THEIR JOBS AND WAGES
THAT EXCEED INDIVIDUALS PRIOR
EARNINGS AND OR MEET LOCAL-
STANDARDS FOR SELF SUFFICIENCY
WE WILL ALSO LOOK AT JOB
RETENTION. AND CERTAINLY LOOK AT
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION TO BE
ABLE TO- MEASURE PROGRESS ON
EQUITY GOALS- IN DISAGGREGATED
IN THOSE OTHER OUTCOMES. IN
TERMS OF THE PROVIDER SIDE THE
DEMAND SIDE WE WILL BE LOOKING
AT METRICS THAT INCLUDE THE
INCREASED DIVERSITY OF THE
WORKFORCE REDUCE TIME TO HIRE
REDUCED USE OF TEMPORARY STAFF
AND SUCH AS TRAVELLING NURSES.
AND INCREASED RETENTION AND
REDUCE TURNOVER YOU KNOW PERHAPS
MOST IMPORTANTLY WILL BE THE
IMPACT ON THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE WILL LOOK AT
PATIENT AND. CLIENT- RECIPIENT.
AT TRICKS THAT WILLING POSITIVE
REYES FOR CUSTOMER SERVICE AND
QUALITY OF CARE IMPROVED
ADHERENCE TO CHRONIC DISEASE
MANAGEMENT. REDUCED EMERGENCY
VISITS AND REDUCED RE
HOSPITALIZATION RATES SO THAT'S
REALLY OUT OF. WATER METRICS
THAT WILL BE APPLIED DIFFERENTLY
TO THE DIFFERENT PROGRAM
COMPONENTS. THANK YOU- DEPUTY
SECRETARIES NAY YOU BROUGHT UP
ONE KEY WORDS THAT I ALWAYS-
PICK UP ON AND THAT DIVERSITY I
KNOW THAT PROP TO A NINE HAS
OFTEN GOTTEN IN THE WAY OF US
BEING ABLE TO COMPILE DATA AND
RESOURCES RELATED TO THAT. AS IT
IMPACTS COMMUNITIES LANGUAGE
AXES ALL OF THE THINGS AND SO
THAT WAS ACTUALLY A QUESTION
THAT I HAD FOR YOU HOW WELL WE-
ALWAYS TALK ABOUT EQUITY AND
DIVERSITY IT'S OFTEN A CHALLENGE
TO MEASURE. AND SO WHAT IS THE
WHAT IS L. W. D. A.'S OUTREACH
PLAN TO ENSURE THAT THIS
EXPANSION OF THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES. WORKFORCE
PIPELINE WILL BENEFIT
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. WELL
THAT IS- AMONG THE HIGHEST
PRIORITIES OF THIS WHOLE
INITIATIVE. TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE INCREASING LINGUISTICALLY
AND CULTURALLY COMPETENT WORKERS
FOR THE HEALTH CARE SECTOR-
WHICH IMPROVES HEALTH OUTCOMES
FOR THE PEOPLE RECEIVING THOSE
SERVICES. AND AGAIN CREATING NEW
PATHWAYS INTO THESE GOOD JOBS
FOR HISTORICALLY MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES. AND AS YOU SUGGEST
OUR REGION TO THESE COMMUNITIES
WILL BE INTEGRAL TO THE SUCCESS.
OF ALL THE TRADING COMPONENTS
AND WILL BE BUILT INTO A
TRAINING PROGRAM DESIGNED AND
SOLICITATIONS. THROUGH
PARTNERSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
CLOSE CONNECTIONS TO COMMUNITIES
TO LABOR ORGANIZATIONS. FAITH
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT CAN
REALLY TAP THAT ARE CLOSE AND
TRUSTING RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
TARGET. COMMUNITIES AND THESE
TARGET COMMUNITIES WILLINCLUDE
IMMIGRANTS. REFUGEES PEOPLE WITH
MULTIPLE LANGUAGE SKILLS YOU'RE
SITTING ON THE DELZ LOW WAGE
WORKERS OF COLORS. COLOR PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES FORMERLY
HOMELESS JUSTICE INVOLVED. AND
PEOPLE WITH OTHER LIVED
EXPERIENCE THAT CAN BE AN ASSET.
AND HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICE
SETTINGS. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT I KNOW THAT- IN THE PAST
HEARINGS THAT WE HAVE HAD WE'VE
SPOKEN A LOT ABOUT HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS MENTAL HEALTH
ACCESS ABILITY TO RECEIVE CARE-
AND SOMETIMES THESE
CONVERSATIONS ARE IN SILOS AND
TO THE FACT THAT WE ARE PUTTING
MONEY OR POTENTIALLY CREATING A
PIPELINE AND PUTTING FUNDING. TO
ACTUALLY ADDRESS THE LACK OF
WORK FORCE AND THE LACK OF
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS TO DO
THIS WORK. IS THE APPROPRIATE
RESPONSE THAT WE SHOULD BE
HAVING AND SOMETHING BEFORE ALL
THE WORK THAT YOU DO THANK YOU
SO MUCH IF THERE ARE NO.
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO- ISSUE FOR
WINTER OTHER WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROPOSALS- AND WE
WILL START OFF AT THE. BE AN
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL MR
GUTERRES YOU'RE BACK ON. THE
MANAGER AND AGAIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK TO YOU ABOUT OUR WORK FORCE
LITERACY INITIATIVE I WE ARE
REQUESTING TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PANEL TO EXPAND
WORKFORCE LITERACY TRAINING AND
CONTEXTUAL. SEASON
CONTEXTUALIZED ENGLISH DIGITAL
SKILLS AND TECHNICAL SKILLS
TRAINING FOR INCUMBENT ANNUALLY
HIRED WORKERS AS WELL AS FOR
UNEMPLOYED INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT- THIS
WILL ENABLE EMPLOYERS TO BUILD
SKILLED WORKFORCES AND INCREASE
EMPLOYEE RETENTION PROVIDE
PATHWAYS TO HIGHER WAGES AND
BETTER JOBS FOR IMMIGRANTS
REFUGEES. AND OTHER LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENT INDIVIDUALS-
THE FUNDS WILL BE ENABLED AND
EBELING PARTICIPATING EMPLOYERS
ORGANIZED LABOR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS OR TRADE
ASSOCIATIONS THE BILL SKILLED
WORKFORCES AND INCREASE AGAIN
RETENTION PROVIDE PATHWAYS TO
CAREERS HIGHER WAGES BETTER
JOBS- FOR ALL OF THOSE
POPULATIONS THAT I BRIEFLY
MENTIONED- ETP WILL UTILIZE- NEW
PARTNERSHIPS AND EXISTING
PARTNERSHIPS. WITH A CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES- CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS ADULT
SCHOOLS K. THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- NONPROFITS AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARDS
THAT HAVE REFUGEE ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS- AND CHAIR MY BRIEF
REMARKS IN REGARDS TO THIS
INITIATIVE WE THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING THIS REQUEST AND I
WOULD LIKE TO AGAIN TURN IT OVER
TO. A DEPUTY DIRECTOR HAVE YOU
HEARD ABOUT MENTAL WITH YOU ON
THE DEVELOPMENT. ARE MEANT FOR
HIS INITIATIVE. THANK YOU WITH
AGAIN BEFORE I BEGIN YOU HEAR ME
. I THINK MISTER MAYER LEASE IF
YOU CAN SEE CLOSER IN YOUR MIKE
TURN ON YOU CAMERA. WE CAN IF I
CAN. OKAY GOOD IT SO THANK YOU
ARE. I DON'T KNOW BECAUSE I
GREETED THE ARMENIAN REQUEST.
FOR THIRTY MILLION FOR A ONE
TIME- INVESTMENT INTO THE
EXPANSION OF THE INTEGRATED AND
TRAINING. FOR WHICH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS. THIS SAMA INVESTMENT
WILL EXPAND THAT MODEL ACROSS
THE STATE. IT'S THE MODEL IS ONE
THAT COMBINES OCCUPATIONAL
TRAINING AND CONCEPTUAL LEARNING
TO ACCELERATE. COMPLETION AND
PAYMENT OF CREDENTIALS- IT IS
VERY DEPENDED UPON A BROAD MIX
OF PARTNERS WITH THE PRIMARILY
THAT EDUCATION. AND ALSO WITH-
CBO'S AND JOB CENTERS TO SUPPORT
SOME OF THAT OCCUPATION SPECIFIC
TRAINING AND THE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES- WHAT THE INTENT HERE
IS TO CREATE ON RAMPS INTO JOBS
THAT EXIST THAT WILL LEAD THEM
TO QUALITY CHOPS. ALSO ADVANCED
AND THAT THE PART OF THE FUNDING
WILL GO TOWARDS AN EVALUATION
THE EVALUATION. IS TO EVALUATE
THE SUCCESS SOME INSURE THAT
WE'RE DEVELOPING SUSTAINABLE
PROGRAMS AND ALSO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO SUSTAIN
THESE PROGRAMS. BEYOND THE TERM
OF THE GRANT. ON BAD AND THEN
THAT SHALL WE EXPECT TO SERVE
ABOUT SIXTEEN HUNDRED
PARTICIPANTS. BOB THAT'S A HIGH
LEVEL SO BY DANCER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. WE TURN IT OVER
TO- TO RAINY FOR THE NEXT ITEM.
HELPED WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD. GREAT THANK YOU-
CALIFORNIA YOUTH LEADERSHIP
PROGRAMS LANGUAGE JUSTICE
PATHWAY AND MOUTHFUL REALLY
UNIQUE INITIATIVE- THAT IS
ACTUALLY BUILDING ON WORK THAT
THE LABOR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY STARTED A COUPLE YEARS
AGO- THE INTENT HERE IS TO.
RECRUIT AND TRAIN AT RISK YOUTH
WHO WISH TO GO INTO NONPROFIT
WORK- COMMITTEE ORGANIZATIONS
SOCIAL JUSTICE. YOUTH
PARTICIPANTS WILL RECEIVE
TRAINING THROUGH COMMUNITY
COLLEGES- AND YOU ARE IN LEARNED
WITH NONPROFIT SOCIAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS ESPECIALLY LEGAL
SERVICES- AND PROVIDERS OF THAT-
OR ADVOCATES SUPPORT FOR
IMMIGRANT IMMIGRANT RIGHTS IT
IT'S A TWO FOR. I LIKE THIS THIS
INITIATIVE- ON THE ONE HAND WE
NEED MORE ADVOCATES IN- IN LEGAL
LANGUAGE SERVICES FOR
IMMIGRANTS- ALSO THIS CREATES A
GREAT PATHWAY FOR- TWO CAREERS
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE WHO REALLY HAVE
A PASSION FOR THIS TYPE OF WORK.
STUDENTS TO RECEIVE INCOMING
OTHER SUPPORT AND MENTORING
BOTHERED WHILE THEY'RE ENROLLED
IN THE PROGRAM- AND AS I SAID
THEY'RE THEY'RE ACTUALLY
EMPLOYED NOT PROFITS. GETTING
WAGES WHETHER WHETHER DOING ART
AND LEARN AT LEAST IF THE
MINIMUM OF FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN
HOUR- THE OUTCOMES WILL BE. PAID
INTERNSHIPS WITH CBO'S- AND THEN
A POSTSECONDARY CREDENTIAL
AWARDED BY THE COMMITTEE COLLEGE
SO THEY'RE ALREADY ARE FIVE AT
LEAST PARTNERING COMMITTEE
COLLEGES ACROSS THE STATE-
MISSION COLLEGE IN LA FRESNO
CITY COLLEGE DE ANZA COLLEGE IN
SAN JOSE ELLIE TRADE TECH- AND
RECITE COMMITTEE COLLEGE SO I
THINK THE IDEAS YOU'RE USED TO
EXPAND. OUT TO OTHER COLLEGE
PARTNERS IN EXPAND THE WORKING
TO EXPAND THE NUMBER OF YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO GET INTO THIS- THIS
THIS CAREER PATH- I'VE- BLESSING
ALSO IS- AT INTENT HERE IS TO.
IS TRAIN- AND YET WORKS.
MEANINGFUL WORK EXPERIENCE AND
AN EMPLOYMENT GOOD JOBS CAREERS-
330-023-0050 STUDENTS. AND I'LL
LEAVE IT THERE AND CHECK. THANK
YOU MISTER RANEY AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE GRADUATE
MONTHS MYSELF I'M GONNA DO A
LITTLE PLUG FOR EAST LOS ANGELES
COLLEGE- THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE
PROGRAM THE TEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
LEADERSHIP CORP AS PAID
INTERNSHIPS I THINK IT'S
CRITICAL FOR THE DEVELOPMENT. OF
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES MOST OF
WHICH ARE FIRST GENERATION
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES AS WELL-
MYSELF INCLUDED SO PROVIDING A
PATHWAY IN WHICH STUDENTS CAN.
GET PAID WHILE ALSO LEARNING A
SKILL AND DEVELOPMENT DEVELOPING
A PRE LAW PARALEGAL- LOVE FOR A
POTENTIAL OPPORTUNITY AS A AS A
WORK PIPELINE I THINK IS REALLY
GREAT ESPECIALLY THE TRANSLATION
SERVICES FOR. A IMMIGRATION
LEGAL SERVICES WHICH WE KNOW IS
VASTLY NEEDED- IF THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE I'M
GOING TO ASK THAT YOU MOVE ON TO
THE CLIMATE RESILIENCY BCP PLACE. OKAY- THAT. ONCE AGAIN HUNDRED
AMOUNT FROM THE NEEDY WORK FOR
SERVICES BRANCH- DISPLACED
WORKER OIL IN CASPER PRIVATE
FUND IT'S A FIFTEEN MILLION ON
CRIME GENERAL FUND MISTER ROMERO
I'M GOING TO ASK AGAIN THAT YOU
TURN ON YOUR CAMERA AND SPEAK
CLOSER TO THE MICROPHONE. MY
CAMERA IS ON. ARE YOU ABLE TO
HEAR ME. BUT. IF YOU CAN
CONTINUE SPEAKING WE WILL WE
WILL PICK IT UP BUT WE DO NEED
TO SPEAK A LITTLE CLOSER TO THE
MIKE PLEASE YOU SOUND. JUST A
LITTLE FAR AWAY. CONTINUE AND
THEN THE SYSTEM WILL WILL PICK
YOU UP. OKAY VERY GOOD- THIS
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR PILOT IS-
WILL ADDRESS THE NEEDS SPECIFIC
TO THE OIL AND GAS WORKERS
FACING DISPLACEMENT. THIS
FUNDING THE DESIGN PROVIDE TO
PROVIDE FINANCIAL STATEMENTS
THAT COMPLEMENT THE STATE'S
EXISTING. UNEMPLOYMENT SERVICES
TO MINIMIZE DISRUPTIONS TO THEIR
PERSONAL LIVES. AND THAT ALSO IS
INTENDED AND DESIGNED TO
COMPLEMENT THE WEEK OVER THIS TO
CREATE WORKERS SERVICES AND
PROGRAMS. SO WHAT I MEAN BY THAT
IS THAT WE HAVE RESOURCES THAT
TARGET THIS LOOK LET'S LOOK AT
WORKERS PROPERLY THIS FUND WILL
TARGET GAS AND OIL WORKERS. ON
SPECIFIC- SPENDING ON. HELLO
CLIMATE WITH EXISTING PARTNERS
TO ENSURE THAT WERE ABLE TO
REACH THESE WORKERS M. .COM. AND
BASICALLY TO ALIGN WITH OTHER
COMPLEMENTARY INVESTMENTS AND
EFFORTS- THAT AFFECTS THE
PROGRAM IN ACTION AGAINST ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. ARE
YOU PROVIDING TO SOMEONE ELSE TO
SPEAK ON THIS. YES LET ME TURN
IT OVER TO- THE WELL CAPPING
WEALTH OR PERSPECTIVES AND BRING
. THANK YOU HAVE A YEAR- WELL
CAPPING WORK FIRST PILOT FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME FUNDS-
IN INSPIRING FASHION THE STATE
WORKFORCE BOARDS CAN INVEST THIS
IN INDUSTRY BASED PARTNERSHIPS
BY INDUSTRY. AS WELL AS
ORGANIZED LABOR SCHOOLS
COLLEGES- LOCAL WORKFORCE BOARDS
COMMITTEE BASED ORGAIZATIONS-
FIFTEEN HUNDRED WILL BE TRAINED-
WILL WORK WITH ALSO THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION WHICH
IS REQUESTING TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THAT TO PLUG
ORPHANED OIL AND GAS WELLS- SO
WE'RE BUILDING IN. TO THE WORK
OF DEPARTMENT CONSERVATION THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO ACTUALLY TRAIN
PEOPLE FOR THE JOBS TO BE
CREATED BY THAT DEMAND FOR THE
TWO HUNDRED BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT I SHOULD SAY THAT
THERE'S ALSO FEDERAL DOLLARS ARE
BEING INVESTED THERE TOO THAT
WILL CREATE- WHAT WE THINK IS
SIGNIFICANT THE DEMAND FOR- FOR
THESE WORKERS- WELL CAPPING MARC
REQUIRED SKILLS THAT ARE COMMON.
IN SEVERAL SEVERAL OF THE
CONSTRUCTION TRADES AND
ESPECIALLY THE OF THOSE ALIGNED
WITH THE OIL AND GAS DRILLING
DURING TENSION IS TO TRANSITION
CURRENT WORKERS- AS WELL AS MOVE
DISLOCATED WORKERS WHO WANT TO
WORK IN OIL CAPPING- THE MOVE
THEM NTO THE INTO THE PIPELINE
FOR GOOD QUALITY JOBS. UP WITH
UP. IN FIVE FOUR BUILDING ON IT
D. A. S. APPROVED PROGRAMS THAT
SERVE- KERN COUNTY- ARE HIGH
ROAD CONSTRUCTION CREWS PROGRAM
WILL DO WILL BE ALIGNED TO HELP
PROVIDE ACCESS POINTS- TO- TO
THESE THESE JOBS AS WELL AS
COORDINATION WITH- IT IS WORK
FOR SERVICES BRANCH AS YOU JUST
HEARD THAT THE WORK THAT THEY'RE
DOING WITH THIS AT THIS PLACE TO
OIL AND GAS WORKERS- SO AT. THE
BUILDING ON THE DEMAND CREATED
BY THE INVESTMENTS AND THE
CREDIT PATHWAYS INTO THE JOBS
FOR DISLOCATED WORKERS BUT ALSO
THOSE WORKERS WHO ARE CURRENTLY
IN THE INDUSTRY BUT WHAT. WHAT
TRANSITION. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I'M NOT SURE WHO I'M
PIVOTING TO. THANK YOU MISS
RAINY I BELIEVE WE'RE GOING BACK
TO MR ROMERO FOR THE SIXTY
MILLION FOR LOW CARBON ECONOMIC
OR A COMIC GRANT PROGRAMS. THAT
THAT WOULD BE MADE OUT OF CHAIR
THAT'S OKAY. WELL THEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU. YES YOU'RE
CORRECT IT IS YOU. DON'T KNOW
THAT. OKAY GOOD SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THREE YEARS- WE'RE
BUILDING ON OUR HIGH ROAD
TRAINING PARTNERSHIP INITIATIVE
IN A HIGHER CONSTRUCTION
CAREERS- THAT INVESTMENT WILL
TRAIN ANOTHER FORTY THREE
HUNDRED WORKERS- APPROXIMATELY
AT LEAST- FOCUSED ON EXPANDING-
AND IT WILL. PRIMARILY BUILDING
NEW NON CONSTRUCTION
APPRENTICESHIPS BUT ALSO
BUILDING ON TOP OF STATE
APPROVED APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
SO OUR PRE APPRENTICESHIP
TRAINING THAT'S A HIRING
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS ACCESS
AGAIN IN THE STATE APPROVED
APPRENTICESHIP- AND DEMAND FOR
WORK IS DRIVEN- AT BY STATE
INVESTMENT IN INFRASTRUCTURE
PROCESS THE FEDERAL INVESTMENTS
IN INFRASTRUCTURE SO WE SEE A
LOT OF OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE
PEOPLE INTO. REALLY GOOD QUALITY
JOBS WHO OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE
BEEN LOCKED OUT OF THE
OPPORTUNITY THIS THIS ECONOMIC
PROSPERITY COMING- I THINK I'LL
BE WITH. IN THE INTEREST OF TIME
MANAGER UNLESS QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU MISTER RAINY I THINK WHAT WE
JUST HEARD IS PART OF A LARGER
CONVERSATION RELATED TO. OUR
CLIMATE RESILIENCY CLIMATE JOBS
GREEN JOBS OF SCALE AND SO IT'S
A LARGER CONVERSATION THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DID SEVERAL OF US
ARE HAVING WITH THE TRADES AS
WELL. AND SO I'M CURIOUS AS TO
THE ADMINISTRATION HAVE
ESTIMATES ABOUT HOW MANY
DISPLACED OIL AND GAS WORKERS
WILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR EDT AND CW
TV PROGRAMS. HOW WERE THE AMOUNT
OF FIFTY MILLION FOR EDT AND THE
FIFTEEN MILLION FIFTEEN MILLION
FOR CWD BE DEVELOPED. THAT'S A
GREAT QUESTION I MAKE MAYBE I
COULD START MANAGER IF I IF
THAT'S OKAY- PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FOUR WE LOOK AT DATA ON THE
NUMBER OF WHEN THE GAS
EXTRACTION WORKERS IN KERN
COUNTY ALONE- IN IT IT NUMBERS
BETWEEN FIFTEEN HUNDRED AND TWO
THOUSAND WORKERS- AND THE-
BOILING CAP. I'M SORRY THE OIL
AND GAS- ORPHAN WELL CAPPING
PILOT- IT'S ENOUGH TO TARGET
FIFTEEN HUNDRED WORKERS- BUT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO POINT
OUT THAT. WITH THE INVESTMENT OF
THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FROM CONSERVATION- IT IT'LL
DRIVE DEMAND FOR WORKERS IN IN
THAT SUB SECTOR BOB. READ PRETTY
DRAMATICALLY- IN ADDITION TO THE
FEDERAL INVESTMENT SO FAR IN THE
PCP FOR CONSERVATION FOR THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR A
WHILE CAPPING. THE ESTIMATE-
THAT THE CREATION OF EIGHT
THOUSAND JOBS- THREE THOUSAND OF
THOSE MORE THAN THREE THOUSAND
OF THOSE WOULD BE DIRECT JOBS-
SO WE SEE THAT THERE'S- THREE-
SIGNIFICANT DEMAND. FOR JOBS SO
WE HAVE A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
TRINITY IN A PART OF CALIFORNIA
THAT REALLY NEEDS- THESE GOOD
QUALITY JOBS- TO BUILD A PATH
WHICH TO THEM- THE THESE ARE
HIGHLY SKILLED- AT LEAST IN THE
IN THE WELL CAPPING WORK THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE- CAPPING
OF THE- ORPHAN OIL WELLS. IT'S
HIGHLY SKILLED WELL COMPENSATED
WORK- THE WAGE RATES ARE FROM
EIGHTY DOLLARS AN HOUR TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS AN
HOUR- AND- YEAH. SO I THINK
THERE'S SIGNIFICANT DEMAND THE
DATA BACKS IT UP. MISTER LUCKY.
YES CERTAINLY I'M. JUST
FOLLOWING UP ON THAT PARTICULAR
ISSUE THE IDEA OF MOVING WORKERS
IN POSITIONS WITH AN AVERAGE
COMPENSATION OF A HUNDRED THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR. WHERE
THE MAJORITY OF HEALTH INSURANCE
RETIREMENT BENEFITS. NOT
INCLUDED IN THAT FIGURE. AND 23%
ARE UNIONIZED. MOVING THEM TO
STATE SPONSORED GREEN ENERGY
JOBS. THAT HAVE LOWER AVERAGE
SALARIES AND LOWER RATES OF
UNIONIZATION. WAS NOTHING SHORT
OF NOT REAL. LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS
HAVE INDICATED THE AN EQUITABLE
RELIEF PROGRAM WOULD BE MORE IN
THE RANGE OF FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY MILLION- FOR WAGE
SUBSIDIES AND TRAINING TO HELP
WORKERS WHAT ADDITIONALLY
REQUIRE THE STATE TO INVEST AS
MUCH THESE ARE LABOR REPORTS A
SEVENTY SIX BILLION WITH A B.
ENTER THE GREEN ENERGY SECTOR.
SO I'M JUST TRYING TO. BALANCE
THIS FIFTY MILLION WITH WHAT IT
WOULD REALLY COST TO- TO THE BUT
THESE WORKERS THAT ARE BEING
PUSHED OUT OF OUR ECONOMY. BACK
INTO A GREEN ENERGY JOBS. CAN
YOU HELP ME UNDERSTAND THAT. AND
RECONCILE THE DISPARITY THERE.
THANK YOU ALL TO ALL TRY TO
RESPOND TO THAT- THE WELL
CAPPING A PILOT IS FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS AND IT'S REALLY
FOCUSED ON- JOBS CREATED BY THE
THAT- WELL CAPPING INVESTMENTS
THROUGH CONSERVATION FROM. FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SO THERE
ARE WORKERS IN OIL AND GAS
DRILLING THEIR HIGHLY PAID WELL
CAUGHT COMPENSATED. WORKERS AS I
AS I SAID AS YOU POINTED OUT-
THIS THIS WORK HAS THE POTENTIAL
TO UP- PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THOSE WORKERS WHO WHO OTHERWISE
MAY BE AFFECTED- BY BY DOWNTURN
THAT SECTOR- TO GO TO WORK IN A
HIGHLY COMPENSATED WORK DOING
THAT THE WELL CAPPING- IT ALSO
CREATES OPPORTUNITIES I THINK
FOR OTHER WORKERS. IN KERN
COUNTY- TO GO THROUGH TRAINING
SIGNIFICAN TRAINING. THROUGH
EXISTING STATE APPROVED
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS THAT
SERVE KERN COUNTY- TO GO TO
WORK- IN THE END WELL CAPPING.
SO IT'S ONE OF THOSE I THINK
RARE OPPORTUNITIES WERE IN
INVESTING IN CLIMATE MITIGATION
IN A WAY THAT'S CREATING NEW
JOBS AND BUILDING TRAINING
PROGRAMS THAT REALLY FOCUSED ON
TRANSITIONING CURRENT WORKERS
EXCITING. OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THOSE HAVE BEEN DISPLACED. BUT
YOU'RE YOU'RE RIGHT IT'S A MUCH
BIGGER. OKAY I THINK YOU
MISUNDERSTOOD ME BUT THAT WAS
GOOD INFORMATION ABOUT THE
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME
FUNDS BUT I'M TALKING ABOUT MORE
TO THE E. D. D. THE PERSON. THE
DISPARITY BETWEEN THE FIVE ZERO
THE FIFTY MILLION VERSUS THE
SEVENTY SIX BILLION DOLLARS THAT
IT WOULD TAKE. TO TO MAKE THE
SYSTEM HALL. FOR THESE WORKERS.
THIS FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
PARDON- FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
ARE INTENDED TO ASSIST EMPLOYERS
THAT ARE ALREADY DISLOCATED ARM
AND THAT'S THE NATURE OF THAT
FUND AND HOW IT'S DESIGNED- IT'S
NOT AS INTENDED TO REPLACE.
THOSE DROPS PER SE OKAY REALLY.
WE SONGS WERE CLEAR ON THAT THAT
THAT DOESN'T COME CLOSE TO-
MAKING THOSE WORKERS HOLE. THAT
THAT'S ALL I'M TRYING TO CLARIFY
HERE THAT IT'S A IT'S A- I'M A
STEP CERTAINLY BUT A VERY SMALL
ONE. THANK YOU MISTER LACKING
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. OKAY
HEARING NONE THANK YOU ALL SO
MUCH FOR IS THAT A PANEL NUMBER
FOUR WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE SUPPLY CHAIN
RESILIENCE- TRAINING CAMPUSES
LET'S BEGIN AGAIN- MISTER RANEY
HERE ON. THANK YOU VENTURE.
MEMBERS THE GOOD MOVEMENT
WORKFORCE TRAINING CENTER-
REQUESTING A HUNDRED TEN MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THREE YEARS BUT THE
TOTAL COST OF THE TRAINING
CENTER IS ACTUALLY HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS- SO WE'RE ASKING
FOR A HUNDRED TEN- THIS BUILDS
ON ACTUALLY HIRING TRAINING
PARTNERSHIP WORK WE'VE DONE- AT
THE PORT OF LOS ANGELES IN LONG
BEACH OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS- TO LABOR MANAGEMENT
PARTNERSHIP AMONG. THE LONG TO
WORKERS I'LL W. THE LA PORT THE
PMA THE SECOND MARITIME
ASSOCIATION AND THE PORT
TERMINAL OPERATORS AT THE PORT
OF LA IN THE PORT OF LONG BEACH
AS YOU KNOW- IT'S THE SAN PEDRO-
BAYPORT COMPLEX HANDLES MORE
CONTAINERS PER SHIP CALL THAN
ANY OTHER PORT COMPLEX IN THE
WORLD- YET IT DOESN'T HAVE A
CENTRALIZED LOCATION FOR
WORKFORCE TRAINING. SO THE
INTENT HERE IS TO CREATE A SAFE
TRAINING SPACE AWAY FROM THE
BUSY ACTIVITIES OF THE
TERMINALS- AND ONE THAT CAN
REPLICATE THE COULDN'T GOODS
MOVEMENT ENVIRONMENTS SUCH AS
THE MARINE CARGO TERMINALS- THE
LA LONG BEACH PORT SET ASIDE A
FIFTEEN ACRE SITE FOR THE
TRAINING CENTER- THE CENTER OF
THE TYPE OF TRAINING WILL FOCUS
ON- WOULD INCLUDE EXPANDED
LASHER TRAINING WHICH WE STARTED
HIRING TRAINING PARTNERSHIP
THERE. ZERO EMISSION CARGO
HANDLING EQUIPMENT TRAINING FOR
WORKERS TO LEARN HOW TO OPERATE
MAINTAIN REPAIR EQUIPMENT- THAT
DIRECTLY SUPPORTS INDUSTRIES OUT
LOW EMISSIONS TRANSITION OF
MAINTENANCE AND REPAIR ALSO OF.
AUTOMATED EQUIPMENT- THE- THE
OTHER IN HERE IS- IS BROAD. IN
AND I THINK AMBITIOUS- IT'S A
REALLY IMPACT THE REGION AND THE
ENTIRE SUPPLY CHAIN. PROVIDING
SPACE FOR OTHER HIRING EMPLOYERS
THAT ARE SEEKING TO TRAIN THEIR
WORKFORCES. ARE AFRAID EQUIPMENT
INCLUDING TRUCKS FORKLIFTS SHIP
TO SHORE CRANES- AND I'LL LEAVE
IT THERE MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU
MISTER RAINY ARE YOU HAPPENING
TO SOMEONE ELSE. I DON'T BELIEVE
SO OKAY THEN WE'LL GOTO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOLLOWED
BY L. A. U. BERMAN A FINANCE-
PATRICK TOPPIN- NO FURTHER
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
. THANK YOU MISTER TOPPEN HELLO
. DELBERT WHAT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE OUR OFFICE
HOURS PUBLISHED A PIECE ABOUT A
WAITING THE ENTIRE SUPPLY CHAIN
RESILIENCY PROPOSAL IN
CONCLUDING THAT THE TRAINING
CAMPUS RAISE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER- YOU POINT OUT THAT
THAT- YEAH THAT THE CAMPUS IS
NOT LIKELY TO MATERIALLY IMPROVE
SUPPLY CHAIN RESTRICTIONS- AT
THE PORTS RIGHT NOW- THAT WE'VE
SEEN AS RESULT OF THE PROJECT
PANDEMIC IN RECENT YEARS- BUT IT
COULD PROVE HELPFUL IN THE LONG
TERM. WE THINK ONE OF THE KEY
QUESTIONS WORK FOR THIS COMPANY
AND THE LEGISLATURE TRUMP
GRAPPLING WITH HOW TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE CAMPUS IS TO
TURN. ON WHAT'S THE NATURE OF
THE WORK FORCE SHORTAGE THAT
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION SPEAKS
UP EITHER CURRENTLY OR IN THE
FUTURE AND TO ENSURE THAT
TRAINING CAPACITY IS THE
BOTTLENECK FOR THAT SHORTAGE-
BECAUSE THE FIRST WORKFORCE
SHORTAGE. IT COULD BE IN OTHER
AREAS IT MIGHT NOT BE TRAINING
RELATED AND WE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE ARM IS ABLE
TO ADDRESS THAT THE PROBLEM AT
ITS ROOT CAUSE- AND ENSURE THAT
THAT THERE ARE NO WORKFORCE
SUPPLY CONCERNS AT THE. PORTS IN
THE FUTURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MAY ALAMO. ABOUT OF QUESTIONS AS
UP AS WELL MISS RANEY. RUN THE
DATA. THE TRAINING AND WORK AND
WORKER SHORTAGE RELATED TO THE
GOODS MOVEMENT AT THE PORTS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- I THOUGHT
I THOUGHT THE L. A. AS- ANALYSIS
WAS WAS QUITE GOOD AS USUAL-
THE- THE- NATURE OF THE
SHORTAGE- IS THAT THERE. THERE
ISN'T TRAINING CAPACITY PORT. SO
HAVE. LONG SHOT WORKERS THERE'S
NO SHORTAGE OF PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO GO TO WORK AT THE PORT THE
WAGES ARE QUITE GOOD- THERE LONG
LONG WAITING LISTS OF PEOPLE WHO
WOULD WHO WOULD LOVE TO BECOME
LONGER WORKERS- THE ISSUE IS. US
LITERALLY SPACE TO DO THE
TRAINING SO. ALL THE LONGER
WORKERS ARE PROVIDED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ACTUALLY- TRAIN
TO BE CRANE OPERATORS FOR
EXAMPLE- BUT THE TRAINING IS
SCATTERED ACROSS. SEVERAL
DIFFERENT PARCELS AROUND THE
PORT. AND AS YOU MIGHT IMAGINE
UP THE CREEK THEY TRAIN ON
ACTIVE CRANES- AND AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE THOSE CRANES THERE THERE
NO- EACH. CHANGE THAT ARE.
WORKING ON TO MOVE CARGO AROUND
AROUND THE AT THE TERMINALS- SO
THERE'S NO PLACE FOR WORKERS TO
GET TRAINED AND THAT SORT OF. A
PROBLEM IS CAUSING. A SHORTAGE
OF SKILLS AND TRAINING AT THE
PORT SO AND I UNDERSTAND. AND
AGREE THAT THIS THIS IS A LONG
GAME STUFF IS NOT GOING TO SOLVE
THE PROBLEM OVERNIGHT. BUT IT'S
A PROBLEM THAT'S BEEN IN
EXISTENCE AT THE PORT FOR SOME
TIME SO- THAT- THE REQUEST HERE
IS TO START TO SOLVE THAT
PROBLEM BY BUILDING A TRAINING
CENTER ON THE FIFTEEN ACRE
PARCEL- SO TO REALLY ITS
TRAINING CAPACITY AND NOT. BUT
NOT A JOB QUALITY ISSUE IT'S NOT
AN ACCESS TO JOBS ISSUE IT IT
REALLY COMES DOWN TO HAVING. A
PLACE TO HAVE EQUIPMENT. THAT
YOU CAN TRAIN PEOPLE IN A SAFE
MANNER- SO WE CAN START
RESPONDING TO THE TO THE
SHORTAGES. OF SKILLS OF THE PORT
OF LA AND LONG BEACH. THANK YOU
MISTER RANEY I BEEN TO BOTH
THOSE PORTS AND THEY ARE MASSIVE
AND JUST. INCREDIBLE TO JUST
WATCH IT OPERATE AND HOW IT.
REALLY JUST- PROVIDES ALL THE
GOODS AND SERVICES NOT ONLY FOR
THE STATE FOR THE NATION. AS A
FOLLOW UP THIS PROPOSAL DOES NOT
COVER THE ENTIRE PROJECT COST TO
BUILD THE CAMPUS. CAN SEE W. D.
B. D. PROVIDE ADDITIONAL DETAILS
ON HOW. REMAINING COSTS WILL BE
FUNDED. THE LA AND LONG BEACH
PORTS WILL PICK UP THE
DIFFERENCE OF THAT COST- AS I
SAID WE'RE WE'RE- REQUESTING A
HUNDRED TEN MILLION DOLLARS THE
TOTAL COST IS CLOSER TO A
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE- THE DIFFERENCE THERE'S
GONNA BE PICKED UP BY THE LA AND
LONG BEACH PORTS. AND AS A
FOLLOW UP IS THAT A FORMAL
AGREEMENT- THAT'S THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION I DO BELIEVE THAT- THAT
THE ALLEY PORTANT LA AT THE LONG
BEACH PORTS HAVE UP FORMALLY
DEVELOPED THE BUDGET- AND HAVE
SET ASIDE FUNDING- TO MAKE UP
THE DIFFERENCE OF THAT COST.
OKAY WHEN YOU GET A MOMENT CAN
YOU- CAN WE FOLLOW UP ON THAT
JUST TO BE SURE. YES ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU IF THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO- ISSUE
NUMBER SIX WHICH I BELIEVE IS
OUR LAST ISSUE OF THE DAY. AND
THIS IS THE D. I. R. BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSALS LET'S BEGIN
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS I BELIEVE
WE HAVE MISSED ANNA PAYING ON
THE LINE. PARDON ME. GOOD
AFTERNOON- DEVELOPING WITH
PERMANENT US RELATIONS. I GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME- GIVE A VERY
HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW OF THE SIX
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS IN FRONT
OF YOU TODAY FOR DISCUSSION.
THOSE ARE REQUESTING ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES THAT WILL HELP OUR
DEPARTMENT MEET OUR INCREASING
WORKLOAD DEMANDS. AS WELL AS
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR WORKER AND
EMPLOYER OUTREACH ACTIVITIES. I
BELIEVE BCPS COVER ENHANCE
ENFORCEMENT AND COMPLIANCE
RESOURCES FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO
IMPLEMENT PROVISIONS RELATED TO
RECENTLY CHAPTER LEGISLATION.
LEGAL AND ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT
TO ADDRESS RISING WORKLOADS IN
THE SUBSEQUENT INJURY BENEFIT
TRUST FUND PROGRAM. LEGAL
SUPPORT FOR THE OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY AND HEALTH APPEALS BOARD
TO ADDRESS INCREASES IN
PETITIONS FOR RECONSIDERATION AS
WELL AS RATES OF MANDATES. LEGAL
AND ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT FOR.
THE OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND
HEALTH STANDARDS BOARD TO ASSIST
WITH LEGAL UNIT WORKLOAD AND
HELP PROVIDE TIMELY PROCESSING
OF VARIANCE APPLICATIONS
RESEARCH AND DATA. ANALYSIS
RESOURCES FOR THE DIVISION OF
WORKERS COMPENSATION MEDICAL
UNIT AND LASTLY ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE REACHING
EVERY CALIFORNIA ARE REACH
CAMPAIGN TO EXPAND THEIR WORK IN
EDUCATING WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS
ON STATE LABOR LAWS. I WILL PARK
THERE IN CASE THE COMMITTEE
WOULD LIKE A WALK THROUGH OF ANY
OF THE SPECIFIC RESOURCE
SOFTWARE PREFERS TO HAVE MAJOR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MISS PAYING
ARE YOU HAVING TO ANY ADDITIONAL
PANELISTS. I JUST HEARD
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ARE AWARE
OF. THANK YOU SO MUCH WILL GO TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
FOLLOWED BY L. L. THANK YOU
YEAH- PATRICK TOPPING DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. NO FURTHER. THINGS
TO ADD THANK YOU. HELLO GENERAL
MOTORS WE HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH
A PACKAGE OF PROPOSALS. THANK
YOU WE HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS-
STAFF NOTES THE SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF VACANCIES AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS CURRENTLY ESTIMATED AT
APPROXIMATELY 25% JUST HIGH WHAT
ARE THE DEPARTMENTS RECRUITING
HIRING AND RETENTION STRATEGIES
FOR THE SHORT AND LONG TERM. I'M
CHAIR IN A PAYING DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS AS YOU MAY
KNOW HOW DR LOST ITS HIRING
DELEGATION FOR ALL CIVIL SERVICE
APPOINTMENTS IN APRIL TWENTY
NINETEEN. AND UNDERWENT A HIRING
FREEZE FOR ALMOST SIX MONTHS
FOLLOWING. IN MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE I. R. REGAINED
ITS HIRING AUTHORITY AND SINCE
THEN WE'VE ADE CONSIDERABLE
PROGRESS ON FILLING OUR
VACANCIES WHICH CONTINUES TO BE
A TOP DEPARTMENTAL PRIORITY. IS
TO PROVIDE SOME MORE CONTEXT IN
TWENTY NINETEEN THE DEPARTMENT
MADE TWENTY APPOINTMENTS. IN
TWENTY TWENTY WE MAY BE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY TWO APPOINTMENTS.
AND IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE MADE
SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
APPOINTMENTS AND SO THAT'S MORE
THAN A 210050% INCREASE. FROM
THE PREVIOUS YEAR ARE THERE ARE
STILL SOME WORK. TO BE DONE
ABOUT OVER THE COMING YEARS WERE
PLANNING ON CONTINUING TO BUILD
ON THE STRATEGIES WE'VE
IMPLEMENTED TO CONTINUE MAKING
PROGRESS ON HIRING. AND SO TO
POINT OUT SOME EXAMPLES OF
SUCCESSFUL STRATEGIES WE'VE
IMPLEMENTED. I'M HIRING WE
TRAINED ALL OF OUR HIRING. AND
SUPERVISORS ON COLLEGE OUR
HIRING PRACTICES TO ENSURE
COMPLIANCE WITH THE MERIT BASED
HIRING SYSTEM WE'VE DEVELOPED
TOOL KIT OF RESOURCES AND JOB
AIDS FOR STAFF INVOLVED IN
HIRING. TO ASSIST IN THE
DROPPING OF BEAUTY STATEMENTS
INTERVIEW QUESTIONS AND
COMPLETION OF HIRING PACKAGES.
WE'VE MADE EXAMS MORE ACCESSIBLE
THROUGH AUTOMATION SO THIS
ALLOWS PROTECT POTENTIAL
APPLICANTS TO QUALIFY FOR HIGH
PRIORITY POSITIONS SUCH AS- THAT
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S-
INDUSTRIAL HYGIENISTS AND SAFETY
ENGINEERS. PREVIOUSLY THIS WAS A
PAPER BASED PROCESS. OUT WE ALSO
HAVE BEEN MORE STRATEGIC IN OUR
HIRING INTERVIEWING LARGER POOL
OF CANDIDATES TO ALLOW US TO
MAKE MULTIPLE HIRES. FOR EXAMPLE
WE HAD A RECENT DIVISION DOT
INTERVIEWED OVER FORTY
APPLICANTS TO FILL SIXTEEN LEGAL
POSITIONS. AND LASTLY WE'RE
DOING A REVIEW OF OUR HIRING
PROCESS TO HELP US IDENTIFY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR IMPROVED
EFFICIENCY. ON THE RECRUITMENT
SIDE I WE'VE BEEN HOSTING AND
ATTENDING IN PERSON AND ONLINE
CAREER FAIRS LAST YEAR ACTUALLY
CALIFORNIA HELD ITS FIRST ONLINE
RECRUITMENT FAIR WHICH HAD OVER
EIGHTY PERSPECTIVE APPLICANTS.
AND WE'VE ALSO SIGNIFICANTLY
EXPANDED OUR ADVERTISING. ON OUR
JOB POSTINGS ON ONLINE
RECRUITMENT SITES PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS INDUSTRY NEWS
SITES AS WELL AS THROUGH
PARTNERSHIPS WITH UNIVERSITIES
AND LASTLY ON RETENTION I WE ARE
IT IS REALLY MAKING AN EFFORT TO
RECOGNIZE THE VALUABLE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF OUR TEAM. I
INCLUDING REESTABLISHING A SKIP
SUPERIOR ACCOMPLISHMENT AWARDS
TED BE ABLE TO TAKE SOME TIME TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THOSE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AS WELL AS
FILLING OUR VACANCIES TO
ALLEVIATE WORKLOAD ON A SIXTEEN
TEAMS. AND LASTLY PROMOTING
UPWARD MOBILITY OR TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES AS WELL AS
DEPARTMENT WHY GIADA JOB
OPPORTUNITIES TO ENCOURAGE
CONTINUED GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT
WITHIN OUR DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU
MISS PAYING I BELIEVE THAT THIS
IS THE FIRST TIME THAT YOU ARE
PRESENTING AND BUDGETS OF FOR
THAT I RECALL AND JUST REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR ATTENTION TO
DETAIL. IN THE RESPONSES TO THE
QUESTIONS- I JUST A FOLLOW UP
BEFORE WE END THERE HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANT REPORTED DELAYS IN
SETTING HEARINGS THROUGH THE
DIVISION OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT TO RESOLVE WAGE
THEFT CLAIMS. WITH THESE
ADDITIONAL IMPLEMENTATION
MANDATES AND REQUESTED
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WELL THE I.
R. BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THE REDUCE
TIMELINE AND BACKLOGS. THANK YOU
MENTOR I DEVELOPING DEPARTMENT
US RELATIONS THANK YOU FOR THE
FOR THE WARM WELCOME ALSO THIS
IS MY FIRST TIME. I THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTIONS AS YOU MENTION
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE
HAS EXPERIENCED DELAYS IN THE
SEVEN CITATION HEARINGS AND WAGE
CLAIM HEARINGS. AND THESE DELAYS
ARE RESULT OF. STOPPING
CHALLENGES AND THE INHERENT
CHALLENGES OF TRANSITIONING TO A
VIRTUAL ENVIRONMENT DURING THE
PANDEMIC I DO WANT TO STAY
CONNECTED TO THE PREVIOUS
RESPONSE BUT MUCH OF THE
STRATEGY TO ADDRESS THESE
TIMELINE ALIGNS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT WHY PRIORITY OF
CONTINUE. TO HIRE OUR
ENFORCEMENT STAFF AND THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE HAS BEEN
WORKING DILIGENTLY TO STAFF UP
ITS WAGE CLAIM EDUCATION. EURO
FIELD AND FORCE MET AND WE GO
UNITS AND SO JUST TO PROVIDE
SOME MORE INFORMATION ON SOME OF
THE EFFORTS TO DATE. LAST YEAR
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE
HIRED EIGHTY SIX INDIVIDUALS IN
VARIOUS CLASSIFICATIONS ON ITS
WAGE CLAIM ADJUDICATION UNITS.
ARE IN THEIR BUREAU FIELD
ENFORCEMENT LAST YEAR THEY
HIRED. FORTY THREE INDIVIDUALS
IN THIS YEAR THEY'RE CURRENTLY
WORKING TO RECRUIT ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS AS WELL AND THE LEGAL
UNIT THEY HIRED TEN INDIVIDUALS
AND THIS YEAR ARE CURRENTLY
RECRUITING FOR TWENTY FOUR. OPEN
POSITIONS AND JUST TO PROVIDE A
BIT MORE BACKGROUND SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES AS WELL. I DO TOO THE
SHIP TO TELEPHONE IN VIRTUAL
HEARINGS DURING THE PANDEMIC OF
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE
DEDICATED A CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT
OF TIME TO DEVELOPING REMOTE
OPERATION PROTOCOLS TO ENSURE
DUE PROCESS. AND PRIOR ACTUALLY
TO TWENTY TWENTY TWO THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S. HEARING OFFICERS
HAD TO OBTAIN AGREEMENT FROM ALL
PARTIES IN A WAGE CLAIM CARE. TO
BE ABLE TO HOLD A HEARING.
VIRTUALLY I WHICH AS YOU COULD
IMAGINE CANNONBALLS SEVERAL
PARTIES BUT AFTER THE PASSAGE OF
AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT HEARING
OFFICERS ARE ACTUALLY NOW
PROVIDED DISCRETION ON HOW TO
HOLD HEARINGS WHICH WILL ALSO
HELP WITH THE WAIT TIMES. AND SO
AND LOST I JUST WOULD LIKE TO
MENTION THAT THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER HAS ALSO BEEN VERY
PROACTIVE IN IDENTIFYING
AUTOMATION OPPORTUNITIES TO
PROVIDE INTERNALIZATION TO
IMPROVE. INTERNAL OPERATIONS AS
WELL AS IMPROVE PUBLIC ACCESS.
TO OUR SERVICES I'M SORRY IT'S
LIKE TO SURE ABOUT BEING OF LAST
YEAR BUT LEAVE COMMISSION OFFICE
LUNCHEON ON. WAY CLAIM AND
QUESTION SPANISH. THANK YOU FOR
MUCH AGAIN FOR THE EXTENT OF
DETAILED QUESTIONS AND AGAIN
WELCOME TO SUB FOR- AND IF THERE
ARE NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AND I ALSO JUST A AS A-
AS A POINT OF PRIVILEGE I JUST
WANNA SAY THANK YOU TO YOU AND
THE COMMISSIONER IN THE
DEPARTMENT. FOR SETTING UP THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF COLD WITH
SICKLY JUST RECENTLY A SAID NOW-
WORKERS- EMPLOYERS I WILL HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
ENSURE THE SAFETY. OF THOSE AT
WORK IN IN AND THEIR- PLACES THE
BUSINESS WHILE WE ALSO MOVE
FORWARD WITH SAFE ECONOMICAL BUT
RECOVERY SO MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
WORK ON THAT AS WELL. AND GIVEN
THAT- WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH- PUBLIC COMMENT.
LET ME MAKE SURE THAT WE- HAS
HAD THE INFORMATION NECESSARY
877-692-8957 PUBLIC ACCESS CODE
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR
FOUR AND WE WILL BEGIN WITH-
FOLKS IN THE HEARING ROOM MR
MCHALE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CHRIS
MAKAYLA ON BEHALF OF THE
HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND WE WANT TO SUPPORT A VOICE
SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL YOUR ITEM. THE ISSUE TO
ON THE U. I. A. FUNDED PAYMENT-
WE WOULD DEFINITELY URGE YOUR
ADOPTION OF THAT AND PERHAPS-
CONSIDERATION FOR. AN
ACCELERATIONOF THAT PATTERN IF-
THE REVENUES CONTINUE TO STAY AS
THEY ARE. OF THE STATE WILL SAVE
CONSIDERABLY A FAIR AMOUNT OF
MONEY HI THIS YEAR YOU'RE SLATED
TO PAY FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN INTEREST THE
PRINCIPAL IS PAID BACK BY THE
EMPLOYER COMMUNITY- IN THE STATE
BEGINNING IN ELEVEN MONTHS-
SOMEWHERE IN THE- RANGE OF ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN GROWING EXPONENTIALLY
THERE AFTER. THERE'S BEEN SOME
DISCUSSION MADAM CHAIR ABOUT THE
NOTION OF TAX CREDITS AND I
WOULD POINT OUT THE FACT THAT.
TAX CREDITS REQUIRE A TAX
LIABILITY THERE A DOLLAR FOR
DOLLAR REDUCTION IN TAX
LIABILITY BUT THERE ARE MANY
MEMBERS FOR EXAMPLE IN THE
HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY IN OUR AREA
AND- ELSEWHERE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. THAT ARE NOT PROFITABLE
RIGHT NOW SO THE NOTION OF A TAX
CREDIT WOULD NOT BE BENEFICIAL
THERE MAY BE OTHER AVENUES LIKE
GRANTS OR SOME SORT OF PAYROLL
DEDUCTION IN THAT REGARD THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS IN THE
HEARING ROOM SEEING NONE LET'S
GO TO THE PHONE LINES. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THAT THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE ABOUT
TWENTY IN Q. WE'LL GO TO LINE
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND
JUST BEFORE WE BEGIN PUBLIC
CONFIDENCE IN IT. EACH COLOR HAS
ONE MINUTE YEAH. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS STANDING IN
LINE WITH THAT SOMEONE ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES CENTER AND I AM
NOT RESTED AND I'M WORKING
CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING CARE
LEGISLATORS TO MAKE WORKERS
EXCLUDED FROM UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE A PRIORITY THIS YEAR
NOW IS THE TIME TO CREATE A
RESILIENT EQUITABLE ECONOMY.
THAT WORKS FOR EVERYONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HE GAVE
ME WHY IN TWO THREE. CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU- MY NAME IS MARIA AND
I'M WITH THE RUSSIAN OPPORTUNITY
CENTER SUMMER I'M ALSO RESIDENT
I'M WORKING CALIFORNIA AND I'M
CALLING TO OR CHIU AND DEMAND
THAT COULD BE THREE TAKE CARE OF
OUR DOCUMENTS ARE WORKERS AND
CREATE- A PROGRAM SIMILAR TO
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE STATE
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA-
AS AN ORGANIZER ON A PRISON
DOCUMENT TO WORK FOR MYSELF I'VE
SEEN AND- YOU KNOW FELT THE
STRUGGLE OF OUR WORKERS WHO HAVE
NOT HAD ACCESS TO ANY ACCOUNT.
TO BARELY ANY ECONOMIC HELP
THESE DAYS LAST YEAR THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC AND OTHER TRAGEDIES.
IN- IN OUR STATE. THREE THREE
THREE- THINK ABOUT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT BEFORE WE ON
TO THE CALLER I TO
ADDRESS THAT JUST VERY QUICKLY
IN BUDGET HEARINGS AND BUDGET
PROPOSALS THAT WE HAVE PASSED WE
HAVE INCREASED FUNDING FOR
CALLIE I T. C. AS WELL AS
FUNDING FOR OUTREACH FOR THE
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY TO BECOME
I TEND TAX PAYERS HAVING AN I.
TEN WILL ALLOW THE UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITY TO TAP INTO. RESOURCES
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS PUT
FORWARD SO WE HAVE EXPANDED
ACCESS TO I. TEN OUT REACH AS
WELL AS EXPANDED ACCESS TO
CALLIE AT C. WHICH IS AN ANSWER
NOT ALL THE ANSWER PUT APART
ANSWER THAT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
THAT- MUCH NECESSARY COMMUNITY
SO THANK YOU FOR THAT. WE CAN
MOVE ONTO THE NEXT CASE YOU'RE
RIGHT. THANK YOU I'M FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES PLEASE GO AHEAD
. OKAY GREAT- HI MEANS IN THREE
KM I'M NOT GONNA ANSWER WITH THE
RESTAURANT OPPORTUNITIES CENTER
I LIVE IN CALIFORNIA- AND I ALSO
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
PRIORITIZE UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS
IN THE NEXT PAYMENT CYCLE- I
KNOW WE'RE WORKING FOR- JIM
CREEK I TEN BUT WE OFTEN COULD
BE. YOU CAN FIND ACTUALLY
SUPPORT. BY RESTAURANT WORKERS
THEN. FARMWORKERS AND EVERYBODY
THAT'S BEEN AFFECTED DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND ALL FOR THE FIRE
THEN EVERYTHING CAN HAPPEN IN
THE FUTURE. YEAH PLEASE PLEASE
PLEASE. FOR THE SAKE OF HUMANITY
. WHAT THESE CRITICAL THANK YOU
. THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
KIMBERLY HERNANDEZ AND I'M WITH
I YEAH I WAS HE AND I AM- I'M A
RESIDENT AND WORK IN CALIFORNIA
AND I'M CALLING TO URGE
LEGISLATORS TO MAKE WORKERS
EXCLUDED FROM UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE UP OUR PRIORITIES THIS
YEAR- OF CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
UNEMPLOYED OR UNDER EMPLOYED
OVER THE PAST YEARS. WERE
ELIGIBLE FOR. TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS
DESPITE TAKING UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
MUCH HIGHER THAN THE AVERAGE
WORK COULD HAVE BEEN CHARACTER.
CATEGORICALLY EXCLUDED SO I'M
JUST- SAYING THAT NOW IS THE
TIME TO CREATE A RESILIENT AND
EQUITABLE ECONOMY THAT WORKS FOR
EVERYONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BRIAN I'M
WITH THE INLAND COALITION FOR
IMMIGRANT JUSTICE- OUT HERE IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AND I AM A RESIDENT
OF CALIFORNIA AND I LIKE TO JOIN
US THE PREVIOUS- CALLERS AS WELL
AS CALLING FOR. LEGISLATORS TO
MAKE WORKERS THAT ARE EXCLUDED
FROM UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE A
PRIORITY HERE. WE KNOW THAT
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS PAY- WELL
INTO THE BILLIONS STATE TAXES
THAT PAPER TOTAL SERVICES THAT
THEY HAVE NO ACCESS TO HIGH
INCLUDING UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE- AND I BELIEVE NOW THE
TIME. TO YOU KNOW ADDRESS IT
BLATANT INJUSTICE AND I THINK
THAT THAT THE LEGISLATIVE REMEDY. THAT AS SOON AS POSSIBLE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WHEN I SPENT OF THE
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU KNOW BUT IT'S BENEFIT THAT
I'M GOING TO JUMP AT THE MYSTIC
ONE BOTANICAL SECOND THAT HE
SAID THAT HE DID BECOME A CODE
IN CALIFORNIA I WILL GET MY LOOK
AT THE THAT LOOKED LIKE HE
SETTLED IT BACK I SAID WELL
ACTUALLY IT I'M GOING TO TALK
ABOUT IF IT'S GREEN THOSE THAT
THEY TO SIMPLY LOOK DOWN ON MY
FIELD. THE THAT IS THE MCALLEN
OF COLLUDED IN PLASTIC IDEA BUT
OF THE AT A COUPLE TO LEGAL BUT
MY OF LOOKS QUITE AS CRITICAL TO
GET ON THE AND BATTLES FALLS
BEEN GATHERED THAT THERE ARE
STYLE. WOMEN THAT HE LEFT OF IF
YOU THE SAME OF THE MIDDLE OF
THE LETTER DIMINISHED TO THE AT
WHAT OTHERS HAVE I'LL A. SET
BODIES THAT MOST OF A COUPLE IN
THE- OF THE SENATE THAT STAFF
THAT THIS IS A BLOW OF MY I GOD
THAT OUR CALLS COME CAMANCHE
IOWA. I'M VIDAK AT THE WOULD
COME INTO IT BECAUSE LEGAL LIST
ANY MORE I THE SAN LEVEL BACK AT
. IT'S COOLEY MUCH THE REST.
HERE YOU AND I UNDERSTAND YOUR
CONCERNS THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. YOU'RE RIGHT EIGHTY
EIGHT PRESCHOOL I HAD. BUT NOT
NUMBER IS NOT AVAILABLE ARE YOU
GOING TO SEND THE LETTER BECAUSE
OF BARBARA HUBBARD GOOGLE THEY
GOT. ARRESTED IN ST ABOUT UNTIL
PROBABLY. I WON'T GET MY THE
SEATTLE DEVIL THAT THAT WOULDN'T
OF WHAT I AT HAVE A POLITICS
THAT IN THE BIGELOW IT IS SIMPLY
OUTSTANDING UP OF THE IS MY
MENTALITY NOW SECOND CANNELLA
TELECOM TO. GET A MUCH BETTER IT
BECAUSE BILL DEVELOPMENT
DEFENDER TALK IT. AND EXCELLING
IN WITH BLACK PEOPLE STRUCTURE
OF A HOLIDAY THANK YOU TO FROM
MEMBER COMPOSED. A LOT FROM THAT
IS CREDIT BUT STARTED PULLING WE
W. I'M NEGATIVE A LOT OF COMING
YEAR HE GLOBAL EITHER OF THE
PLATFORM IMPALE AT THE POINT AT
THE FACT THAT I'VE BEEN MENTAL
LADING OF THE MEDIA. GET GIVE IT
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW IT OKAY
THE FACT WE'VE BEEN BEATING UP
ON MEDIA LUCK NEED OTHER PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT ACTIVE. THANK
YOU TAKE A MOMENT TO TRANSLATE
TAG ASSETS IN EUROPE THE GUY
APALA YOUR MOTHER THAT WAS A
MISTAKE I WHO IS A WAREHOUSE
WORKER AND SHE'S CALLING TO
INSURE THAT EXCLUDED.
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS AND THOSE
WHO PAY INTO OUR SYSTEM AND ARE
NOT INCLUDED IN EDT BENEFITS ARE
PRIORITIZE A NOT INCLUDED IN
THAT NOT EXCLUDED AND THAT
INCLUDES. FRIENDS AND PARENTS
AND PARENTS OF CITIZEN CHILDREN
WHO SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO
BENEFITS THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. YOUR MIND EIGHTY FOUR
BEFORE HAD. RIGHT EIGHT FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MAY HAVE YOUR
LINE ON MUTE. WIDE FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHE HI THIS IS
KATHY BURKE WITH THE HELP OF A
THIRD WITH A PEACENIK CALIFORNIA
HAS THE FLEXIBILITY TO THE
HEARING TODAY I WANNA LET YOU
KNOW THAT WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL FOR LOCALHEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AT STATE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH
IS OVERWHELMINGLY WORKFORCE. AND
WE ALSO HAVE A PACKAGE SUBMITTED
TO THE LEGISLATURE FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO PRIME THE
PUMP FOR A DEAD PERSON LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE OF THE
FUTURE WE NEED THAT BECAUSE
SIXTY LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT
LEADERS AND HEALTH OFFICERS HAVE
LEFT THEIR POSITIONS DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND A LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS HAVE OVER TWO
HUNDRED VACANCIES FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSES. AND TODAY HE SENT
YOU A LETTER WITH A CALIFORNIA
CAN'T WAIT PROPOSAL WHICH
OUTLINES MOSTLY ONE TIME FUNDS
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE
RETENTION OF SKILLED TRAINING
AND EXPANDING EXISTING
FELLOWSHIP AN OPPORTUNITY
PROGRAMS AND. WE HOPE YOU WILL
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE YOUR RIGHT
. THANK YOU I'M THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR CHRIS BOLGER ON BEHALF OF
THE COALITION FOR ETP IN JOBS MY
COMMENTS ARE IN RELATION TO THE-EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL THE
PROPOSED INCREASES WITHOUT LINE
ISSUES THREE AND FOUR ON THE
AGENDA. OUR COALITION SUPPORTS
JOB TRAINING APPRENTICESHIPS AND
CAREER ADVANCEMENT FOR LABOR
BUSINESSES IN EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS WE HAVE DOZENS OF
ORGANIZATIONS SIGNED ON IN
SUPPORT OF OUR EFFORT WHICH YOU
CAN HE HIGHLIGHTED IN OUR LETTER
TO THE COMMITTEE. EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PANEL OF THE PREEMINENT
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM IN
THE STATE WE APPLAUD THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE PROGRAM THAT
SAID OUR POSITION IS THAT MORE
FLEXIBILITY IS REQUIRED FOR THE
NEW MONEY. WE ADVOCATE FOR AT
LEAST FIFTY OF THE HUNDRED AND
TEN MILLION BE OPEN AND
AVAILABLE TO ANY INDUSTRY OR
SECTOR CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE FOR
ETP. GIVEN THE TREMENDOUS DEMAND
IN BACKLOG WE THINK THAT
FLEXIBILITY WOULD PROVIDE FOR
THE MOST EFFICIENT. OUTCOMES
POSSIBLE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
BYE MODEL FOR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GIVE ME
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M ERIN
EVENT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NURSE MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION. NURSE MIDWIVES WORK
TO PROVIDE MATERNITY CARE TO
WOMEN STATEWIDE AND URBAN AND
RURAL AREAS IN HOSPITALS AND
BIRTH CENTERS. CMMS ISSUE THREE
FUNDING FOR THE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE WE REQUEST ONE MILLION
DOLLARS OVER FIVE YEARS BE USED
TO EXPAND THE FONG BROWN
PROGRAMS TO IMPLEMENT THE WHAT
MADE BY FOR YOU WORKFORCE
TRAINING ACT. THE PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED BY LAST YEAR SB
SIXTY FIVE THE MONOMETHYL. THIS
LIMITED FUNDING WILL HELP BRING
HEALTHCARE TO MATERNITY DESERT
AROUND THE STATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM THREE ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES GOOD EVENING. ROBERT
MCKEE FOR THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE- BURKE BUT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR ALL YOUR
EDT AND IMPROVING THE STATE'S
PERFORMANCE IN THE FUTURE ON
BEHALF THE EMPLOYER COMMUNITY I
DON'T LIKE EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR ONE
BILLION THIS YEAR AND TWO
BILLION NEXT YEAR ADDS MONEY
DIRECTLY TO THE U. Y. FUND. THE
SMALL AMOUNT RELATIVE TO THE
SIZE OF THE INSOLVENCY- IT IS
DEEPLY APPRECIATE EMPLOYER
COMMUNITY AS A BEGINNING TO KIND
OF REDUCE THE INCOMING TAX
INCREASES THAT WE WILL STARTING
NEXT YEAR AND MAY DETECT TAKES
TEN YEARS. I ALSO LIKE THE FACT
THAT THERE BY L. A- AND SIGN IN
WITH THE THIS IS BENEFICIAL
INVESTMENT FOR THE STATE AS WELL
GIVEN THAT PAYMENT WILL HELP
REDUCE FUTURE INTEREST. PAYMENTS
FOR THE STATE. I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PERFECT GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS KAYLA TRADING ON BEHALF
OF THE VALLEY INDUSTRY AND
COMMERCE ASSOCIATION CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED THREE BILLION DOLLARS
TO HELP THE U. I. IT FUND
INSOLVENCY WITH ONE BILLION IN
THIS YEAR'S. BUDGET THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU I'M THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GREAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR TIME SHE
HE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LANDSCAPE CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION THAT WERE- PETRIFIED
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO PAY DOWN
THE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE FUND
DEFICIT TO THE ONE BILLION THIS
YEAR TWO BILLION NEXT YEAR. END
UP IF THE REVENUES CONTINUE TO
CUT THE HIGHER THAN ESTIMATED WE
WOULD URGE YOU AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES TO CONSIDER
ACCELERATING THE TWO BILLION
DOLLARS THE GOVERNOR HAS TALKED
ABOUT FOR NEXT YEAR AND PUT INTO
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET IT'LL NOT
ONLY HELP THE STATE BUT WILL
HELP. MANY MANY SMALL EMPLOYERS
WHO ARE IN YOUR DISTRICTS- WE
APPRECIATE ANYTHING YOU CAN DO
ON THIS ISSUE WHAT'S GOING TO
AFFECT ALL HUNDRED TWENTY
LEGISLATIVE DISTRICTS IN ALL THE
EMPLOYERS HAVE TO PAY PAYROLL
TAXES THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU I'M FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI BRIDGET MY DOWN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STAFFING PROFESSIONALS IN THE
AMERICAN STAFFING ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S THREE BILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL TO HELP PAY DOWN THAT
YOU OF YOU I FIND THAT. THANK
YOU. YOU'RE RIGHT EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON-
THIS BRIGHT LITTLE CALLING FROM
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED THREE
BILLION DOLLARSTO HELP FREE THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE TRUST
FUND INSOLVENCY WITH THE BILLION
DOLLARS IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
I'D LIKE TO ALSO NOTE THAT SOME
OF YOUR COLLEAGUES IN A RECENT
LETTER TEACHER TANG HAVE
ADVOCATED FOR SEVEN AND A
QUARTER BILLION DOLLARS FOR THAT
PURPOSE- THAT WOULD HAVE THE
EFFECT OF NOT ONLY REDUCING THE
U. I TRUST FUND DEFICIT BUT ALSO
WOULD HAVE THE EFFECT OF
REDUCING. THE FISCAL IMPACT ON
THE GENERAL FUND AS THE GENERAL
FUND PAYS FOR THE INTEREST
ASSOCIATED WITH ISSUE I TRUST
FUND DEFICIT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU RIGHT NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR- DAVE BUTLER ON
BEHALF OF UNITED CHAMBER
ADVOCACY NETWORK A COLLECTION OF
THE SEVEN LOCAL CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE AND THE GREATER
SACRAMENTO REGION REPRESENTING.
OVER FIVE THOUSAND EMPLOYERS
WERE ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S A ONE BILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSED ALLOCATE-
ALLOCATION TO UNDERWRITE THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE. FUND
DEFICIT- WE SURVEY OUR MEMBERS
EACH AND EVERY YEAR AND-
CALIFORNIA'S TAX RATE IS THEIR
NUMBER ONE CONCERN AND AS YOU
KNOW- AS LONG AS THIS- DEFICIT
IS NOT PAID IT WILL RESULT IN-
HIRED. EMPLOYMENT TRENDS TAXES
FOR ALL EMPLOYERS PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE IN THE STATE SO WE
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO
PLEASE CONSIDER. ADDITIONAL
AMOUNT. TO UNDERWRITE THIS ONE
PARTICULARLY IF- SURPLUSES ARE
HOLDERS PAY AS THEY HAVE BEEN
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU APPLIED ONE A ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I CAN AFTERNOON
CHAIR NUMBER. THEN WITH GRACE
AND CAL POLY CALIFORNIA AND
COLLEAGUES URGE PARTICIPATION OF
FUNDING FR WORKERS CURRENTLY
EXCLUDED FROM THE UNEMPLOYMENT
SYSTEM AND YOU KNOW JUST
RECOGNIZING- THAT DEPEND ON THE
CAR HEAVILY ON THE BODY FROM
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND RECOGNIZE THAT
UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE BATES SENATE
GUARDIANS OF UNEMPLOYMENT
ANOTHER APPOINTMENT I THINK YOUR
QUESTION IT MAY HISTORICALLY
HAVE EXCLUDED THEM FROM THE-
EIGHTEEN THAT. THAT WE HAVE ON A
DOCUMENT COULD. BENEFIT FROM. WE
ARE- THE MATCHMAKER CARE ACT
AMOUNTS. TO CREATE A RESERVE AND
QUITE. AND COME. THAT WORKS FOR
EVERYONE THANK YOU MUCH TAKEN.
LONG TERM. THANK YOU RIGHT SIXTY
THREE PER GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
YOU HEAR ME OK. YES PLEASE CALL
. HI GOOD AFTERNOON AUDIBLE THE
CHECKOUT HERE AND WHAT WOULD BE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS PRESENT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE THANKS MY NAME IS THAT
THIRTIES AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER CALLING
TO SUPPORT THE PROPOSED TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
AND WORKFORCE INVESTMENT AS
OUTLINED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET TO SUPPORT IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY MEMBERS ACROSS THE
STATE SOME OF THAT YOU HEARD OF
OUR GREAT STATE SUCH AS THE-
CALIFORNIA YOUTH LEADERSHIP
CORPS PROGRAM. FURTHERMORE THE
MEMBER OF THE STATE IN THE FOR
ALL COLLECTION WE CALL ON THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE WORKERS
EXCLUDED FROM UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE A PRIORITY HERE BUT
FUNDING AND EXCLUDE WORKERS
PROGRAM. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
FIFTY. PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRMAN
HONORABLE MEMBERS MY NAME IS DEV
BEAN SHARMA I'M THE DIRECTOR
LABOR RELATIONS AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AT THE PORT OF LOS
ANGELES. I'M CALLING IN REGARDS
TO THE GOOD TO BE THE TRAINING
CAMPUS CONSTRUCTION OF THE
CAMPUS WILL HELP TO SUPPORT THE
ENTIRE GOODS MOVING INDUSTRY
TOWARDS BETTER AND INCREASED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR TRAINING AND
REMOVING BARRIERS TO ENTRY FOR
THOSE INTERESTED IN CAREERS GETS
MOVEMENT WHEN COMPLETED THIS
WOULD BE THE NATION'S FIRST
TRAINING CAMPUS DEDICATED TO THE
INDUSTRY. AND LIKE A COLLEGE
CAMPUS THAT TEACHES DIFFERENT
DISCIPLINES THIS CAMPUS WILL
TRAIN IN DIFFERENT OCCUPATIONS
SUCH AS LONG SHORT TRUCKING AND
WAREHOUSING AS YOU HEARD EARLIER
THERE IS A CAPACITY ISSUE AS NOT
HAVING ENOUGH SPACE AND SO LONG
SHORT LIMITED TO THE NUMBER OF
EQUIPMENT THEY CAN USE TO TRAIN.
AND FOR TRACKING THE TRAINING
CHALLENGES ARE FRONT PAGE NEWS
DALY IN DESIGNING AND WORKING TO
DEVELOP THIS CAMPUS WE'VE ENGAGE
WITH KEY EMPLOYERS AND- OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS THE L. W.
THE TEAMSTERS AND WE'RE ALSO
WORKING WITH ORGANIZATION TO
LEARN BEST PRACTICES SUCH AS THE
OUTSTANDING WORK BEING DONE BY
THE WAREHOUSE WORKERS RESOURCE
CENTER- IN TERMS OF THE CURRENT
SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES THAT WE'RE
DEALING TODAY I'M TOO FAMILIAR
WITH THAT MY ROLE AT THE PORT
AND I'LL SAY THAT WHEN THE
CAMPUS IS COMPLETE. WE ARE GOING
TO BRING TO A DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
THAT WE ARE CURRENTLY DEVELOPING
AS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER WE HAVE
PASSED ONE OF THE STATE'S FIRST
TIRO TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS THAT
PROGRAM WILL GO INTO THIS- THE
CAMPUS LATER THIS YEAR WE WHAT
WE ARE COMMENCING A RESKILLING
AND UPSKILLING PROGRAM THAT ALSO
GOING TO THE CAMPUS. IN YOU KNOW
LASTLY WHEN I TOWARDS THE FUTURE
THE CAMPUS IS DESIGNED TO
INCLUDE ELECTRIC INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR THE USE OF THE TECHNOLOGY
ALL TOO OFTEN BUT TECHNOLOGY
ADVANCES WORKERS ARE LEFT BEHIND
WITH THE CLAIMS THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE THE NECESSARY SKILLS FOR
MORE ADVANCED TECHNOLOGIES OR
THAT EMPLOYERS CAN'T AFFORD TO
TRAIN THEM WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT AS WE TRANSITION TO ZERO
EMISSION HUMAN OPERATED CARGO
HANDLING EQUIPMENT THIS CAMPUS
WILL MAKE SURE THAT THE GOODS
MOVEMENT WORKFORCE IS NOT LEFT
BEHIND. AND ALSO ABLE TO LEARN
THE SKILLS ON HOW. TO OPERATE
THAT EQUIPMENT. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU RYAN SIXTY.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS EARLY DECEMBER C.
WITH CALIFORNIA GROCERS
ASSOCIATION IN SOME SUPPORT FOR
THE GOVERNMENT'S PROPOSAL TO PAY
DOWN DO YOU I FUND INSOLVENCY
INSOLVENCY AND REDUCE THE FUTURE
TAX INCREASES FOR THE GROCERY
INDUSTRY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD STE. HI MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
DILUTION HERE TESTIFYING ON
BEHALF OF CHARLES R. DREW
UNIVERSITY OF MEDICINE AND
SCIENCE CHARLES R. DREW
UNIVERSITY MADISON TRYING TO BE
ONLY OCT STORK BLACK UNIVERSITY.
OF LEICESTER TEXAS OBVIOUSLY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA- WE ARE
CALLING IN AND TESTIFYING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF HE
GOVERNOR'S. OUT ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLAR HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE- PROPOSAL WE DO
BELIEVE THAT IT WILL BE OF VALUE
ADD I THINK THE ONE THING THAT
WE'RE A LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT
RELATING TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL. IS THAT IT DOESN'T
FOCUS ENOUGH ON EQUITY IN THE
SENSE THAT WE BELIEVE THAT A
SUBSTANTIAL PORTION OF THIS ONE
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
REALLY SHOULD BE SET ASIDE FOR
INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE A STRONG
TRACK RECORD OF- BASICALLY
ADMITTING AND GRADUATING. ARE
UNDER REPRESENTED GROUPS INTO
THE HEALTHCARE PROFESSION I
THINK THE WAY THAT IT'S
STRUCTURED- THROUGH THE LABOR
AND WORKFORCE AGENCY IS A LITTLE
BIT UNIQUE- GIVEN THE FACT THAT
MUCH OF MUCH HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE TRAINING REALLY
HAPPENED AT THE- COMMUNITY
COLLEGE- AND- UNIVERSITY LEVELS
ON BOTH THE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SECTORS AND SO- WE'RE ASKING
THAT AN EQUITY LENS REALLY BE
PLACED. ON THE DISTRIBUTION OF
THESE DOLLARS AT LEAST A PORTION
OF THEM AND- LOOK FORWARD TO-
COMMUNICATING MORE. DETAILS
ABOUT HOW THAT CAN BE DONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ONE OF. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
MEMBERS KATIE HANSEN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION. RESTAURANT CLOSURES
IN COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH ORDERS
DURING THE PANDEMIC DRAMATICALLY
IMPACTED OUR STOCK LEVELS.
BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF
RESTAURANT WORK WE ARE CENTRAL
JOB CREATORS OUT COMMUNITIES
WILL BE DIRECTLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
THREE POINT FIVE HUNDRED
PHARMACY. THAT'S WHY WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO ONE BILLION DOLLARS
THIS YEAR INTERMINGLING DOLLARS
NEXT YEAR TO HELP PAY DOWN YOU
I. FUND INSOLVENCY. BOB
HERTZBERG D. FUTURE LARA WHITE.
FOR TWO. RESTAURANT DURING A
TIME WHEN THEY ARE STILL
RECOVERING FROM THE FINANCIAL
IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIDE ONE OH EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MANY HELLO I'M
CALLING FROM AN ORGANIZATION
BECAUSE I DO WAY SEE AND I'M A
RESIDENT AT WORK OR IN
CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING TO URGE
LEGISLATORS TO MAKE WORKERS
EXCLUDED FROM UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE A PRIORITY THIS YEAR
WE WANT TO URGE YOU TO PROTEGER
FUNDING WILL BE EXCLUDED WORKERS. TO PLEDGES PLATED SESSION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONE ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIRMAN BURKE CHRISTOPHER
SANTIAGO POLICY ADVOCATE WITH
COLLECTIONS AND ALONG POVERTY
BACK WHEN ALL THE COMMENTS MADE
BY MY COLLEAGUES ON OUR
REGARDING EXCLUDED WORKERS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND BAY
WITHOUT THAT THE CONSERVATIVES
AND YOU FIND THAT WHERE
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT AND I'M
CALLING TO URGE LEGISLATORS
LEGISLATORS TO WORK TO MAKE-
WORKERS EXCLUDED FROM YOUR HIGH
PRIORITY THIS YEAR UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS- DESPITE FACING HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE. STARTS WITH
ECHO FROM THE NON MANY OF THE
WORKERS EARN IN THAT HEIGHTEN
REST OF COMPANIES BUT I'M SURE
AND FOUND HAVING TO CHOOSE.
BASIC SECURITY AND HEALTH AND
SAFETY BLACK TWO YEARS WE HOPE
YOU'LL WITH THAT THE BILL
TOMORROW- ACTIVE ECONOMY THAT
PROTECT OUR HEALTH WORKERS- AND
BY SUPPORTING. YOU I EXPANSION.
FOR THE COMMUNITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIDER TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS MARLON CHAVEZ I'M A RESIDENT
OF CALIFORNIA AND PART OF THE
INLAND EMPIRE ARE YOU COLLECTED
I'M CALLING YOU TO PLEASE-
PREDATORS FUNDING FOR EXCLUDE
WORKERS LEGISLATIVE SESSION- BY
CREATING AN UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE PROGRAM FOR
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONE. MOMENT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BUDGET CREAN MEMBERS
MARKET BEGAN BEHALF WITHIN OUR
NATIONAL LONG SHOT WHERE YOU GO
THIRTEEN THREE NINETY POINT
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNMENT'S ALLOCATION OF THAT
ONE MILLION TEN MILLION FOR THE
GOOD MOVEMENT TRAINING PARENTS
AND PICO. BOB WHAT IT WOULD BE
AN ESSENTIAL THEY CAN'T GOOD
MORNING- KEPT OUR STORE SHELF
STOCK DURING THE PANDEMIC I KEPT
MOVING P. P. ARE THEY ONE DAY
HOME THE JOB TRAINING CENTER IS
NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT- THAT YOU
RECEIVE THE PROPER TRAINING AT A
NEW TECHNOLOGY I INTRODUCED. AND
TRAINING CENTER NEED AT
CURRENTLY YOU HAVE WORKERS TRAIN
AT DIFFERENT TERMINOLOGY.
DIFFERENT MODEL AND THAT KIND
CUTTING CONFUSION- THAT FUNDING
IS NEEDED AND. WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIDE FOR NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ON THE POLICE COMING UP
IN THE BLUEGREEN ALLIANCE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY OFFER
COMMENTS ON ISSUE TWO OF THE NON
DISCUSSION ITEMS REGARDING
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY
IMPLEMENTATION. BLUEGREEN
ALLIANCE IS AN ALLIANCE OF MAJOR
COMPANIES UNIONS AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS
WORKING FOR LOW CARBON AT GLOBAL
ECONOMY EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY
REPRESENTS PROGRESSIVE EXCEPT
INSURING I WILL TRANSITION TO A
CLEAN ECONOMY THAT SUPPORT GOOD
JOBS FOR DISADVANTAGED
CALIFORNIANS IN EQUITY POOR
COMMUNITIES WHERE CRIME
INVESTMENTS TAKE PLACE. IT IS
ESSENTIAL THAT THE STATE FUND
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF WORKFORCE
STANDARDS INCLUSIVE PROCUREMENT
ON CLIMATE SPENDING
IMPLEMENTATION OF BABY SIX
EIGHTY WILL ENSURE THAT CLIMATE
INVESTMENTS PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY
JOBS CALIFORNIANS WHO NEED THEM
WE CAN ADVANCE ON THIS MISSION.
WITHOUT A COMMITMENT TO
IMPLEMENTATION. THE REQUESTED
TIME TO BE APPROVED. BY THE L.
UP. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU OPERATOR
AND I WANT TO THANK ALL OUR
PANELISTS TODAY FOR
PARTICIPATING AND EVERYONE WHO
DIALED IN FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AS
WELL AS OUR- INCREDIBLE BUDGET
STAFFING MY STAFF FOR ALL THE
SUPPORT AND FORD AT THIS HEARING
WHICH WAS. QUITE IMPORTANT LOTS
OF VERY IMPORTANT ISSUES AND
WITH THAT WE WILL ADJOURN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.